>> WHAT UP, AND WELCOME TO THE
MLB GAME OF THE WEEK PREGAME
SHOW PRESENTED BY STATE FARM.
BAY AREA JUST STUNNING ON US
RIGHT NOW.
GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE AND ORACLE
PARK, THE SITE OF THE MLB GAME
OF THE WEEK, LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
MILWAUKEE BREWERS AND SAN
FRANCISCO GIANTS FINISHING UP A
FOUR-GAME SERIES.
CREW GETTING LOOSE.
THEY IMPROVED TO 82-52.
FOURTH STRAIGHT LOSS TIES A
SEASON-HIGH.
BILL RIPKEN AND STEPHEN NELSON
IN SECAUCUS.
BILL: WE REALLY GOOD.
STEPHEN: ORACLE PARK IS IN MY
TOP FIVE.
IT IS A GREAT DAY FOR A BALLGAME
AND A GREAT DAY TO TURN THINGS
AROUND IF YOU ARE A FAN OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS.
GREAT SEASON, TO BE SURE, BUT
THEY WAKE UP FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN A LONG TIME AND NOT IN
FIRST-PLACE NY NOT BECAUSE OF
ANYTHING THEY HAVE DONE WRONG.
DODGERS ARE JUST BEHIND THEM.
BILL: THAT IS THE PROBLEM FACING
THE NL WEST RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNEW GOING INTO THE DODGERS
HAVE A TALENTED ROSTER.
THEY GOT MAD MAX AND TREA TURNER
AT THE TRADE DEADLINE JUST TO
HELP THEM OUT.
I LOOKED AT THIS RACE SIMPLY IS
THIS -- IF SAN FRANCISCO DOESN'T
WIN THE DIVISION, IT MIGHT NOT
BE BECAUSE OF, SHALL WE SAY, A
COLLAPSE OR THEY HAVE FALTERED.
THE DODGERS ARE JUST GOOD.
THEY HAVE 30 GAMES TO PLAY AND
TIME TO GET IT DONE, AND TODAY
WILL BE THE START OF THAT.
YOU HAVE GOT TO WIN TODAY TO
MAKE UP THE GROUND AGAIN AGAINST
THE DODGERS.
STEPHEN: DODGERS ARE COMING TO
TOWN FOR A SERIES THIS WEEKEND
BUT THEY ARE DEALING WITH
ANOTHER BUZZ SAW IN THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE.
WE WILL SHOW YOU THE HIGHLIGHTS
FROM LAST NIGHT.
>> NOW LORENZO CAIN, BASES
LOADED.
IT'S GOT -- PITCH, LINE DRIVE
BASE HIT.
THE THROW FROM BRYANT OFF-LINE.
2-0, MILWAUKEE.
>> TIE GAME, SOME OF THE
INNING---SEVENTH INNING.
PETERSON INTO LEFT FIELD.
CAIN SCORES.
>> CAIN RIPS ONE TOWARDS LEFT.
BACK AT THE WARNING TRACK.
TOP OF THE FENCE.
DID IT STAY IN PLAY?
>> HOME RUN.
LORENZO CAIN WILL CIRCLE THEM.
STEPHEN: WHAT HAVE THE BREWERS
SHOWING YOU IN THIS SERIES
AGAINST THE GIANTS?
WE TALK ABOUT THE STAFF ALL YEAR
AND WE WILL VISIT WITH A MEMBER
OF THE PITCHING STAFF A LITTLE
BIT, BUT LO-CAIN GETTING GOING,
CHRISTIAN YELICH GETTING GOING.
WHAT IS IT SHOWING YOU?
BILL: I THINK FOR THE MOST PART,
WHEN YOU SAW THE RECORD, 82-52,
30 GAMES OVER .500, I'M NOT SURE
WE THOUGHT THEY WERE GOING TO BE
THIS GOOD, BUT THEY HAVE SHOWN
ME -- YOU TALKED ABOUT THE BUMP.
THAT IS THE FIRST THING THAT
JUMPS OUT AT ME.
STARTERS ARE NASTY, BULLPENS
MIGHT BE NASTIER, IF THAT IS
POSSIBLE.
BOYS GETTING GOING OFFENSIVELY,
YOU WILL NEED TO ETCH A FEW RUNS
OUT.
I THINK THEY HAVE A SITUATION IN
HAND WHERE THEY CAN COAST INTO
THE POSTSEASON.
STEPHEN: IT WILL BE ERIC LAUER
FOR THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, YOU HAVE
LOGAN WEBB, PERHAPS THE HOTTEST
PITCHER ON THE PLANET RIGHT NOW,
AND YOU WANT TO DIVE IN A LITTLE
BIT, AND THAT BRINGS US TO HOW
TO.
GO ONLINE, THE OLD YOUTUBE.COM
-- HOW TO MAKE A SIMPLE
ADJUSTMENT.
HOW HAS WEBB DONE THAT?
BILL: I THINK HE HAS CHANGE THE
GRIP ON THE FASTBALL A LITTLE
BIT.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU THE TWO-SEAM
FASTBALL AND WE CAN EXPLAIN
LATER.
HE HAS THE ABILITY TO THIRD THAT
SIDE OF THE PLATE, MAKE HIM
VERY, VERY NASTY.
THE BREAKING BALL ALSO HAS
BECOME THIS TWO-SEAMER SANK
ER-SLIDER GUYS, WE USED TO CALL
THEM IN THE DAY.
THE SLIDER ISRAEL.
YOU CAN INTO THE MIDDLE AND ONE
GOES THIS WAY AND ONE GOES THIS
WAY.
IT'S ALL GOOD.
I WANT TO LOOK AT THIS AT-BAT.
CHAPMAN.
THIS IS WHAT SANK-OR-SLIDER GUY
CAN DO.
LOOK AT THE MISERY HE IS IN.
THE PAIN THAT HE IS IN.
NOW HE'S GOT TO GO BACK INTO THE
BATTER'S BOX AND GO, I DON'T
WANT TO GO IN THERE.
THEN HE HAS THIS ARSENAL BECAUSE
YOU DON'T WANT TO FILE ANOTHER
BALL OF HIS FOOT.
THAT IS A THREE-PITCH ORDEAL.
YAN GOMES COMES UP LATER IN THE
GAME.
AFTER HITTING THAT PART OF THE
PLATE AND HE WILL FOLLOW THE
SAME TRACK WITH THE SPLIT CHANGE
AT 86.
PASSED BALL, CHANGEUP, SLIDE
PIECE RIGHT HERE.
SEE YOU LATER.
IT GOT ME THINKING ABOUT THIS
GUY BACK IN THE DAY.
THERE IS THE OUTSIDE PART OF THE
PLATE, THE TWO SEEM COME BACK
FASTBALL.
SANK-ORSLIDE THAT THIS MAN HAD
AND THE WILLINGNESS TO GO TO
PETE WAS PRETTY REAL.
THE BREAKING BALL IS FILTHY.
AND WE PUT THEM SIDE-BY-SIDE --
FREEZE THIS FOR ME -- WHEN I GET
THIS GLOVE UP FULLY INTO THE
POSITION, I WANT YOU TO FREEZE
IT AGAIN.
GET THE HAND UP IN THERE.
KEEP GOING.
FREEZE.
BOTH GUYS ARE ALMOST IDENTICAL
IN THAT MODE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT NECESSARILY
DOES TO THE HITTER RIGHT HERE,
BUT IT IS SOMETHING ABOUT
THROWING THAT GLOVE UP THERE
FIRST, AND THEN IT IS GOING TO
GET OUT OF THE WAY.
LOOK AT THESE TWO-SEAM FASTBALL
IS ON THE OUTSIDE PART OF THE
PLATE THAT ARE ALMOST IDENTICAL
AS THEY GO, AND THEN WE WILL DO
THE BREAKING BALL.
FREEZE IT AGAIN ON THE SAME
POINT OUT THERE WHEN THE GLOVE
GETS HIGH.
THAT IS PRETTY GOOD RIGHT THERE.
LOOK AT THIS.
IT'S ALMOST IDENTICAL WHAT YOU
DO.
BOTH GUYS ALSO PITCH FROM THE
FIRST BASE SIDE OF THE RUBBER.
WHAT THAT DOES, THAT TELLS ME
WHEN THE GUY IS DOING THAT, THIS
SIDE OF THE PLATE IS HIS
BREAD-AND-BUTTER.
THE TWO-SEAM FASTBALL AND THE
BREAKING BALL CAN COME JUST PLAY
IT FORWARD, PLEASE.
BUT THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
DO.
FASTBALL, SLIDER, FASTBALL,
SLIDER.
ALMOST LIKE YOU ARE GOING DOWN
THE MIDDLE OF THE PLATE.
WE TALK ABOUT MAKING SIMPLE
ADJUSTMENTS.
LOOK AT THE FASTBALL THE LOGAN
WEBB THREW IN 2020.
STEPHEN: HEY NOW.
BILL: LOOK AT THE SANKER.
SLIDER USAGE IS UP.
EVEN THOUGH THE CHANGEUP IS A
NICE WEAPON, AND IT WAS A LITTLE
SPLIT CHANGE I SAW WHEN YAN
GOMES, WHEN WE SLOWED DOWN AND
LOOKED AT IT, SANKER-SLIDER, ONE
IS COMING IN AND ONE IS GOING
AWAY, THIS DUDE AT HOME PLATE,
ESPECIALLY RIGHT-HANDERS, IT'S
AMAZING.
THE FOUR-SEAM FASTBALL, THE HOW
TO THING -- IF WE CAN GET IN
HERE, FOUR-SEEM FASTBALL IS
EXACTLY THAT.
THAT IS A FOUR-SEAM FASTBALL.
WHAT THAT IS DESIGNED TO DO IS
BASICALLY SPIN THIS WAY AND IT
GOES FROM  POINT A TO POINT B.
IF THEY ARE THREE-QUARTER GUYS
WHO THROW FROM HERE, IF YOU ARE
LETTING THIS THING GO, THESE
SEAMS RIGHT HERE FIND A WAY TO
FIGHT AGAINST THE WIND.
THAT IS THE SANKER RIGHT THERE.
ONE SIMPLE ADJUSTMENT, FOUR-SEAM
FASTBALL SOMETIMES FROM HERE HAS
A TENDENCY TO FLATTEN OUT,
ESPECIALLY WITH THE EXTRA
GIDDYUP AT THE END.
TO GET THAT RISE, GET THAT LIFT,
AND THAT WORKS, BUT THE
TWO-SEAMER, BOTH OF GUYS HAVE
IT.
STEPHEN: FOR THE UNINITIATED,
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
SINKER AND A SANKER?
BILL: SANKER IS THE LOOK THAT
CHAPMAN GAVE.
I FACED GUYS LIKE BILLY SMITH,
KEVIN BROWN, SCOTT ERICKSON.
I KNEW WHAT THAT WAS LIKE.
WHEN THAT SANKER'S COMING DOWN
IN ON YOU, THERE IS THREE THINGS
THAT CAN HAPPEN IF YOU ARE THE
HITTER.
ONE, YOU CAN HIT IT HARD, BUT IT
GOES IN THE DUGOUT.
NOW IT IS 0-1.
TWO, YOU KEEP IT FAIR AND YOU
HIT THIS HIGH OVER YOUR KNUCKLES
AND YOU BREAK YOUR BAT.
OR THREE, YOU CALL THE TOW
TRUCK.
THAT BALL IS GOING DOWN ON THE
FOOT --
STEPHEN: ALL THREE STINK.
BILL: NONE OF THEM ARE GOOD.
THAT IS A SANKER. STEPHEN: LOGAN
WEBB, HIS LAST 13 TRENDS HAVE
BEEN TERRIFIC.
GIANTS HAVE WON 12 OF 13.
THEY NEED A WIN TODAY.
THAT TAKES US TO OUR GAME OF THE
WEEK POLL, PRESENTED BY STATE
FARM.
WHO WILL WIN TODAY, WEBB AND THE
GIANTS OR ERIC LAUER AND THE
MILWAUKEE BREWERS?
WHEN WE COME BACK, CORBIN BURNEE
SIXTH OF AUGUST, WE WILL TALK
HIM, AND AMY G AS WELL.
>> THERE IS A BASE HIT.
SLAPS ONE TO LEFT.
AQUINO IS THROWN TO THE PLATE.
CAIN IS IN THERE.
R.B.I. SINGLE.
KOLTEN WONG.
4-2, CINCINNATI.
WONG SENDS IT DEEP TO RIGHT, AND
SHE IS GONE.
KOLTEN WONG.
TWO-RUN HOME RUN.
ADD ON RUNS FOR THE BREWERS IN
THE BOTTOM OF THE EIGHTH.
7-4 NOW.
>> HOW BIG IS THAT?
HE HAS COME UP WITH SOME HUGE
HITS.
BIG HOME RUNS.
>> TWO-RUN HOME RUN, KOLTEN WONG
WITH THREE RBIS IN HIS LAST TWO
AT-BATS.
WONG STRUCK OUT TWICE IN THIS
ONE.
THIS ONE DOWN THE RIGHT-FIELD
LINE.
TWO RUNS COME HOME.
>> TOOK A WHILE FOR THE BREWERS
TO GET GOING IN THIS SERIES, BUT
HERE THEY ARE.
HERE COMES A CHANGEUP, FIRST
PITCH.
KOLTEN ABLE TO WAIT BACK.
THAT WAS DOWN THE MIDDLE AND
SMOKES IT DOWN THE RIGHT-FIELD
LINE.
STEPHEN: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK YOUTUBE PREGAME
SHOW, PRESENTED BY STATE FARM.
SPECIAL GUEST WITH US, RIP.
CORBIN BURNES OF THE MILWAUKEE
BREWERS  LAST TIME WE WERE
TOGETHER IT WAS ON A YOUTUBE
BROADCAST AGAINST THE REDS, AND
ONE OF THOSE REDS WE HEARD JOEY
VOTTO TALK ABOUT, THIS IS THE
BEST STUFF HE HAS EVER FACED IN
HIS CAREER.
WHEN YOU HAVE A HITTER LIKE JOEY
VOTTO SAYING SOMETHING LIKE
THAT, HOW DID IT HIT YOU?
CORBIN: THAT IS A GREAT
COMPLIMENT.
JOEY FACED A LOT OF GOOD
HITTERS.
I THINK HE COMPARED US TO THE
2010 PHILLIES.
SOME OF THE GUYS WHO WERE ON
THAT TEAM PRETTY UNBELIEVABLE.
TO GET THAT RECOGNITION FROM
JOEY, A GUY WHO HAS BEEN IN THE
LEAGUE FOR A LONG TIME, IS
PRETTY SPECIAL, SOMETHING THAT
MYSELF ALONG WITH THE OTHER GUYS
TAKE PRIDE IN.
BILL: CORBIN, TAKE ME INTO YOUR
LITTLE TRIP RIGHT NOW INTO SAN
FRAN.
YOU THROW MONDAY, YOU THROW
WELL, GET A W.
THEN, WHAT CAN THE REST OF THE
WEEK OFF IN SAN FRANCISCO TO
HANG OUT?
TAKE ME INTO YOUR ROUTINE ON THE
ROAD, SHALL WE SAY.
YOU PITCH ON MONDAY.
WHAT IS YOUR SIDE TODAY LIKE AND
WHAT IS GOING ON THERE COME AND
DO YOU JUST KIND OF KICK IT ON
THE EXTRA OFF DAYS?
CORBIN: YEAH, THE LAST COUPLE
DAYS HAVE BEEN PRETTY RELAXED.
MY DAY AFTER AND TWO DAYS AFTER,
I AM PRETTY LAID BACK.
IT IS ABOUT GETTING THE BODY
RECOVERED AND TRYING TO FEEL
GOOD AFTER THE LAST ONE.
AT THIS POINT IN THE YEAR, IT IS
ABOUT RECOVERY AND GETTING WHAT
I NEED TO GET DONE AND CATCH
PLAY AND SOME FLY IN BETWEEN.
IT HAS BEEN A GOOD COUPLE DAYS.
I HAD A BUNCH OF FAMILY IN TOWN
SO I GOT TO SPEND SOME TIME WITH
THEM AND ENTERTAIN THEM A LITTLE
BIT, AND WATCH THESE GUYS WIN A
COUPLE GAMES.
STEPHEN: THIS IS NO ORDINARY
ROAD TRIP.
YOU WENT TO COLLEGE AT ST.
MARY'S IN THE BAY AREA.
I IMAGINE YOU HAVE A WHOLE
VILLAGE AT ORACLE PARK, DO NOT?
CORBIN: YEAH, I HAVE SOME
FRIENDS CLOSE.
MY WIFE'S FAMILY, A LOT OF THEM
ARE UP IN THIS AREA.
IT IS A GOOD HOMECOMING TO NOT
ONLY SEE THEM IN THE FRIENDS,
BUT TO BE BACK IN THE BAY, WHERE
I PLAYED SOME OF THE YEARS.
BILL: NELLY TALKED ABOUT THAT
STUFF, AND I ASSUME JOEY VOTTO
HITS THE STARTERS, BUT LAST
NIGHT'S BALLGAME YOU GOT TO
WATCH A PLETHORA OF RELIEVERS
COMING IN, ONE AFTER ANOTHER
DOING THE JOB.
WHAT IS THAT LIKE ON A NIGHTLY
BASIS WHEN YOU TURN THE BALL
OVER, YOU GO BACK INTO THE
DUGOUT, KNOWING THAT THE GAME IS
IN PRETTY GOOD HANDS?
CORBIN: OUR BULLPEN HAS BEEN
UNBELIEVABLE.
WHEN WE KNOW WE ONLY HAVE TO GO
SIX INNINGS, IT IS PRETTY
SPECIAL.
EVEN WHEN YOU GO TO COUSINS OR
STRICKLAND OR SUTER EARLY ON,
THOSE GUYS HAVE BEEN
UNBELIEVABLE ALL YEAR.
THEY ARE A GROUP THAT NEEDS TO
BE CREDITED FOR A LOT OF THE
WINS WE HAVE GOTTEN, BEING IN
FIRST PLACE SO FAR THIS YEAR.
STEPHEN: YOUR STAFF, TOP TO
BOTTOM, HAS GOTTEN A LOT OF INK,
AND RIGHTFULLY SO.
JOEY VOTTO AND ALL OF US TV
CLOUDS, ETC.--TV CLOWNS, ETC.,
ETC.
WHO IS THE GUY UNDERSTAFFED
WHERE YOU STEP BACK AND GO, WOW,
HE IS GROSS?
WHO IS THE FILTHIEST GUY ON YOUR
SQUAD?
CORBIN: WILLIAMS OR HADER ON THE
BACKEND.
BOTH HITTERS KNOW THAT DEVON IS
GOING TO THROW A CHANGEUP.
AND THAT I THINK SAME GOES FOR
HADER.
YOU WILL GET A FASTBALL AT THE
TOP OF THE ZONE.
THE NUMBERS THEY PUT UP,
STRIKEOUT NUMBERS THEY PUT UP,
IT'S PRETTY SPECIAL.
AS A STARTING STAFF, IT IS NICE
TO HAVE THOSE TWO GUYS TO LOCK
IT DOWN.
BILL: YOU TALKED ABOUT THEIR
STRIKEOUTS.
YOU ARE NOT TOO SHABBY YOURSELF.
[LAUGHTER]
THE THING THAT GETS ME AS MUCH
AS THE PUNCH IS THE NO-WALKS
THAT GO WITH IT.
TAKE ME THROUGH YOUR MINDSET
WHEN YOU GET A FREE PASS.
IS THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
IS SO TABOO YOU DON'T WANT TO BE
DEALING WITH?
CORBIN: EARLY ON IN MY CAREER I
FELT I GOT IN TROUBLE BY PUTTING
GUYS ON BASE.
THE BEGINNING OF THE LAST YEAR
IS MY FOCUS.
I JUST DON'T WANT TO HURT
MYSELF.
WANT TO MAKE THEM EARN IT.
I CAN SAY I GET A LITTLE UPSET
-- THERE ARE SOME SITUATIONS
WHERE THE WALKS ARE NOT THE
WORST THING AND I HAVE TO TELL
MYSELF IT IS OK, YOU ARE FINE.
I LIKE TO TAKE PRIDE IN MAKE
THOSE GUYS EARN IT.
STEPHEN: LAST ONE BEFORE WE
LET YOU GO -- THIS IS GAME OF
THE WEEK ON YOUTUBE.
FAVORITE YOUTUBE VIDEO OF ALL
TIME?
CORBIN: OH, JEEZ.
I THINK THE ONE I STILL CRACK IS
"CHARLIE BIT ME."
[LAUGHTER]
THAT IS THE FIRST ONE THAT COMES
TO MIND.
THAT WILL MAKE YOU LAUGH EVERY
TIME.
STEPHEN: WE ARE SO OLD AND NOW I
THINK I GRADUATED COLLEGE.
[LAUGHTER]
CORBIN BURNES, THANKS FOR TAKING
TIME OUT.
STAY HEALTHY AND WE WILL SEE YOU
IN THE POST.
CORBIN: AWESOME.
THANK YOU GUYS.
STEPHEN: "CHARLIE BIT ME."
RIP AND I ARE IN NEW JERSEY.
SCOTT BRAUN ON SITE IN SAN
FRANCISCO, AS IS AMY G, WHO
VISITED WITH LOGAN WEBB.
AMY: LOGAN WEBB WITH US, AND YOU
HAVE EMERGED AS ONE OF THE BEST
GIANTS STARTERS THIS SEASON, AND
IT HAS BEEN A FUN STORYLINE TO
WATCH YOU THROUGH YOUR CAREER.
WHAT DO YOU FEEL HAS BEEN A
TURNING POINT FOR YOU, LOGAN,
FINDING THE COVETED CONSISTENCY
THAT STARTERS SEEK?
LOGAN: I THINK CAP HAS TALKED
ABOUT IT A LOT.
I THINK THE MAIN THING IS JUST
ATTACKING THE ZONE AND I THOUGHT
WE WERE DOING REALLY GOOD AT
THAT IN SPRING, AND THEN THE
FIRST MONTH AND A HALF, I HAD
SOME GOOD STARTS.
RIGHT BEFORE I GOT HURT I WAS
STARTING TO FIGURE IT OUT.
UNFORTUNATELY I WAS HURT.
BUT THEN JUST STAYING WITH THE
SAME MENTALITY OF ATTACKING THE
ZONE AND GOING INTO THE REHAB
STARTS AND EVERYTHING AND I
DIDN'T KNOW WHETHER OR NOT I WAS
GOING TO BE OUT OF THE BULLPEN
OR STARTING.
LUCKILY I WAS ABLE TO KEEP
STARTING.
ONCE YOU GET IN A GROOVE, YOU
JUST FEEL GOOD OUT THERE.
YOU JUST GET MORE CONFIDENT EACH
TIME.
AMY: CONFIDENCE, ATTACKING THE
ZONE IS GOING TO BE KEY AGAINST
THIS BREWERS LINEUP.
THEY ARE DEEP, AND THE BENEFIT
OF BEING ABLE TO WATCH THREE
GAMES AT ORACLE PARK TO SEE WHAT
THEY DO.
HOW DANGEROUS IS THIS LINEUP?
CAN YOU SHARE THE KEY TO BEING
ABLE TO CONTAIN THEM WITHOUT
GIVING AWAY THE GAME PLAN?
LOGAN: THEY HAVE AN UNBELIEVABLE
TEAM.
HONESTLY, THE MENTALITY IS THE
SAME.
JUST GOT TO ATTACK THEM.
I THINK ALL GOOD TEAMS -- IF YOU
GETTING BAD COUNTS, GOOD TEAMS
AND GOOD HITTERS, THEY WILL GET
YOU ON THAT.
THIS TEAM IS NO DIFFERENT.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF POWER HITTERS
, GUYS WHO GET WALKS, A REALLY
GOOD TEAM.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE PITCHING
STAFF.
I'M EXCITED TO FACE HIM.
IT WAS FUN LAST TIME.
IT WOULD BE A GOOD GAME.
AMY: ONE TO WATCH, FOR SURE.
LAST THING I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT IS THE SLOGAN -- LET THE
OLD GUYS WAY.
A COUPLE OF THOSE OLD GUYS WERE
WINNING CHAMPIONSHIPS WHEN YOU
WERE IN HIGH SCHOOL -- COMFORT,
POSEY.
WHAT HAS IT BEEN LIKE TO
EXPERIENCE BEING THERE TEAMMATE?
WHAT HAVE THEY GIVEN YOU?
LOGAN: THE BEST THING ABOUT
THOSE GUYS AS THEY COME TO THE
FIELD EVERY DAY, WHAT THEY WANT
TO DO EACH AND EVERY DAY.
FINDING CONSISTENCY IN THE
ROUTINE -- THAT IS WHAT I LEARN
FROM THEM THE MOST FROM
ESPECIALLY GUYS LIKE BUSTER, WHO
I THROW TO EVERY TIME.
JUST PICKING HIS BRAIN ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
I FEEL LIKE I'VE ASKED HIM 10
DIFFERENT TIMES WHAT HIS
FAVORITE PITCHER WAS.
JUST FINDING OUT LITTLE THINGS
THAT HE LIKES AND ALL THE GUYS
WHO HAVE BEEN AWESOME, THEY ARE
THE MAIN REASON WHY WE ARE IN
THE POSITION WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE OF WHAT THEY ARE DONE
BEFORE, JUST BEING
PROFESSIONALS.
I'VE LEARNED A LOT FROM BEING
ABLE TO WATCH THEM.
AMY: CERTAINLY RUBBED OFF ON
YOU, THAT'S FOR SURE.
LOGAN WEBB, THANKS FOR YOUR
TIME.
STEPHEN: LET'S TURN IT UP.
"CREATOR SPOTLIGHT" SHINING ON
DAWSON WRIGHT.
50K SUBSCRIBERS.
HE IS A MASSIVE SAN FRANCISCO
GIANTS FAN.
APPROPRIATE WE HAVE HIM ON.
HE JOINS US FROM PENNSYLVANIA.
GREAT TO DIGITALLY MEET YOU.
EVERYONE CAN GO TO YOUR CHANNEL
AND GET ANYTHING, FROM VIDEO
ESSAYS ON WHAT IS GOING ON RIGHT
NOW, CURRENT EVENTS IN MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL, RANKINGS, TO
LEARNING ABOUT BASEBALL HISTORY.
IT'S FOR FANS OF ALL AGES AND
ALL LEVELS OF INTEREST.
BEING THAT YOU ARE A FAN OF THE
GIANTS, YOU WAKE UP TODAY AND
YOUR TEAM IS NO LONGER IN FIRST
PLACE, HOW DO YOU FEEL?
BE HONEST WITH ME?
YOU ARE RIGHT?
DAWSON: IT'S TOUGH GETTING USED
TO, HONESTLY, IF YOU ARE GOING
TO TELL ME THE START OF THE
SEASON WE WOULD BE HALF A GAME
BACK, I WOULD BE ABSOLUTELY
THRILLED.
IT'S TOUGH GETTING USED TO, BUT
I'M STILL CONFIDENT WITH WHERE
THE TEAM IS RIGHT NOW.
STEPHEN: SEE, ALL YOU FANS
WATCHING COMBAT IS HOW YOU FAN
--ALL YOU FANS WATCHING, THAT IS
HOW YOU FAN RIGHT, PERSPECTIVE.
ELLIE IS COMING TO TOWN, THAT IS
A BIG SERIES.
WHAT YOU WANT TO SEE OUT OF YOUR
CLUB?
DAWSON: WELL, THE OFFENSE REALLY
NEEDS TO SHOW UP.
POSEY HAS BEEN STRUGGLING
LATELY.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE STARTER
DEPTH WITH WOOD AND CUETO GOING
DOWN.
UNTIL THEY GET BACK THEY WILL
NEED TO RELY ON THIS BULLPEN TO
CARRY THEM THROUGH THE GAMES
WITH HELP FROM THE OFFENSE AS
WELL.
STEPHEN: FANDOM AS I, YOU CAN
OBJECTIVELY SAY THAT THIS
NATIONAL LEAGUE WEST RACE IS
INCREDIBLE BECAUSE IT IS NOT
JUST SAN FRANCISCO AND L.A., YOU
HAVE THE PADRES, ONE OF THE MOST
ELECTRIC TEAMS IN THE LEAGUE.
THEY HAD A SUMMER SWOON AND ANNA
BATTLING FOR A WILD-CARD SPOT.
THEY WEAR YOUR NUMBER ONE RANKED
PRESEASON TEAM, CORRECT?
DO YOU BELIEVE THEY CAN HANG
ONTO A POSTSEASON SPOT?
DAWSON: YEAH, I THOUGHT OUT OF
ALL THE TEAMS THEY HAD THE BEST
OFF-SEASON AND WERE SAID TO BE A
DIVISION CONTENDER WORLD SERIES
CONTENDER.
THE SCHEDULE FOR THE REST OF THE
YEAR IS NOT GOING TO BE NICE TO
THEM.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE TYPE OF EASY
SCHEDULE THE REDS DO.
WITH TATIS COMING BACK, THEY HIT
THE SUMMER SKID, I THINK THEY
ARE BETTER THAN THAT.
I THINK THEY ARE A MORE COMPLETE
TEAM THAN THE REDS ARE AND I
HAVE THEM TAKING THE SECOND
SPOT.
STEPHEN: NOBODY COULD HAVE
PREDICTED THE INJURY BUG THAT IS
BIDDEN THE PITCHING STAFF TIME
AND AGAIN.
FERNANDO TATIS, JR., A FEW IL
STINT AS WELL.
BIG PICTURE, NOT JUST THE
DIVISION YOU ARE PAYING
ATTENTION TO -- WHAT SEPTEMBER
STORYLINE HAS YOU LOCK IN?
DAWSON: YOU KNOW, I'M INTERESTED
IN FOLLOWING THE SEATTLE
MARINERS.
THEY ARE HAVING A LOT BETTER
SEASON THAT I THOUGHT THEY
WOULD.
THEY ARE 3.5 GAMES BACK IN THE
WILD-CARD SPOT.
MAKING THE PLAYOFFS IS A VICTIM
FOR THE FRANCHISE.
THEY HAVE BEEN REBUILDING FOR A
WHILE NOW.
I THINK THEY HAVE A SHOT AT
TAKING THE SECOND WILD-CARD
SPOT, AND MAKING THE PLAYOFFS
WOULD BE HUGE FOR THE FRANCHISE.
STEPHEN: ALL RIGHT, DAWSON, YOU
HAVE A LOT OF SUBSCRIBERS,
50,000.
OG ONES KNOW THE CHAPMAN
CHALLENGE.
FOR THOSE WHO HAVEN'T SEEN IT,
THEY ARE GOING TO WATCH IN A FEW
MOMENTS, JUST TO BREAK DOWN WHAT
HAPPENED HERE.
DAWSON: THE CHAPMAN CHALLENGE --
BASICALLY WHAT YOU WANT TO TRY
TO DO IS SIMULATE CATCHING
CHAPMAN.
YOU HAVE A SHORTER DISTANCE AWAY
FROM YOUR CATCHER.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU JUST WANT TO SEE HOW FAST HE
IS ABLE TO CATCH FROM THE
DISTANCE.
MY POOR CATCHER JADEN JUST TOOK
ONE RIGHT TO THE CHEST.
ABOUT 140 MILES AN HOUR
SIMULATION.
I BELIEVE HE IS ABLE TO CATCH
110, BUT THAT WAS A CHALLENGE A
FEW YEARS AGO.
I HOPE PEOPLE START TO BRING IT
BACK.
IT IS A LITTLE DANGEROUS.
DON'T TRY IT AT HOME.
IT IS SOMETHING GREAT, AND IT IS
SOMETHING THAT REALLY HELPED
KIDS STRUCK BY CHANNEL, TOO.
STEPHEN: THAT'S AWESOME.
WOULD YOU RATHER CATCH CHAPMAN
REAL-LIFE OR ABSENT WHEN SOMEONE
TO THE CHALLENGE NOW?
DAWSON: HAVE SOMEONE DO THE
CHALLENGE WITH ME NOW.
CHAPMAN, YOU STILL GET A LITTLE
BIT OF MOVEMENT ON THEIR.
WITH THAT TAIL, YOU ARE DONE
BEHIND THE PLATE.
YOU ARE DONE.
STEPHEN: DAWSON WRIGHT, GREAT TO
VISIT WITH YOU.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN DO IT AGAIN
SOON.
YOUR FAVORITE MEMORY WAS THE
'14 GIANTS.
MAYBE INSTEAD OF EVEN YOUR
MAGIC, IS AUDIOMETRIC.
-- ODD YEAR MAGICAL DAWSON:
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
STEPHEN: YOU LOOK AT THE LAST
NINE TURNS, HE HAS THE BALL
TODAY FOR THE CREW ON THE ROAD
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
WE HAVE GOT SOME PIC
>> FASTBALL.
THAT ONE WAS HIT WELL TO RIGHT
CENTER FIELD.
MAKE YASTRZEMSKI.
IT'S GONE.
AND BY PLENTY.
TWO-RUN HOMER COME HIS 20TH OF
THE YEAR.
3-0, GIANTS.
HE HITS ONE, AND NOBODY WAS
THERE.
LEADOFF SINGLE.
MIKE YASTRZEMSKI, WHO GOT THE
HIT THAT STARTED THE RALLY, AND
HE LINES THIS ONE INTO THE
CENTER FIELD BASE HIT.
HIS PENSKE, SECOND HIT OF THE
GAME.
THAT LINED RIGHT BACK UP THE
MIDDLE.
MIKE YASTRZEMSKI INTO CENTER
FIELD FOR THE LEADOFF SINGLE.
YASTRZEMSKI DRIVES THAT WENT OUT
TO LEFT CENTER FIELD.
GOING BACK, PEDERSON ALL THE WAY
TO THE WALL.
IT'S GONE.
MIKE YASTRZEMSKI TO LEFT CENTER
FIELD.
THAT IS A BEAUTIFUL SWING.
4-0, GIANTS.
YASTRZEMSKI INTO LEFT CENTER
FIELD.
THAT IS GOING TO GET DOWN, AND
THAT IS GOING TO BE ANOTHER RUN.
PETERSON CUTTING IT OFF.
YASTRZEMSKI.
5-0, GIANTS.
WHAT AN IMPRESSIVE RALLY THIS
HAS BEEN.
STEPHEN: GETTING CLOSE TO THE
END OF THE LINE ON THE MLB GAME
OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY STATE FARM.
RIGHT NOW IT IS TIME FOR PICKS
TO CLICK, PRESENTED BY FANDUEL
SPORTSBOOK.
BACK WITH RIP AND STUDIO 42.
DOES KRIS BRYANT HIT A HOME RUN
TODAY?
BILL: I'LL SAY YES, AND I KNOW I
USUALLY GO ON THE UNDERSIDE
BECAUSE IT IS NOT EASY TO HIT
HOMERS.
LOOK, SAN FRAN, THEY NEED TO
STOP THE BLEEDING.
THEY NEED A W.
I'M GOING TO SAY YES.
STEPHEN: YOU BROKE DOWN LOGAN
WEBB AND THE ADJUSTMENTS HE HAS
MADE LAST YEAR TO THIS YEAR.
GROUND BALL PITCHER, SECOND
HIGHEST RATE IN THE MAJORS.
6.5, OVER-UNDER.
WHERE ARE YOU GOING?
BILL: THAT IS A TOUGH ONE FOR ME
HERE.
I'M GOING TO GO WITH 6.
GOOD MARK, 6.5.
MAKES YOU THINK.
I WILL SAY UNDER BUT HE STILL
PITCHES EXTREMELY WELL, WHAT
UNDER 6.5.
STEPHEN: HE HAS GOT TO FACE THE
MILWAUKEE LINEUP, WHICH DOES NOT
HAVE WILLY ADAMES IN IT TODAY.
IT IS HIS BIRTHDAY.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY, WILLIE.
BREWERS ARE AVERAGING 4.7 RUNS
PER GAME IN THE SERIES SO FAR.
OVER-UNDER, THREE TOTAL RUNS?
BILL: ANOTHER GOOD NUMBER RIGHT
THERE.
I TELL YOU WHAT, LOGAN WEBB HAS
BEEN SO GOOD, I WILL SAY UNDER
THAT ONE BECAUSE I'M PUTTING A
LOT OF THE EGGS IN THAT BASKET.
SAN FRAN WINNING MEANS LOGAN IS
GOING TO PITCH WELL BECAUSE KB
IS GOING BRIDGE.
ALL THE EGGS IN THAT BASKET.
STEPHEN: THERE IS A SENSE YOU
ARE LEANING TOWARDS A GIANTS
VICTORY, BUT THE NUMBER OF RUNS
IS STILL A QUESTION.
4.5.
BILL: 4.5 FOR THE GIGANTES?
I'M GOING TO SAY OVER.
THE FIRST FOUR-GAME SKID, NO
REASON TO PANIC.
JUST A HALF-GAME BACK FROM THE
DODGERS.
GO OUT AND PLAY A GOOD GAME, PUT
SOME RUNS UP ON THE BOARD, LET
LOGAN WEBB DO HIS THING.
STEPHEN: RIP'S TAKE ON NOT JUST
THOSE PLAYS, BUT THE RESULT.
ABOUT YOU?
BUT THE QUESTION OUT THERE.
BILL: THERE YOU GO.
STEPHEN: WOW, 55% AGREEING WITH
YOU, BILL RIPKEN.
YOU ARE A MAN OF THE PEOPLE,
ALWAYS HAVE.
BILL: I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
I WILL SAFE 55% OF THE PEOPLE
HAVE A GOOD IDEA WHAT IS GOING
ON.
LOGAN WEBB HAS BEEN GOOD.
FIRST FOUR-GAME SKID BY THE
GIGANTES.
STEPHEN: RIGHT NOW, WHO IS YOUR
HORSE IN THE NATIONAL LEAGUE?
THESE ARE TWO FRONT RUNNERS.
BILL: WHO IS THE HORSE?
I STILL THINK IT IS THE DODGERS.
THERE IS NO REASON TO THINK THAT
THE SEASON HASN'T GONE THE WAY
IT HAS.
LOOK, THEY ARE GOOD.
THE DODGERS ARE GOOD.
STEPHEN: THEY'RE GOING TO SAN
FRANCISCO NEXT.
SCAUN,N, SHAWNWN ESTES, TIM
DILLARD, A GUTIERREZ.
ENJOY.
>> HERE'S THE PITCH.
SCOTT: GAME DAY IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
IT'S IS LIKE AWARD SEASON.
SIZZLING TO SAVE THE DAY FROM
THE MIDWEST.
SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS.
WE ARE HERE RIGHT NOW.
SCOTT BRAUN SAYING HELLO TO OUR
AUDIENCE FROM AND I'M WITH SHAWN
ESTES AND TIM DILLARD.
YOUTUBE START, YOU DO KNOW THAT?
TIM: A LITTLE BIT.
SCOTT: WE ARE OFF TO A GREAT
START.
BOTH OF THESE TEAMS HAVE BEEN
OFF TO A GREAT START.
THREE GAMES OVER POINT 500.
FIRST PLACE FOR THE FIRST TIME
SINCE MAY 31.
THIS TEAM IS IN SECOND BASE AND
HAS EXCEEDED EXPECTATIONS.
SHAWN: THAT IS WHAT IS MOST
CURIOUS ABOUT.
ONE OF THE FIRST TEAMS.
THAT IS THE BEST RECORD IN THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE.
TEAM EFFORT.
LOGAN WEBB.
BEST E.R.A.
AND THEN THE FRANCHISE RECORD
THROUGH SEPTEMBER 1.
LEADS THE MAJOR LEAGUE --
KRIS BRYANT FITS RIGHT IN.
VERY VERSATILE.
SINCE THEY --
SCOTT: THE OFFENSE HASN'T SHOWN
UP.
THEY ACTUALLY --
THE FIRST THREE GAMES -- -- AND
OUR CONTINUATION --
SHAWN: FIVE-GAMER OR ONE-GAME
TWO GREAT TEAMS, PLAYING THE
BEST BASEBALL.
THEY HAVE A CHANCE TO RIGHT THE
SHIP.
SCOTT: WE WILL TALK ABOUT IT IN
JUST A FEW.
YOU DO GET TO LOOK UP.
CRAIG COUNSELL.
TIM: YEAH, HERE IT IS.
YOU GOT CORBIN BURNES, 89
STRIKEOUTS.
THERE WILL BE MORE OF THOSE.
DEVIN WILLIAMS FOLLOWING UP HIS
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR LAST YEAR.
JOSH HADER COMING INTO SEAL THE
DEAL.
YOU LOOK AT THESE GUYS AND THEY
ARE JUST LIGHTS OUT.
MOSTLY HOMEGROWN GUYS AND SOME
OF MILWAUKEE'S BEST.
SCOTT: PITCHING IS SOBERING.
JUST KEEP ADDING ON THE LINE FOR
WHAT THEY ARE PUTTING TOGETHER
WAS ON PACE FOR 99 WINS.
ACTUALLY WOULD LIKE A CLEAN ONE
BUT WE WILL SETTLE FOR 99 IF
THAT IS HOW IT WORKS OUT.
THEY ARE REALLY GOOD ON THE
ROAD.
46 UP AND 23 DOWN AWAY FROM
MILLER PARK.
WE ARE ABOUT TO BRING IN THE
FOURTH MEMBER OF OUR TEAM.
AMY G WILL BRING IN THE OG TRIO.
SHE WILL TALK TO BRANDON
CRAWFORD BEFORE WE GET TO
GAMETIME IN SAN FRANCISCO.
>> SEE IF BURNES CAN DELIVER ONE
HERE.
BURNES, A BASE HIT INTO LEFT
FIELD.
HE IS GOING TO HEAD HOME.
AND CORBIN BURNES WITH HIS
FOURTH R.B.I. OF THE SEASON.
2-2, AND HE GOT HIM.
BUZZ BOMB IN THE OUTSIDE CORNER.
HADER READY TO FIRE.
SWING AND A FLY BALL SHALLOW
RIGHT CENTER.
HE MAKES THE CATCH TO END THE
BALLGAME.
>> 2-0, BREWERS.
>> SWING AND A HIGH FLY DEEP
INTO LEFT FIELD.
WAY BACK, IT IS GONE.
HALFWAY UP THE BLEACHERS IN THE
FIELD FROM LORENZO CAIN.
>> GETS THAT WANT TO LEFT CENTER
GOT SOME CARRY.
YASTRZEMSKI ON THE RUN.
OFF THE WALL.
TELLABS ON HIS WAY TO THIRD.
IT WILL BE IN R.B.I. TRIPLE.
>> BREWERS THREE OUTS AWAY FROM
TAKING THE FIRST TWO GAME OF
THIS SERIES.
>> THIS ONE ON ITS WAY.
IT IS GONE!
GIANTS WITH A RUN ON THE BOARD
IN THE BOTTOM OF THE NINTH
INNING.
NOW THE GIANTS ARE DOWN TO THEIR
FINAL OUT.
>> CAIN IS UNDER IT, AND THE
BREWERS HAVE WON BACK-TO-BACK
GAMES.
AMY: WE'VE GOT A BEAUTIFUL DAY
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
IT'S A GREAT DAY FOR SOME
BASEBALL.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE THE FINAL
GAME OF THIS FOUR-GAME SERIES
BETWEEN THE SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS
AND THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS.
WELCOME BACK TO OUR BROADCAST.
I AM AMY GUTIERREZ.
GIANTS TRYING TO SALVAGE A GAME
IN THE SERIES AS THEY HAVE
DROPPED THE FIRST THREE, BUT
THAT IS NOT TO SAY THEY HAVEN'T
HAD A VERY SUCCESSFUL SEASON.
THE GIANTS HAVE PROBABLY BEEN
THE BIGGEST PRIZE IN BASEBALL,
COMING INTO 2020 ONE, NO ONE WAS
THINKING THE GIANTS WERE GOING
TO BE A CONTENDER, BUT THEY'VE
QUIETLY PUT TOGETHER A VERY GOOD
SEASON.
WE HAVE HEROICS FROM PLAYERS
THAT MOST FANS ARE JUST GETTING
TO KNOW, BUT THERE IS THREE GUYS
THE GIANTS FANS WILL NEVER
FORGET.
THE USUAL SUSPECTS, BELL,
CRAWFORD, AND POSEY.
NOT ONLY HAVE THEY LED THE TEAM
WITH VETERAN EXPERIENCE, THEY
ARE EACH HAVING A CAREER SEASON.
BRANDON BELT, CAREER-HIGH IN
HOME RUNS.
CRAWFORD, CAREER-BEST OPS.
POSEY, BEST SINCE HIS 2012
SEASON.
SURPRISE IS KIND OF A TEAM
BECAUSE A LOT OF FANS THINK IT
IS A SURPRISE BRANDON CRAWFORD
IS HAVING SUCH A RESURGENT
SEASON.
10 YEARS FOR HIM IN MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
I THINK A BETTER WORD FOR IT IS
REWARDED.
I HAD A CHANCE TO CATCH UP WITH
THE THREE TIME ALL-STAR, THE
GOLD GLOVER COME ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF WORK YOU PUT INTO HIS
OFF-SEASON AND 2021.
>> I THINK IT STARTED WHEN THE
NEW HITTING GROUP CAME IN.
BASICALLY OPEN ARMS.
IN 2019I WAS NOT HAVING A GOOD
YEAR OFFENSIVELY.
I WAS OPEN TO WHAT THE NEW EYES
HAD FOR ME.
THERE WAS A LOT OF WORK PUT IN
JANUARY AND LEADING UP INTO
SPRING TRAINING OF LAST YEAR.
I THINK THE RESULTS WERE
STARTING TO SHOW A LITTLE BIT
LAST YEAR.
OBVIOUSLY A SHORTENED SEASON.
WOULD HAVE BEEN INTERESTING TO
SEE WHAT A FULL SEASON WOULD
LOOK LIKE, AND THIS IS THE
RESULTS OF THAT WORK THAT I PUT
IN, AND MENTIONED THE WORKOUTS,
I THINK THE OFF-SEASON I WAS A
LITTLE BIT MORE CONSISTENT COME
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T GO ON FAMILY
TRIPS AND WE STAYED LOCAL.
I WAS ABLE TO SOUND TOP OF IT
MORE.
ALSO MORE DYNAMIC WORKOUTS AND
EXCLUSIVENESS HELPED OUT ALSO.
AMY: YOU PRETTY MUCH ONLY KNEW
ONE MANAGER FOR THE MAJORITY OF
YOUR CAREER IN BRUCE BOCHY.
NOW YOU'VE GOT KAPLER.
WHAT HAS HE DONE TO EARN YOUR
TRUST, AND WHAT WOULD YOU CAN
POINT IT IS ABOUT HIM THAT
BRINGS OUT THE BEST OF YOU ON
THE FIELD?
LOGAN: I THINK JUST HOW HE IS
ABLE TO ADAPT AND CHANGE JUST
WITHIN THE LAST YEAR I'VE BEEN
WITH HIM ALSO COMING INTO LAST
YEAR, WE DIDN'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT TO EXPECT.
IT WAS A WEIRD YEAR.
INITIALLY I THINK IT WAS WELL
KNOWN THAT I WASN'T GOING TO
PLAY AGAINST LEFTIES.
I THINK JUST THE OPENNESS TO BE
ABLE TO SEE THAT, YEAH, WHAT
GUYS CAN DO, JUST BEING ABLE TO
USE HIS EYES AND SEE THE
EXPERIENCE OR DEFENSE.
LEFTIES LIKE STUFF LIKE THAT.
HE IS VERY OPEN ABOUT IT AND
THIS YEAR HAS BEEN TOTALLY
DIFFERENT.
HE HAS ALLOWED STARTING PITCHERS
TO GO LATER IN THE GAME SO IF
THE NUMBERS -- LEFTIES CAN HIT
LEFTIES, STUFF LIKE THAT.
AMY: JERRY ON THE TOP AS WE WRAP
UP WITH BRANDON CRAWFORD IS HE
IS A GIANT FOR TWO MORE
SEASONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME, BRANDON
CRAWFORD.
THAT IS PROBABLY THE BIGGEST
REWARD CAN BE GETS TO REMAIN SAN
FRANCISCO GIANTS.
WE HAVE FIRST PITCH COMING UP.
LOGAN WEBB SQUARING UP AGAINST
ERIC LAUER.
DON'T GO ANYWHERE, EVERYONE.
GIANTS AND BREWERS, COMING UP.
>> NO LORENZO CAIN, BASES
LOADED.
LINE DRIVE, BASE HIT RIGHT
FIELD.
HERE COMES NARVAEZ TOWARDS THE
PLATE.
BRYANT OFF-LINE.
2-0, MILWAUKEE.
TWO-RUN SINGLE BY LORENZO CAIN.
>> DICKERSON THE THIRD.
RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
INTO THE GAP.
THAT WILL GO THROUGH.
DICKERSON HAS SCORED.
BRYANT WILL STOP AT SECOND WITH
AN R.B.I. DOUBLE.
BUSTER, HE IS DUE.
MUDDLING THE FIRST-BASE LINE, A
FAIR BALL.
BELT GOES TO THIRD.
IT IS 2-2.
>> TIE GAME, SEVENTH INNING.
>> PETERSON INTO LEFT FIELD,
BASE HIT.
THE BREWERS WILL TAKE THE LEAD,
AS CAIN SCORES AND JACE PETERSON
CONTINUES TO IMPRESS.
>> LORENZO CAIN COMING HERE IS
THE PITCH TO HIM.
CAIN RIPS ONE TO LEFT.
AT THE WALL, IT IS OFF THE TOP
OF THE FENCE, AND DID IT STAYED
IN PLAY?
IT DID.
BREWERS WILL TAKE ANOTHER LOOK
AT THIS ONE.
>> HOME RUN.
♪
>> IT'S THE BREWERS AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO GIANTS.
>> THIS HAS THE FEEL OF A
PLAYOFF-TYPE SERIES.
THERE IS A LOT OF BUZZ WITH
THESE TWO TEAMS RIGHT NOW.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE A LOT OF
FUN.
>> GET UP!
GET OUTTA HERE! >> IT IS OUTTA
HERE.
>> OH, THAT BALL IS HIT.
>> HE JUST PUT THE CREW ON TOP.
>> CAN YOU BELIEVE IT?
>> AND HE MAKES THE CATCH!
OH, WHAT A PLAY!
>> AND THIS IS GOING TO WIN IT
FOR THE BREW CREW!
>> AND THE BALLGAME IS OVER!
SCOTT: TWO OF THE TOP THREE
TEAMS IN THE NATIONAL LEAGUE
SQUARING UP THIS AFTERNOON AND
FINISHING UP A FOUR-GAME SERIES.
IT IS THE GIANTS HOSTING THE
MILWAUKEE BREWERS, ALL HAPPENING
RIGHT HERE LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
YOUTUBE GAME DAYS ARE SPECIAL --
MIC'D-UP PLAYERS, GLOBAL
AUDIENCE.
BRAND-NEW FEATURE IN THE LAST
FEW WEEKS, YOU CAN PERSONALIZE
YOUR LISTENING EXPERIENCE BY
LISTENING TO THE HOME OR RADIO
CALLS, OR US, OR JUST DJ IT, GO
BACK AND FORTH.
YOU DO YOU.
PITCHING MATCHUP, ERIC LAUER
AGAINST THE GREAT LOGAN WEBB.
HE HAS BEEN FANTASTIC ESPECIALLY
IN THE LAST 12, 13 STARTS.
LAUER MAKING HIS FIRST START OFF
THE COVID I.L.
WEBB HAS ALLOWED TWO RUNS OR
FEWER IN EACH OF HIS LAST 13
STARTS.
AS GOOD AS KEVIN GAUSMAN HAS
BEEN THE SEASON FOR SAN
FRANCISCO, WEBB HAS BEEN THE MAN
LATELY, SHAWN.
LET'S RUN THROUGH YOUR SCOUTING
REPORT.
SHAWN: LOGAN WEBB, YOU WANT TO
CLEAR THE MECHANISM, WANT TO
FOCUS ON THE PITCH, THROW THE
CATCHER WITHOUT WORRYING ABOUT
THE HITTER, COMMIT TO EVERY
PITCH.
SOMETIMES HE THINGS A LITTLE BIT
TOO MUCH.
HE IS BEST WHEN HE POUNDS THE
STRIKE ZONE, DOESN'T THINK, JUST
RELIES ON STUFF.
WANT TO CONTINUE KILLING WORMS.
KEEP THE BALL IN THE GROUND.
HIGHEST GROUNDBALL PERCENTAGE IN
THE NATIONAL LEAGUE THIS SEASON,
61%.
TWO OR FEWER -- 13 STRAIGHT
STARTS HE HAS GIVEN UP TWO RUNS
OR FEWER.
IN THOSE 13 STARTS HIS TEAM IS
12-1.
THE ONE LOSS CAME AGAINST THE
BREWERS IN HIS LAST START
AGAINST MILWAUKEE.
SCOTT: THAT WAS ON THE SIXTH OF
AUGUST.
HE MATCHED UP AGAINST CORBIN
BURNES AND THAT ONE.
WEBB WAS FANTASTIC -- SIX
INNINGS, ONE RUN, THREE HITS,
NINE STRIKEOUTS, JUST ONE WALK,
91 PITCHES.
SECOND TIME AROUND AGAINST THE
BREWERS.
UNDERWAY ON YOUTUBE.
WEBB FIRES A STRIKE AT KOLTEN
WONG.
SCOTT BRAUN, SHAWN ESTES COME
TIM DILLARD, AND AMY G DOWN ON
THE FIELD.
WONG'S NUMBERS EVEN BETTER ON
THE ROAD THIS YEAR.
DROP SHOT FOR CRAWFORD.
LET'S RUN THROUGH THE VISITING
STARTING NINE LINEUP CARD,
PRESENTED BY STATE FARM.
FOR CRAIG COUNSEL ON THE BEST
ROAD TEAM IN BASEBALL, WE SAW
WONG BOUNCE OUT.
URIAS PLAYING SHORT FOR ADONIS,
YELICH ON FIRE, GARCIA HAVING A
CAREER YEAR, PETERSON IS AN
ON-BASE MACHINE, VOGELBACH BACK
AS OF YESTERDAY, LUKE MAILE
CALLED UP AS WELL, CATCHING FOR
ERIC LAUER.
HERE IS LUIS URIAS, WHO CRAIG
COUNSELL TOLD US, TIM, HAS
RELAXED HIMSELF SINCE WILLY
ADAMES TOOK HIS JOB.
TIM: THEY PUT HIM IN AN EVERYDAY
SHORTSTOP AND HE PROBABLY WASN'T
READY TO TAKE OVER THAT ROLE.
THAT IS A PRETTY BIG ROLE FOR A
GUIDE TO DO THAT AT SUCH A YOUNG
AGE.
WILLY ADAMES COMES IN AND TAKES
THE PRESSURE OFF URIAS.
EVERYWHERE HE PLAYS, HE IS
FANTASTIC.
HE HAS BEEN GETTING THE JOB DONE
AT THE PLATE AS WELL.
SCOTT: I THINK SOMETIMES WE
FORGET THE AGES FOR SOME OF
THESE PLAYERS, JUST BECAUSE JUAN
SOTO COMES UP OR WANDER FRANCO,
20, 21 YEARS OLD, AND LOOKS LIKE
THEY BELONG RIGHT AWAY.
THAT IS NOT THE CASE FOR
EVERYONE.
URIAS HAS BEEN ONE OF THE BETTER
OFFENSIVE PERFORMERS ON THE
TEAM.
HOT SHOT TO BELT.
HE FOUND IT.
TOSS TO WEBB COVERING WITH
PLENTY OF TIME.
SHAWN: GREAT JOB BY LOGAN WEBB.
YOU ARE TAUGHT FROM THE FIRST
DAY OF SPRING TRAINING, THE
FIRST STEP HAS TO BE TOWARDS
FIRST BASE.
YOU CAN'T ASSUME THE PLATE IS
GOING TO BE MADE, EITHER.
BRANDON BELT, POSITIONING
PERFECT RIGHT THERE ON THAT
BALL.
ANOTHER GROUND BALL FOR LOGAN
WEBB IT.
MENTIONED THE GROUND BALLS, TWO
TO START THIS GAME.
SCOTT: 61 POINT 2% GROUND BALLS
THIS YEAR FOR LOGAN WEBB, BEST
IN THE NATIONAL LEAGUE, MUCH
BETTER THAN HIS MARK FROM A YEAR
AGO.
FORMER M.V.P. CHRISTIAN YELICH,
19 OF HIS LAST 20.
SHAWN: THE REASON WHY HE HAS
BEEN AN IMPROVEMENT FROM THE
LAST SEASON IS BECAUSE OF THE
TWO SEAM USAGE.
HE HAS THROWN A LOT MORE SINKERS
THIS YEAR, 36% COMPARED TO 15%
LAST YEAR.
HE IS GETTING GREAT RESULTS.
SCOTT: WE ARE TRYING AND GUESSED
THE RENTAL FOR MILWAUKEE TODAY.
ODDS COURTESY OF FANDUEL.
IT IS JUST THREE, OVER-UNDER.
BOTH OF YOU TAKE A SHOT AND KEEP
IN MIND WHO IS ON THE MOUND, AND
JUST LAW OF AVERAGES.
BREWERS HAVE WON THE FIRST
THREE.
YELICH GOING TO LEFT SIDE AND
BRANDON CRAWFORD A SWEET PLAY
FADING AWAY.
REAL QUICK BEFORE I GO TO BREAK,
THREE RUN FOR MILWAUKEE TODAY?
SHAWN: UNDER.
TIM: OVERCOME I HAVE TO SAY
OVER.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: PRESSURE IS ON.
CRAWFORD HANDLE THE PRESSURE
NICELY.
3 GROUND BALLS, THAT IS WHAT
LOGAN WEBB DOES.
WE WILL SEE THE GIANTSBAT, NEXT.
>> ON JULY 7, TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT, THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS
MADE ONE OF THE BIGGEST RATES IN
FRANCHISE HISTORY WHEN THEY
ACQUIRED REIGNING CY YOUNG
WINNER CC SABATHIA FROM
CLEVELAND.
THEY MADE THE MOVE WITH ONE GOAL
IN MIND, MAKE THE POSTSEASON FOR
THE FIRST TIME SINCE 1982.
>> WE FELT BEFORE WE GOT CC THAT
WE WERE PRETTY GOOD CLUB, BUT
WHAT CC DID WAS GIVE US
INCREDIBLE DEPTH.
>> CC SABATHIA.
FIVE-HIT SHUTOUT.
>> WHEN WE GOT CC SABATHIA, WE
MADE IT LOUD AND CLEAR, WE WILL
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN DO TO BRING
OUR FANS POSTSEASON BASEBALL.
>> SABATHIA GOES ALL THE WAY!
WHAT A MASTERPIECE!
>> SABATHIA WENT 11-2 WITH
MILWAUKEE, PITCHING ON THREE
DAYS REST IN THREE CONSECUTIVE
STARTS DOWN THE STRETCH.
>> THE BREWERS WIN AGAIN.
CC SABATHIA, HIS THIRD STRAIGHT
COMPLETE GAME.
>> ON THE FINAL DAY OF THE 2008
SEASON, CC DELIVERED HIS MOST
CLUTCH PERFORMANCE OF THE YEAR,
LEADING THE BREWERS TO THE FIRST
POSTSEASON IN NEARLY TWO AND A
HALF DECADES.
>> SABATHIA!
A COMPLETE-GAME!
>> THE BREWERS ARE GOING TO THE
PLAYOFFS.
>> CC SABATHIA, WHAT PICKUP.
SCOTT: THREE GROUND BALL FOR
LOGAN WEBB AND THE GIANTS.
NOW WE WILL SEE IF THE OFFENSE
CAN PRODUCE.
HERE IS THEIR STARTING NINE,
PRESENTED BY STATE FARM.
AUSTIN SLATER WILL BE THE WAY,
THEN KRIS BRYANT, FORMER M.V.P.
IN THE TRADE DEADLINE
ACQUISITION.
BRANDON BELT IS HAVING SOME
SEASON.
DARIN RUF HAS BEEN A STUD FOR
THEM AT THE PLATE.
THAIRO ESTRADA PLAYING SECOND
TODAY.
CRAWFORD AT SHORT.
CASALI INSTEAD OF POSEY
CATCHING.
LOGAN WEBB WILL ROUND OUT THE
STARTING NINE.
WE BEGIN WITH AUSTIN SLATER.
LAST NIGHT 0-3 WITH A WALK.
THIS TIME FIRST PITCH GOING
AFTER IT, DEEP CENTER FIELD, AND
FORGET ABOUT IT!
AUSTIN SLATER MUSCLES UP, AND
THE GIANTS ARE ON THE BOARD WITH
ONE PITCH.
IT IS THEIR FIRST LEAD OF THE
SERIES.
MAKE IT 1-0 ON HIS 10TH OF THE
SEASON.
SHAWN: AND THAT IS WHY AUSTIN
SLATER IS ON THIS ROSTER.
HE WAS WITH THE CLUB FROM THE?,
TO KILL OF HANDED PITCHING.
HASN'T DONE AS WELL THIS YEAR.
HE WAS NOT WAITING AROUND FROM
TAKE THE FIRST-PITCH FASTBALL,
KNOWS LAUER THROWS A LOT OF
FASTBALLS.
THE EXECUTION UP IN THE ZONE, HE
DROVE INTO THE BIG PART OF THE
BALLPARK, AND THE GIANTS ARE ON
THE BOARD EARLY.
TIM: HE WAS PROBABLY IN THE
DUGOUT GOING I'M GOING TO SWING
FIRST PITCH NO MATTER WHAT.
SHAWN: THAT HAS TO BE
PREDETERMINED AS A HITTER.
TIM: I THINK SO.
I WOULD DO THAT.
SCOTT: ESPECIALLY AS THE LEADOFF
HITTER.
SHAWN: THERE ARE CERTAIN GUYS AS
YOU WATCH THE PITCH AND THAT
SWING BIKES LATER, HE HAS
ATTENDED POWER.
YES IT SOME OF THE LONGEST HOME
RUN -- HE HAS HIT SOME OF THE
LONGEST TERM AND ON THIS GIANTS
TEAM BUT HE IS NOT BEEN
CONNECTING CONSISTENTLY.
SCOTT: GET STOP ABOARD THE
TROLLEY.
10 PLAYERS WITH DOUBLE-DIGIT
HOMERS.
NOW MAKE IT 11.
SHAWN: HE WAS SITTING ON NINE
FOR A WHILE.
NOW 11 DOUBLE-DIGIT HOME RUN
GUYS.
TIM: THAT'S CRAZY.
HE WAS JEALOUS.
HE SAW THE OPENING AND EVERYONE
ON THE TROLLEY AND FELT LEFT
OUT.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: EASY TO WATCH US ON HIS
OWN INSIDE THE CLUBHOUSE.
THIS TEAM KNOWS HOW TO SPREAD
THE WEALTH AND THEY HAVE BEEN ON
A POWER SURGE ALL SEASON LONG,
IT'S INCREDIBLE.
BRYANT LIFTS ONE, GETS UNDER IT.
AND JACKIE BRADLEY, JR., DOESN'T
HAVE TO MOVE MUCH.
THERE IS OUT NUMBER ONE.
OK, ERIC LAUER WAS RUDELY
INTERRUPTED BY AUSTIN SLATER ON
THE FIRST PITCH, BUT THE STATE
FROM SCOUTING REPORT SHOWS US A
GUY WHO IS HAVING A GREAT
SEASON, TIM.
TIM: HE LOVES DAY GAMES.
MAKE MY DAY, PUNK.
THAT IS CONDUCIVE TO WHAT WAS
ON THE FIRST PITCH.
IT IS CONDUCIVE TO THE EXCEL IT
EARLY AND THEN -- ACCELERATE
EARLY AND THEN CRUISE.
TOP OF THE ZONE, THAT IS HIS
BREAD-AND-BUTTER.
SCOTT: AND IT SOUNDS GOOD.
INVISICUTTER.
SHAWN: WAS THAT FIRST PITCH
INVISICUTTER OR JUST
FOUR-SEAMER?
TIM: I DON'T KNOW.
[LAUGHTER]
SHAWN: JUAN SOTO, I AM SURE YOU
ARE LOCKED IN ON THAT.
SCOTT: THEY PUT IT DOWN AS A
FOUR-SEAMER SO IT WASN'T
INVISICUTTER.
TIM: SPECIAL OCCASIONS.
SHAWN: I'M SURE WE WILL GET A
HEAVY DOSE OF INVISICUTTER.
SCOTT: HEAVY DOSE OF MOVIE REFS.
YOU AND I ARE GOING TO BE
TESTED.
WAS THE FIRST ONE?
TIM: OH, "DIRTY HARRY."
EASTWOOD, BABY.
FILMED HERE.
SHAWN: HE LIVES DOWN SOUTH IN
CARMEL.
SCOTT: WONG IS AS GOOD AS IT
GETS ON THE KEYSTONE.
TWO GONE.
TIM: TALKING ABOUT LOGAN WEBB
AND BEING THE GROUND BALLS MAN.
HE DOESN'T MIND GIVING UP FLY
BALLS.
I THINK THAT IS AN INTERESTING
THING.
SHAWN: AS LONG AS THEY'RE NOT
BARRELED.
ESPECIALLY IN THIS BALLPARK.
MATT CAIN PITCHED-YEAR-OLD A LOT
OF YEARS--PITCHED HERE A LOT OF
YEARS.
WIND THRILLS AND THIS BALLPARK.
THEY MOVED THE FENCES IN.
BUT THIS IS STILL A REALLY TOUGH
PLACE TO HIT HOME RUNS, WHICH IS
WHAT THE DISH WHICH MAKES WHAT
THE --WHICH MAKES WHAT THE
GIANTS HAVE DONE THIS YEAR EVEN
MORE IMPRESSIVE.
SCOTT: THREE GOLD GLOVERS FOR
MILWAUKEE.
RUF TAKES A STRIKE.
I THINK LAMONTE WADE, JR.,
SHOWED US HOW COZY THIS BALLPARK
WAS YESTERDAY.
HE HIT A BALL THAT TURNED INTO A
DOUBLE IN THE LATE STAGES.
WOULD HAVE BEEN A HOME RUN IN
EVERY OTHER PART, ACCORDING TO
STATCAST.
SHAWN: IF I HAD A DOLLAR FOR
EVERY TIME I HEARD THAT IN THIS
BALLPARK, I WOULD HIT A HOME RUN
IN EVERY OTHER BALLPARK,
ESPECIALLY TRIPLES ALL I.
IT IS A LONG WAYS OUT.
SCOTT: 415 WITH A HIGH WALL.
SHAWN: LAMONTE WADE, JR.,
AGAINST WOODRUFF THE OTHER
NIGHT, HE THOUGHT HE SQUARED ONE
UP.
FROM HIS REACTION, HE HIT IT OUT
OF THE BALLPARK, AND THE LAST
NIGHT AGAIN, SAME TYPE OF
REACTION.
I GUESS HE IS GETTING HIS FIRST
TASTE OF ORACLE.
HE'S BEEN HERE FOR A BIG PORTION
OF THIS YEAR.
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF THOSE BALLS
GO OUT OF THE BALLPARK.
HUGE PICKUP FOR THE GIANTS.
SCOTT: RUF POPS ONE UP.
THAT WILL GO OUT OF PLAY.
RUF HAS BEEN QUITE TO PICK UP A
COUPLE YEARS AGO.
HE WAS CRUSHING BASEBALLS FOR A
FEW YEARS IN THE KOREAN BASEBALL
ORGANIZATION.
CAME BACK TO THE STATES.
HE HAS TAKEN OFF FOR SAN
FRANCISCO.
IF YOU ARE INTO O.P.S.+ HE IS
149.
COMPREHENSIVE STAT IN THE
BALLPARK.
HE LEADS THE TEAM IN THAT
CATEGORY.
SHAWN: I KNOW THIS IS GOING TO
SHOCK SOME PEOPLE, BUT HE HAS
BEEN THE RIGHT-HANDED VERSION OF
MAX MUNCY, WITH ABOUT 150 LESS
AT-BATS.
BUT WHEN HE IS IN THE LINEUP, HE
IS DOING DAMAGE.
SCOTT: PAYOFF, HE WALKS.
DO PLENTY OF THAT AS WELL.
JUST LIKE MUNCY.
SHAWN: OVER 1000 AGAINST
LEFT-HANDED PITCHING.
SCOTT: HE LOVES LEFTIES.
HE HAS BEEN PRETTY GOOD AGAINST
RIGHTIES THIS YEAR.
LOOK AT THE OBP FOR DARIN RUF.
JUST A FEW TAKES UNDER THAT
MARK.
AMONG THE BEST IN THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE.
SHAWN: WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
THIS YESTERDAY WATCHING THE GAME
COME THAT IS WHAT THIS LINEUP
DOES TOP TO BOTTOM -- THEY WORK
COUNTS CAN THEY TAKE PITCHES,
THEY DON'T SWING AND MISS A
WHOLE LOT.
SCOTT: HELLO ESTRADA GOING AFTER
THE FIRST PITCH.
LINES IT TO LEFT.
CHRISTIAN YELICH IS THERE.
HARD HIT BASEBALL RESULTED IN A
FLY BALL OUT, BUT THE GIANTS
COUNTS FIRST AND TAKE THE FIRST
LEAD OF THE SERIES.
IN THE COMMENTARY SECTION,
"WASTING NO TIME."
1-0, SAN FRANCISCO THROUGH ONE.
♪
>> I CANNOT STOP SMILING.
I AM GETTING TO BE HERE.
I'M SO HAPPY.
FAMILY IS HAPPY.
IT IS A NEW CHAPTER IN OUR
LIVES.
WE ARE CLOSING WHEN THAT IS
GREAT AND OPENING WHEN THAT IS
HOPEFULLY BETTER.
COMING TO A TEAM LIKE THIS THAT
HAS SO MUCH HISTORY, WINNING
WAYS AND SO MANY GOOD VETERANS.
I WAS SO EXCITED I
.
I FEEL LIKE THERE IS NO EGO.
YOU HAVE GUYS FILLING HOLES
WHEREVER THEY NEED IT.
THAT IS THE KIND OF TEAM BASE
YOU WANT.
THAT IS WHAT I HOPE TO DO HERE,
TOO.
COMING FROM A TEAM THAT HAD NOT
WON AND 108 YEARS, HAVING THAT
ON YOUR SHOULDERS, IT HELPED IN
ANY PUSHER PLAYOFF RACE.
>> YOU ARE THE MAN, CHRIS.
>> I APPRECIATE IT, GUYS.
LIKE I TOLD HIM WHEN HE FIRST
CALLED ME, I WILL PLAY WHEREVER
YOU WANT ME TO.
I JUST WANT TO WIN.
ONE THING I WAS EXCITED, WEARING
ORANGE AND BLACK.
I TOLD MY WIFE, HOPEFULLY I LOOK
GOOD IN THOSE COLORS.WE
WILL SEE FIRST GAME TODAY.
>> FANS, HE IS HERE, MAKING HIS
GIANTS DEBUT AT THIRD BASE.
NUMBER 23.
KRIS BRYANT.
SCOTT: A LITTLE SUNSHINE IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
ONE OF THE BEST TIMES TO BE AT
THIS BALLPARK.
REALLY ONE OF THE BEST YEARS TO
BE A GIANTS FAN.
I KNOW THEY HAVE QUITE A FEW
TITLES, BUT LOOK AT THE DEAL
THEY PULLED OFF HER KRIS BRYANT
ABOUT A MONTH AND A HALF AGO.
IT GETS US THINKING ABOUT OTHER
NOTABLE DEADLINE ACQUISITIONS
LIKE KEVIN MITCHELL.
JASON SCHMIDT.
JAVIER LOPEZ, THREE WORLD SERIES
TITLES.
AND THEN HUNTER PENCE, OF
COURSE, WHO WAS AT THE BALLPARK
FREQUENTLY.
2010, 2012, 2014, AND EVERY
OTHER YEAR KIND OF THING.
IT IS 2021, AN ODD YEAR, BUT
WORKING FOR THEM.
THERE IS K.B.
LET'S START OUR FIRST POLL
QUESTION.
BEST TRADE LINE ACQUISITION IN
GIANTS HISTORY.
WE GIVE YOU MUTUAL, LOPEZ,
SCHMIDT OR PENCE -- MITCHELL,
LOPEZ, SCHMIDT OR PENCE.
YOU ARE NEW TO THE PARTY, BUT
YOU NEED TO PARTICIPATE AND GIVE
US YOUR ANSWER.
SOMETIMES THAT EVEN HELPS TO
INFLUENCE EVERYONE WATCHING ON
THEIR PHONE OR ON THEIR COMPUTER
OR WHEREVER THEY ARE WATCHING,
TABLET, THEY MIGHT MAKE THEIR
CHOICE BASED ON WHAT TIM DILLARD
SAYS.
SHAWN: I KNOW HUNTER PENCE, NAME
DROP, SO HUNTER PENCE.
SCOTT: LOGAN WEBB PICKS UP HIS
FIRST STRIKEOUT.
SHAWN: I WILL SAY DING, DING,
DING, HUNTER PENCE.
I LIKE WORLD SERIES, I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT YOU, BUT HOCKEY HAS A
BUNCH OF THEM -- JAVI HAS A
BUNCH OF THEM AND I LOVE JAVI.
I WOULD LIKE TO PICK HIM BASED
ON HIM BEING MY BUDDY, BUT UNDER
PENCE AND WHAT HE DID WHEN HE
CAME OVER AS A GIANT, NOT JUST
ON THE FIELD BUT OFF THE FIELD,
WAS HUGE AND THEIR RUN IN
WINNING THE WORLD SERIES IN 2012
AND 2014, JUST THE ENERGY HE
BROUGHT AN PRODUCTION ON THE
FIELD.
IT WAS SOLID.
JUST WHAT HE BROUGHT TO THE
CLUBHOUSE WAS THE DIFFERENCE.
SCOTT: STRIKE TO JACE PETERSON.
ON BASE J'S THEY WERE CALLING
HIM -- ON BASE JACE.
I THOUGHT YOU'RE GOING TO SAY,
YES, YES, YES.
SHAWN: I SHOULD HAVE.
YOU REMEMBER THAT RALLYING CRY
FOR I DON'T KNOW WHAT YEAR IT
WAS. SCOTT: FOR WRESTLING FANS,
THAT IS WHAT DANIEL BRIAN DOES.
IT WAS WORKING.
IT IS ALL WORKING FOR LOGAN WEBB
SO FAR THIS SEASON.
HE PICKS UP ANOTHER STRIKEOUT.
SECONDARY PITCHES HAVE BEEN
SUPERB FOR LOGAN WEBB LATELY AS
WE WATCH IT AGAIN.
LET'S BRING IN AMY G.
AMY?
YOU GOT US?
AMY: YES, I HAVE YOU, GENTLEMEN.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
[STATIC]
SCOTT: WE WILL GET BACK TO AMY.
TIM: WE DON'T HAVE HER.
I KNOW SHE WAS GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THAT NASTY SLIDER WE JUST
SAW.
SCOTT: DANIEL VOGELBACH.
A LITTLE PAINT ON THE OUTSIDE
CORNER.
SHAWN: THAT IS THE THING ABOUT
LOGAN WEBB.
HE HAS A GOOD SINKER TO GET THE
GROUND BALLS BUT HE ALSO HAS A
SWING AND MISS SLIDER.
HE HAS GOT THREE PITCHES THAT HE
CAN GET YOU OUT WITH.
THE LOCATION HAS BEEN HUGE
BECAUSE HE HAS BEEN MAKING THE
PICTURES LOOK LIKE STRIKES.
AND THEN WITH STRIKES, AND THAT
BEAN BALLS -- THEY END UP BEAN
BALLS.
SCOTT: ANOTHER GROUND BALL
PLAYED ON A NICE TOP.
ESTRADA UNFAZED.
FOUR GROUND BALLS, TWO
STRIKEOUTS, SIX UP, SIX DOWN FOR
LOGAN WEBB.
HIS TEAM LEADS AT 1-0.
>> IT IS BRIAN WILSON.
IT IS ALL ON HIM.
>> THE FIRST OUT IS THE BIGGEST
OUT IN ANY CLOSER'S INNING.
JOSH HAMILTON STEPS UP.
HE HAS M.V.P. WALK UP IN MY
HEAD.
I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO GET A
STRIKEOUT.
>> STRIKE THREE CALLED.
>> GET THAT CALL AND THAT FIRST
OUT OF THE WAY.
>> ONE DOWN.
>> VLADIMIR GROUNDOUT ON THE
FIRST PITCH.
NOW WE HAVE TWO OUTS.
>>>> AND THE GIANTS AFTER ALL
THE YEARS OF WAITING ARE ONE OUT
AWAY FROM WINNING THE WORLD
SERIES.
>> THEN I GOT NELSON CRUZ.
I GOT TO TWO STRIKES.
LOOKING AT THE DUGOUT, EVERYONE
IS ON EDGE.
I CAN FEEL THE ELECTRICITY IN
THE CROWD.
>> LET'S GO GIANTS!
>> I'M GOING TO THROW MY BEST
SLIDER OF THE YEAR RIGHT NOW.
HE HITS A HOME RUN, WHATEVER,
GET THE NEXT GUY.
HE SWUNG THROUGH, CALLED STRIKE
THROUGH.
>> SWING AND A MISS!
THAT IS IT!
>> THE DREAM STARTED.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 52
YEARS, THE GIANTS ARE WORLD
CHAMPIONS.
YES!
>> WOO!
AH!
>> THE SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS ARE
THE 2010 WORLD CHAMPIONS.
SCOTT: IT IS THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE, PRESENTED
BY STATE FARM.
SCOTT BRAUN, TIM DILLARD, SHAWN
ESTES, AND ABG JOINING US FROM
THEN FRANCISCO.
EVERYONE WATCHING US WORLDWIDE
ON YOUTUBE THIS AFTERNOON FOR AN
EPIC SHOWDOWN BETWEEN TWO OF THE
BEST IN THE NATIONAL LEAGUE.
BREWERS HAVE TAKEN THE FIRST
THREE IN THIS FOUR GAME SET.
SAN FRANCISCO HAS ACTUALLY
FALLEN OUT OF FIRST PLACE FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN A FEW MONTHS.
THEY ARE HOT HALF GAME BACK OF
THE DODGERS ENTERING THE DAY.
BRANDON CRAWFORD, THE BEST
BATTING AVERAGE SINCE JULY 1.
POWER HAS TICKED DOWN FOR
CRAWFORD LATELY BUT HE HAS BEEN
IN ON BASE MACHINE.
SHAWN: HE HAS HAD AN
UNBELIEVABLE YEAR AND WAS
REWARDED WITH A TWO-YEAR DEAL.
SCOTT: ON THE HANDS.
YELICH WILL TRY FOR OUT NUMBER
ONE.
SHAWN: REWARDED WITH A TWO-YEAR
DEAL.
COMING INTO THE SEASON, A LOT OF
PEOPLE THINKING THIS MAY BE HIS
LAST YEAR.
EVEN MENTIONING HE PROBABLY
WOULD NOT PLAY AGAINST
LEFT-HANDED PITCHING.
HE CAME IN WITH A CHIP ON HIS
SHOULDER, LEAPED HE WAS ONE OF
THE BEST SHORTSTOPS IN THE MAJOR
LEAGUES, AND SAID DO NOT FORGET
ABOUT ME.
I AM STILL HERE.
AS IT MAKING THE ALL-STAR TEAM.
TWO-YEAR DEAL.
UNBELIEVABLE DEFENSIVELY.
YOU MENTIONED JULY 1, HE HAS
COOLED OFF AS OF LATE.
BUT HE WILL SHOW UP WHEN IT
COUNTS THE MOST.
SCOTT: GOOD THING YOU STUCK WITH
HIM, TWO YEARS, $32 MILLION.
NOT BAD.
A WHIP FROM CURT CASALI.
DOES IT MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE,
TIM, ON WHO YOUR CATCHER IS?
TIM: IT DOES AT TIMES.
YOU HAVE TO TRUST THE GUY.
IF YOU ARE 100% BEHIND THE PITCH
ANTI-CALL SOMETHING DIFFERENT,
YOU SHAKE OFF, AND HE CALLS THE
SAME THING AGAIN, YOU HAVE TO
SAY, OK, DO I KNOW THIS GUY WELL
ENOUGH?
WHAT I LET HIM BABYSIT MY KIDS
TYPE ATTITUDE, AND IF YOU WOULD,
YOU GO WITH HIM.
YOU NEED THAT COMMUNICATION.
SCOTT: CASALI MUST BE SOME KIND
OF BABYSITTER.
A BALL AND TWO STRIKES.
LOGAN WEBB HAS A 1.629 E.R.A.
WHEN CASALI IS BEHIND THE DISH.
IT IS 3.18 AND 12 STARTS WITH
POSEY.
NO KNOCK ON BUSTER, BUT THEY
REALLY ENJOY WORKING WITH CURT
CASALI, WHO IS DOWN ON STRIKES,
THE FIRST PUNCH OUT FOR ERIC
LAUER.
TIM: WHO HAS GOT TO FACE IN THE
NINTH INNING, JOSH EGGER?
HERE'S A CHANGEUP, SLIDER,
FASTBALL.
SHAWN: AND HE THREW HIM
CHANGEUPS ON TOP OF THAT.
WAS NOT EVEN FAIR.
SCOTT: HE HAD AND NASTY
CHANGE OF LAST NIGHT.
SHAWN: YOU MENTIONED HE WORKED
ON THAT CHANGEUP WITH DEVIN
WILLIAMS.
TIM: THEY ARE THROWING PARTNERS.
THEY PLAY CATCH EVERY DAY.
YOU SQUAT DOWN IN THE GRASS AND
YOU ARE CATCHING IT, AND THEY
THROW NASTY PITCHES.
I HAVE NEVER HAD THAT.
SCOTT: [LAUGHTER]
SHAWN: AND WILLIAMS IS HELPING
HADER OUT WITH HIS CHANGEUP.
YOU THROW 99, WHY DO YOU NEED A
CHANGEUP?
WE SAW LAST NIGHT.
HE STOLE A COUPLE STRIKES.
A CHANGEUP THAT WAS NASTY.
THAT HEATER OUT OF THE STRIKE
ZONE.
IT IS UNFAIR.
SPEAKING OF HEATERS ABOVE THE
ZONE, THAT IS WHAT LAUER LIKES
TO THROW, AS WELL.
SCOTT:SCOTT: HE IS PUMPING THEM
IN.
0-2.
GOING THE OTHER WAY.
SHOUTING BACK AS GARCIA AND THE
OUT IS RECORDED.
MONTAS WE'LL SIT DOWN THIS --
LAUER WILL SIT DOWN THE SIDE.
THE GIANTS LEAVE AT 1-0 AFTER
TWO.
>> YOU COULD NOT HELP BUT WATCH
GORMAN THOMAS, GOOD, FEROCIOUS,
BREW CREW PERSONIFIED.
>> GORMAN WAS A GUY THE TOWN
FELL IN LOVE WITH AN IDENTIFIED
WITH.
>> BATTING AVERAGE IS OVERRATED.
IN THE NAME OF THE GAME, IT IS
R.B.I.'S.
>> FROM 1978 THROUGH 1982, NO
PLAYER HIT MORE HOME RUNS THAN
GORMAN.
>> IT WAS FABULOUS.
>> BASE HIT.
>> THERE WAS ALWAYS SOMEONE ON
BASE.
>> RUNNERS AT THE CORNERS AND
NOBODY OUT.
LINED UP THE MIDDLE FOR A BASE
HIT.
GORMAN THOMAS REALLY COMES ALIVE
WHEN HE HAS RUNNERS ON BASE.
>> ALTHOUGH HE DID NOT LOOK LIKE
YOUR PROTOTYPICAL CENTER
FIELDER, GORMAN GOT THE JOB
DONE.
>> LEAST CENTER FIELD
OUTFIELDER YOU WOULD IMAGINE.
HE WAS BIG.
HE WAS NOT FAST.
HE LOOKED A LITTLE OUT OF SHAPE.
>> WHAT HE LACKED IN STYLE,
THOMAS MADE UP FOR WITH SHEER
HUSTLE AND AGGRESSIVENESS.
>> GORMAN DID NOT LEAVE ANYTHING
ON THE TABLE.
HE GAVE YOU EVERYTHING HE HAD
THAT DAY.
SCOTT: THERE IS EDUARDO ESCOBAR.
HE SHOULD BE BACKS IN THE MIX
FOR THE BREWERS TOMORROW.
THEY TRAIL 1-0.
FANS WATCHING THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK, YOU HAVE YOUR CHOICE
LISTENING EXPERIENCE.
HERE IS YOUR ICON, THERE YOU GO.
CHOOSE AUDIO TRACK, SELECT
PRIMARY BROADCAST OR SELECT
HOME, AWAY CALL, WHOEVER IS
DOING THIS RIGHT NOW IS DOING AN
EXCELLENT JOB.
ALL AUDIO SEAMLESSLY INTEGRATED
ON DEVICES SO YOU DON'T MISS A
MINUTE.
GO BACK AND FORTH.
HAVE FUN WITH IT.
ALSO, WE LOVE THIS ON YOUTUBE,
OUR FIRST POLL QUESTION.
BEST TRADE DEADLINE ADDITION IN
GIANTS HISTORY.I
AM SURE HUNTER PENCE IS WATCHING
RIGHT NOW.
HE TAKES THE TITLE.
TIM AND SHAWN AGREED.
66% OF THE VOTE.
2012 WAS A PRETTY GOOD-LOOKING
YEAR FOR THE GIANTS.
I WILL TAKE ONE COMMENT FROM ONE
OF OUR YOUTUBE CREATORS, JACKIE
BRADLEY JR. FOULS OFF THE FIRST
PITCH FROM LOGAN WEBB IN THE
THIRD.
MADE THE CUT SAYS HANDS DOWN
HUNTER PENCE BECAUSE IN BOTH THE
CLUBHOUSE AND ON THE FIELD HE
WAS SUCH A MASSIVE PICKUP.
ECHOING WHAT YOU SAID, SHAWN.
SHAWN: NASTY SLIDER.
YOU GUYS GOT ME IN TROUBLE WITH
JAVY.
HE TEXT ME AND SAID YOU ARE DEAD
TO ME.
YOU FINISHED SECOND, I AM SORRY.
I WAS FOLLOWING DYLAN.
-- DILLON.
WHOEVER HE PICKS.
TIM: YOU ARE SO NERVOUS, YOU
MAKE ME NERVOUS.
SCOTT: WE HAVE A FEW MORE TO GO.
THE PRESSURE IS ON.
THERE IS THE SHIFT AGAINST
BRADLEY JUNIOR.
THAT WAS NO PROBLEM FOR BRANDON
CRAWFORD A COUPLE OF INNINGS
AGO.
AN EXCELLENT PLAY TO RETIRE
YELICH IN THE FIRST.
BRADLEY STRIKES OUT.
A TOUGH SEASON FOR HIM AT THE
PLATE.
WEBB HAS PLAYED NUMBER THREE ON
THE AFTERNOON.
SHAWN: ANOTHER SLIDER.
TWO STRIKE.
IT IS NOT THE PITCH AS MUCH AS
THE LOCATION.
IT IS A STRIKEOUT AT HIS HAND.
SUCH GOOD LATE BITE TO IT IN THE
ZONE.
A LOT OF SWINGS AND MISSES WITH
THAT PITCH.
HE HAS BEEN DOING AS
EFFICIENTLY, AS WELL.
MAKING QUICK HIT OF THESE
BREWERS HITTERS.
SCOTT: THEY WOULD LOVE A LENGTHY
OUTING FOR WEB -- FIRM WEBB.
THE GIANTS HAD TO -- FROM WEBB.
THE GIANTS WOULD HAVE TO
IMPLEMENT A BULLPEN GAME BECAUSE
JOHNNY CUETO WAS SCRATCHED.
HE EVENTUALLY ENDED UP ON THE
INJURED LIST.
WHEN CUETO PITCHED, THAT WAS IN
PLACE OF ALEX WOOD ON THE COVID
I.L. AT THE MOMENT.
THE GIANTS ARE BATTLING A BIT
WITH THEIR ROTATION AT THE
MOMENT.
HE IS WASTING NO TIME.
SHAWN: THIS IS ONE GUY NOT
BATTLING.
TIM: HE ALREADY HAS FIVE IN THE
GAME.
HE IS THROWING STRIKES WITH ALL
HIS PITCHES.
HE IS NOT GOING HERE'S MY
FASTBALL.
HE IS MIXING IT UP.
CHANGEUP.
SLIDER.
SCOTT: LUKE MAILE, COMEBACKER
FROM WEBB.
TWO.
SHAWN: THAT IS THE THING ABOUT
LOGAN WEBB.
IF HE HAS A PITCH WORKING FOR
HIM, THE SINKER, SLIDER,
CHANGEUP, HE WILL SAY, OK -- AND
HE CAN LOCATE A SLIDER AND SAY
YOU WILL HAVE TO BEAT ME WITH
THIS PITCH.
UNTIL YOU DO, THIS IS WHAT YOU
WILL SEE A STEADY DIET OF.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT THE SINKER
A BIG PICTURE HIM, BUT THIS
YEAR, HITTERS ARE ONLY HITTING
.161 OFF OF HIS SLIDER WITH 60
STRIKEOUTS.
THAT HAS BEEN A BIG PITCH FOR
HIM, AS WELL.
SCOTT: LAUER DOES HAVE ONE HOME
RUN THIS SEASON.
I AM TRYING TO WORK IN THE PITCH
COUNT.
THERE YOU GO.
STRIKE DOWN THE PIPE.
I WILL GET THIS QUESTION FOR YOU
GUYS BEFORE WE TALK TO KEVIN
GAUSMAN, WHO JOINS US IN THE
NEXT HAPPENING.
YOUTUBE CREATORS, YOU KNOW WHAT
TO DO.
SEND US YOUR QUESTIONS.
MADE THE CUT SAID BETTER
OFF-SPEED PITCHES.
WEBB OR GAUSMAN?
YOU WATCH HIM MORE, SO I GO TO
YOU FIRST.
SHAWN: THAT IS A PRETTY GOOD
ONE.
SCOTT: SHAWN WILL ANSWER LATER
BECAUSE LOGAN WEBB IS OH SO
ECONOMICAL THIS AFTERNOON.
NINE UP, NINE DOWN, AND HIS
SUPER TEAMMATE, KEVIN GAUSMAN,
IS GOING TO JOIN US ON YOUTUBE
IN A MOMENT.
♪
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> GREAT BASEBALL RIGHT THERE.
THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO.
>> THAT BALL IS CRUSHED.
>> AND THIS IS GOING TO DO IT.
OH MY.
>> STRIKE THREE.
THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
>> WE TALKED ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS.
THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
SHAWN: CATCHER-PITCHER
CHEMISTRY, LET'S DO THAT.
>> DO YOU WANT TO BE FRIENDS
WITH ME TODAY?
WE CAN BE FRIENDS.
>> PUELLO.
-- FAIL.
1-2.
1-2
CHECK, CHECK.
>> THIS KEEPS HITTING THE BALL
BUT NOT FINDING ANYTHING BUT
SOME LUCKY PLAY.
THEY ARE BOTH SMOOTH.
SCOTT: AGREED, DANIEL VOGELBACH.
OR ROWDY TELLEZ.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
BIG BOYS AT FIRST BASE.
ROWDY IS MIC'ED UP FOR US
TODAY, PROVIDE SOMETHING EXTRA
AUDIO WISE ALL DAY LONG.
THANK YOU, ROWDY.
TIM: IT IS PROBABLY BETTER HE IS
NOT PLAYING.
SCOTT: YOU GET MORE COMMENTARY.
TIM: WE PROBABLY WILL GET GOOD
STUFF.
SHAWN: NO ONE IS GOING TO STAND
AROUND HIM.
HE CAN STILL GO TO OTHER GUYS
AND CHASE THEM AROUND THE
DUGOUT.
SCOTT: CAN YOU IMAGINE IF TIM
DILLARD WAS MIKED UP BACK ON THE
DAY WITH THE BREWERS?
YOU WOULD HAVE WALKED UP TO EACH
PLAYER AND ALMOST ON AN
INTERVIEW SHOW.
TIM: I AM WAY TOO SCARED.
SHAWN: IT WOULD BE A THREE HOUR
COMEDY.
TIM: THERE WAS SO MUCH ANXIETY.
NOW I AM LIKE, I CAN ENJOY A
BALLGAME.
SCOTT: IT IS FUN.
LOGAN WEBB FOULS THE FIRST PAGE
WITH LAUER BACK SINCE WE START
THE HOME THIRD.
WE ARE PLEASED TO BE JOINED BY
KEVIN GAUSMAN.
THANKS FOR THE TIME.
HOW ARE YOU?
KEVIN: THANKS FOR HAVING ME,
GUYS.
NO PROBLEM.
SCOTT: WE HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
FROM YOUTUBERS IN A MOMENT.
LET'S START WITH YOUR THOUGHTS
YESTERDAY.
IT WAS NOT THE RESULT FOR THE
TEAM YESTERDAY IN THE END, HOW
DID YOU FEEL ABOUT YOUR
PERFORMANCE YESTERDAY?
KEVIN: I FELT ALL RIGHT.
I ALWAYS TRY TO GET DEEPER IN
THE GAME, BUT TRYING TO PUT
SOMETHING TOGETHER OFFENSIVELY.
ALEX DICKERSON CAME IN,
PINCH-HIT FOR ME, HIT A DOUBLE,
AND KRIS BRYANT CAME UP AND PUT
A GOOD SWING ON THE BALL AND HIT
A DOUBLE AND SCORED A RUN.
WE WERE ABLE TO TIE IT UP.
YOU KNOW, THAT IS JUST NATIONAL
LEAGUE BASEBALL FOR YOU
SOMETIMES.
SCOTT: THAT IS RIGHT.
LOGAN WEBB GOES DOWN ON STRIKES.
ACTUALLY, SPEAKING OF WHICH,
LET'S GET OUR FIRST QUESTION
FROM YOUTUBE CREATOR.
DAWSON RIGHT ASKS, HOW
IMPRESSIVE HAS IT BEEN SEEING
THE EMERGENCE OF MR. WEBB THIS
SEASON?
KEVIN: IT HAS BEEN A LOT OF FUN.
LOGAN WEBB IS SOMEONE I HAVE
BEEN PLAYING CATCH WITH.
TO JUST SEE THE CONSISTENCY KIND
OF COME DAY IN AND DAY OUT, AND
THIS CONFIDENCE LEVEL, YOU CAN
SEE IT ON HIS FACE.
HE SHOWS UP AND EXPECTS TO WIN
AND PITCH WELL.
FOR A YOUNG PITCHER, WHEN YOU
REALIZE IT DOES NOT MATTER WHO
YOU ARE FACING, IF YOU CAN
EXECUTE PITCHES, YOU CAN HAVE
SUCCESS.
IT IS A HUGE LEARNING CURVE.
HIS PITCH HAS MOVED SO MUCH, IT
IS JUST A MATTER OF BEING ABLE
TO B AROUND THE ZONE
ENOUGH WHERE THE GUYS RESPECTED.
IF HE CAN GET AHEAD OF GUYS, HE
IS PRETTY NASTY.
SHAWN: KEVIN, SHAWN ESTES YEAR,
TIM DILLARD, AS WELL.
WE WERE GOING TO BE ASKED YOU TO
QUESTION EARLIER, FORTUNATELY,
WE DID NOT GET A CHANCE TO
ANSWER.
SINCE WE HAVE YOU ON THE
BROADCAST NOW, THE QUESTION WAS,
WHO HAS THE NASTIER OFFSPEED
STUFF, YOU ARE LOGAN WEBB? --
YOU OR LOGAN WEBB?
KEVIN: I WOULD HAVE TO SAY WEBBY
BECAUSE HE HAS TWO.
HE HAS A NASTY SLIDER AND NASTY
CHANGEUP.
TODAY HE THREW A CHANGEUP AT 90
MILES AN HOUR.
IT WENT STRAIGHT DOWN.
HIS ABILITY TO MAKE A BALL MOVE
IS REALLY IMPRESSIVE, AND A LOT
OF FUN TO WATCH.
I WOULD SAY HIM.
YOU KNOW, I MIGHT SPLIT CAN BE
REALLY GOOD, BUT EVEN ON HIS TWO
SAME IS CRAZY AT TIMES --
TWO-SEAMER IS CRAZY AT TIMES.
HE IS A GUY WHO CAN THROW A
SLIDER 20 INCHES HORIZONTAL AND
A FASTBALL THAT MOVES 20 INCHES
HORIZONTAL, YOU KNOW?
IT IS FUN TO WATCH HIM JUST KIND
OF MOVE AROUND THE BALL.
HE IS A GUY, KIND OF LIKE COREY
KLUBER,, THE AMOUNT OF MOVEMENT
HE GETS IS IMPRESSIVE.
SCOTT: THERE IT IS.
AUSTIN SLATER IS HOOKING THEM UP
WITH A COUPLE OF HITS SO FAR.
THE ONLY TWO WE HAVE SEEN THIS
AFTERNOON COME FROM AUSTIN
SLATER.
A HOME RUN ON THE FIRST PITCH AT
THE BOTTOM OF THE FIRST.
THEN GOES TO THE VACATED RIGHT
SIDE.
FIRST SINGLE WITH ONE OUT IN THE
BOTTOM OF THE THIRD.
WE ARE HANGING OUT WITH KEVIN
GAUSMAN.
TIM: HEY, KEVIN.
TIM DILLARD.
YOU ARE A STARTING PITCHER, YOU
HAVE A SPLITFINGER.
A LOT OF TIMES COACHES DON'T
TEACH THAT ANYMORE.
CAN YOU GIVE BACKSTORY?
I KNOW IT IS TAXING ON THE ARM.
HOW MUCH DO YOU THROW IT?
I JUST WANT TO HEAR THE STORY
BEHIND IT BECAUSE I TRIED IT
OVER SEVERAL YEARS.
IT IS SUCH A TOUGH PITCHED A
MASTER.
AND HOW DO YOU STAY HEALTHY
DOING IT?
KEVIN: HEALTHWISE, I REALLY DO
NOT KNOW WHY.
I THINK IT IS BECAUSE I DO NOT
THROW AN ACTUAL TRUE SPLIT, YOU
KNOW?
IT IS MORE PACHE LIKE.
IT IS LIKE TIM LINCECUM USED TO
THROW.
I THINK THAT WEAR AND TEAR AND
COMPARED TO WHEN YOU THROW A
TRUE SPLIT, IT TOOK ME,
HONESTLY, FIVE YEARS TO FEEL
COMFORTABLE AND CONFIDENT AND
FOR IT TO BE CONSISTENT.
FOR ME, I WAS A GUY, I WAS
TYPICAL, A YOUNG GUY, THROUGH
HARD -- THREW HARD, HAD NO IDEA
WHERE THE BALL WAS GOING FOR I
HAD A PRETTY GOOD CURVEBALL BUT
COULD NEVER THROW A CHANGEUP.
I ACTUALLY HAD MY J.V. PITCHING
COACH, CHRIS BALM, PITCHED IN
TRIPLE-A FOR A COUPLE OF TEAMS,
AND HE WAS LIKE, HEY, I T
REW THIS, WHY DON'T YOU -- I
THREW THIS, WHY DON'T YOU TRY
THIS?
I DO NOT FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH
IT UNTIL GOING TO COLLEGE.
GROWING UP IN COLORADO IN HIGH
SCHOOL, I DO NOT NEED THE
CHANGEUP TO BE HONEST.
BASEBALL WAS NOT VERY GOOD
THERE, TO BE HONEST.
SCOTT: [LAUGHTER]
KEVIN: I HAD GUYS I WOULD THROW
HEATERS.
A LOT OF GROUND BALLS.
IT WAS A PITCH THAT HAS TAKEN A
LONG TIME.
IT IS A LOT OF FUN.
IT IS DEFINITELY FRUSTRATING AT
TIMES.
IT HAS A MIND OF ITS OWN AT
CERTAIN TIMES, BUT, WHEN IT IS
ON, IT IS A LOT OF FUN.
SCOTT: YOU JUST SAW YOUR
TEAMMATE BRANDON BELT FLY OUT TO
CENTER.
TWO ON, TWO OUT.
AFTER THE SLIDER SINGLE, AN
ERROR AGAINST JACE PETERSON, THE
THIRD BASEMAN.
A COUPLE OF MORE MINUTES WITH
KEVIN GAUSMAN, OR HOPEFULLY
MORE, FOR YOUR SAKE.
IF THE GIANTS CAN ADD ON WITH
DARIN RUF, I WILL HIT YOU WITH
THE HARD STUFF.
THIS IS FROM AUSTIN, KEVIN, IF
YOU HAD TO CHOOSE, WOULD SPEND
TODAY KAYAKING IN THE CUBBY COVE
OR HEAD TO ALCATRAZ FOR THE FULL
TOUR EXPERIENCE WOULD BE A KIND
OF DAY?
KEVIN: THE CUBBY COVE FOR SURE.
THAT IS SOMETHING I ALWAYS THINK
IS SO COOL.
IT IS NOT MATTER WHAT TIME THE
GAME IS, WHETHER 12:45 OR 7:00
AT NIGHT, THERE SOMEBODY OUT
THERE WAITING ON A/BALL.
I THINK -- EIGHT/BALL.
I GREW UP -- A SPLASH BALL.
I GREW UP A GIANTS FAN.
.
I HAD A BUDDY IN TOWN WHO IS
DECIDING IF HE WAS GOING TO DO
THAT TODAY.
I'M INTERESTED TO SEE IF HE IS
OUT THERE WAITING FOR ONE.
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT WOULD
BE REALLY COOL TO GO OUT THERE
ONE DAY AND HOPEFULLY CATCH ONE.
THAT WOULD BE AWESOME.
SHAWN: KEVIN, SHAWN AGAIN.
I DO NOT THINK PEOPLE NOTICE
ABOUT YOU, YOU ARE HAVING A
SNEAKY GOOD YEAR AT THE PLATE,
BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
YOU HAVE NOT HAD A WHOLE LOT OF
AT-BATS, BUT YOU ARE HITTING
ALMOST 200.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW HOW MUCH
PRIDE YOU TAKE IN YOUR HITTING?
DO YOU WORK ON IT A BUNCH?
NOT TO SAY YOU WOULD HAVE GONE
OFF THE WALL LIKE DICKERSON LAST
NIGHT, BUT YOU ARE AROUND.
KEVIN: I TRY TO GET IN THE CAGE
EVERY DAY AND SEE PITCHES.
WE HAVE THIS MACHINE IN THERE
THAT REALLY, BROUGHT TO SPRING
TRAINING.
THEY GOT THESE FOAM WALLS, AND
THE MOVEMENT ON THEM IS CRAZY.
WITH GUYS STUFF NOWADAYS, YOU
FEEL LIKE GETTING IN THERE EVERY
DAY AND SEEING NASTY PITCHES,
RISING FASTBALL, SINKERS,
CUTTERS, WHATEVER PITCH A GUY
THROWS, THEY CAN PUT IT TOGETHER
AND MAKE IT, YOU KNOW, MAKE IT
RESEMBLE IT.
GOING IN THERE AND BUNTING OFF
THAT HELPS.
IT HELPS YOUR CONFIDENCE, BUT IT
IS DEFINITELY A LOT OF LUCK.
YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES YOUR EYES
ARE CLOSED WHEN YOU ARE
SWINGING.
YOU TRY TO DO SOMETHING WHILE
YOU'RE UP THERE.
SCOTT: IT IS WORKING.
KEEP IT UP.
KEVIN, THANK YOU.
GOOD LUCK THE REST OF THE WAY.
1-0 GIANTS AFTER THREE.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
>> MAKE FUN OF ME WITH MY
BALLCLUB?
♪
>> SINKER IN THE HEAD.
>> HEART IS PALPITATING.
>> YES.
>> TELL US MAYBE HOW DO YOU FEEL
ABOUT THIS YOUNG TALENT?
YOU HAVE A LOT OF DOMINICAN
KIDS.
>> HE IS UP NEXT.
YOU GOT AGO.
>> HE HAS GOT TO HIT.
HE IS ON DECK.
>> THIS IS BEFORE THE INNING.
BO BICHETTE ALL OF A SUDDEN,
SOMETHING HIT HIM.
A BEE STING OR SOMETHING.
JUST BEFORE THIS HALF INNING
BEGAN.
>> PROBABLY A BIG SURPRISE.
YOU STAND OUT THERE AND
SOMETHING BIT HIM.
>> STAYS ALIVE.
YOU JUST NEVER KNOW WITH VOTTO
AS THE BASIS JED WOLF.
>> THE HOME RUN JACKET.
HE CANNOT FIT IT ON.
HOW LONG DO YOU HAVE TO WEAR
THAT?
I THINK YOU SHOULD HAVE TO PLAY
DEFENSE WITH IT FOR HALF AN
INNING.
>> AND A GOOD READ.
WAS NOT GRACEFUL, BUT IT WAS
EFFECTIVE.
HE IS HAVING AN ADVENTURE
SOMETIME.
>> HE HAD NO BALANCE, LIKE A
WEEVIL.
>> IT WAS CRAZY, RIGHT?
SCOTT: I MEAN, DOES IT GET ANY
BETTER THAN THAT?
THAT IS OUR VIEW.
THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE IS PRESENTED BY STATE
FARM.
IT IS THE FIRST-PLACE MILWAUKEE
BREWERS IN NATIONAL LEAGUE
CENTRAL MATCHING UP WITH THE
SECOND PLACE SAN FRANCISCO
GIANTS IN THE N.L. WEST.
LOGAN WEBB BACK TO WORK.
TOP OF THE ORDER FOR MILWAUKEE.
IT IS KOLTEN WONG.
NINE UP, NINE DOWN FOR MR. WEBB.
NO FLYBALL OUTS YET FROM LONG.
NO -- FROM WONG.
NO LIFT FROM A TEAM THAT IS
PLENTY OF IT.
SHAWN: TOUGH TO LIFT A GOOD
SINKER.
TIM: WE ARE SPOT ON RIGHT NOW.
YOU WITH THE GROUND BALLS, ME
WITH THE POT FLIES. --
POP-FLIES.
SCOTT: IF YOU LISTEN TO THESE
GUYS, YOU WILL LEARN SOMETHING,
I THINK.
SHAWN: WE TALKED ABOUT THE
SINKER YESTERDAY AND THE
INABILITY TO LIFT THAT LIKE ALL
THE HITTERS HAVE BEEN DOING
LATELY.
SCOTT: AND WONG IS DOWN ON
STRIKES.
LOGAN WEBB'S FIFTH PUNCH OUT
THIS AFTERNOON.
AMY G, LOGAN WEBB IS LOOKING
GOOD.
AMY: HE IS, AND I GET TO ADD ON
TO THE LOVEFEST FOR LOGAN WEBB.
ANOTHER GIANT, PROVOST --
ANOTHER GIANT IMPRESSED.
BUSTER POSEY HOSTED AN EVENT
YESTERDAY AND THE QUESTION WAS,
WHO DO YOU LIKE CATCHING THE
MOST?
LESTER SAID LOGAN WEBB.
-- BUSTER SAID LOGAN WEBB.
SINCE HE HAS COME BACK FROM AN
INJURY, HE HAS BEEN ON FIRE.
BUSTER SAID IT IS FUN TO WATCH A
PITCHER BELIEVING IN HIMSELF AND
THE RESULTS THAT SHOW UP ON THE
FIELD.
TIM AND  SHAWNIE, I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU REMEMBER THAT CAREER WHEN
YOU FELT LIKE YOU TURNED A
CORNER AND STARTED TO BELIEVE IN
YOURSELF?
TIM: I WAS ABOUT TO SAY, THAT IS
WHY I AM UP HERE.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: I WAS WAITING FOR ONE OF
THOSE.
TIM, HE HAS GOT THE LINES.
TIM: THAT IS ALL I HAVE GOT.
IT IS IMPORTANT WHEN YOU REACH
THAT MOMENT AND FIGURE OUT WHAT
KIND OF PLAYER YOU ARE.
I WAS DRAFTED TWICE AS A
CATCHER.
WHEN YOU SEE SOMEONE WITH THAT
LIGHTBULB THAT GOES OFF, IT
SHOULD BE FUN TO CATCH THOSE
GUYS.
IT IS LIKE PLAYING A VIDEOGAME
IN REAL LIFE.
SCOTT: URIAS INTO THE CORNER.
THAT WILL PUNCH OFF THE WALL AND
TURN INTO A STANDUP DOUBLE.
A1 OUT DOUBLE FOR URIAS:.
-- FOR URIAS.
SHAWN: THAT WAS AN INTERESTING
AT-BAT.
HE HITS A BALL HARD OVER THE
PLATE, 93 AWAY.
I THOUGHT OFF THE BAT IT WAS
GOING TO BE FOUL.
HE LOOKED AT IT.
SLATER THAT IT, HE THOUGHT HE
GOT A BALL?
IT HITS OFF THE BRICKS.
SLATER ALMOST MAKES A GOOD PLAY.
HE HAD A CHANCE OF SECOND BASE
IF HE FIELDED IT CLEANLY.
TIM: I THINK HE THOUGHT IT WAS
GOING TO BE FOUL.
HE HAD TO MAKE UP WITH IT FOR
THE -- MAKE UP FOR IT WITH THE
LEGS.
MAYBE IT WAS THOSE WIND GUST YOU
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER.
SCOTT: CHRISTIAN YELICH TAKES
ONE IN TIGHT.
SHAWN: THIS WILL BE INTERESTING
--
TO SEE BECAUSE LOGAN WEBB HAD A
GOOD WINDUP.
WE ALREADY SAW HIS WORST PICTURE
OF THE DAY LOCATION WISE TO
CHRISTIAN YELICH.
WE WILL SEE IF HE CAN GET IT
BACK OUT OF THE STRETCH.
I THOUGHT IT WAS TOUGHER FOR
GUYS AT SECOND BASE OUT OF THE
STRETCH THEM FIRST.
YOU ARE USED TO LOOKING OVER
YOUR SHOULDER.
WHEN THEY GET A GUY ON SECOND
BASE, YOU LOOK OVER THE OTHER
SHOULDER.
IT CAN MESS WITH YOUR TIMING A
LITTLE BIT AND YOU CAN SOMETIMES
AT A LITTLE BIT TOO QUICK TO
HOME PLATE.
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE SEEING IN
THE FIRST TWO PITCHES TO YELICH.
TIM: IT IS INTERESTING IN SPRING
TRAINING, THEY HARP ON IT AND
YOU LOSE FOCUS DURING THE
BASEBALL SEASON, BUT PITCHERS
HAVE TO WORK ON THAT.
AS RIDICULOUS AS YOU FEEL
SOMETIMES IN THE BULLPEN WHERE
IT IS YOU, THE CATCHER AND
COACH, YOU HAVE TO LOOK OVER
YOUR RIGHT SHOULDER LIKE A WALL
BEHIND YOU BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
WORK ON THE TIMING AND WHAT IS
GOING ON BEHIND YOU.
YOU CANNOT JUST WORK WITH THE
CATCHER AND YOUR CRAFT.
IF YOU DON'T PRACTICE IT IN THE
BULLPEN, THE GAME SPEEDS UP ON
YOU -- SNEAKS UP ON YOU.
SCOTT: YES, SPORTS GAMING
UNIVERSE, IN THE COMMENTARY
SECTION, WHO SAID, ARE WE GOING
TO BE ALERT ON WEBB TODAY FOR
THAT THING THAT SHOULD NOT BE
SPOKEN ABOUT?
YES, THAT IS THE FIRST HIT OF
THE DAY FOR THE BREW CREW.
THAT BEING IT IS A NO-NO.
HE DID IT THROUGH THREE INNINGS,
AND NOW A FOUR PITCHCAST FOR
CHRISTIAN YELICH TO PHILIP FIRST
BASE.
TIM: A COUPLE OF THINGS YOU LOOK
FOR IN STARTING PITCHERS,
ESPECIALLY IF THEY GET A NICER
RHYTHM EARLY AND DO NOT GIVE UP
A HIT IS HOW THEY'RE GOING TO DO
THE SECOND TIME THROUGH THE
ORDER OR IF SO MANY GETS ON
BASE.
WE SAW THE FIRST EXAMPLE OF
THAT.
GUY GETS ON BASE AND THEN HE
LOSES HIS FEEL FOR THE STRIKE
ZONE.
LET'S SEE HOW QUICK IT TAKES FOR
HIM TO GET IT BACK.
UNFORTUNATELY, HE WILL HAVE TO
FACE THE MIDDLE PART OF THE
LINEUP AND NAVIGATE THROUGH
THEM.
AND YOU STILL HAVE TO MAKE
PITCHES.
THAT IS WHAT IS TOUGH ABOUT
PITCHING.
YOU CANNOT JUST MAKE MISTAKES
AND SAY, HIT IT.
YOU STILL HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
MAKE YOUR PITCHES.
SCOTT: I NOTICE ONLY THE FOURTH,
WITH TWO TEAMS THAT KNOW HOW TO
PITCH, THIS IS ONE OF THE
MARQUEE MATCHUPS.
AVISAIL GARCIA WATCHES ONE SALE
INSIDE.
GARCIA HAS A FEW AT-BATS IN HIS
CAREER AGAINST WEB.
ONE WAS A HOME RUN.
HE HAS DELIVERED WITH RUNNERS IN
SCORING POSITION.
HE HAS BEEN ONE OF THEIR BEST
OVERALL ALL-AROUND PLAYERS AND
HAS KICKED IT INTO ANOTHER GEAR
SINCE JULY.
TIM: THAT HOME RUN CAME WHEN
THEY DO STOP IN MILWAUKEE.
IT WAS ON A SLIDER.
NOT A BAD SLIDER.
WE LOOKED AT IT OVER AND OVER.
HE WAS LOOKING AT IT BECAUSE IS
KRYPTONITE WAS SLIDERS AWAY, AND
IT CAUGHT JUST ENOUGH PLATE.
GOOD HITTING BY GARCIA.
YOU GO BACK TO THE FIRST AT-BAT
WHERE HE STRUCK OUT, IT WAS THE
BASKETBALL OUT.
PITCHERS REMEMBER.
THEY KNOW WHO'S IN THE BOX.
-- FASTBALL OUT.
PITCHERS REMEMBER.
THEY KNOW WHO WAS IN THE BOX.
SCOTT: IT WAS A MONTH AGO GARCIA
FACED WEBB AND THE BREWERS.
BALL AND TWO STRIKES.
SHAWN: IT TOOK ABOUT FIVE
PITCHES TO GET THAT RELEASE
POINT OUT OF THE STRETCH.
THAT WAS A HUGE PITCH ON A1-ONE
COUNT -- ON 1-1 COUNT.
I BELIEVE THAT WAS A CHANGEUP.
NASTY.
BOTTOM JUST FELL OUT OF IT.
HE WILL THROW HIS CHANGEUP, NOT
JUST TO LEFTIES.
TYPICALLY YOU SEE A LOT OF
RIGHT-HANDERS.
HE WILL THROW HIS CHANGEUP TO
RIGHTIES, AS WELL.
TIM: THAT IS PEOPLE.
IN RIGHTY  -- THAT ISEVIL.
RIGHTY-ON-RIGHTY IS WRONG.
SHAWN: I WAS A LEFTY WHAT I
FACED -- WHEN I FACED A LEFTY,
THEY DID NOT SEE A LOT OF LEFTY
ON LEFTY CHANGEUPS.
LATER, I STARTED THROWING THAT
PITCH AND WOULD GET A LOT OF
LOOK BACKS LIKE WHAT ARE YOU
DOING THROWING ME A CHANGEUP?
TIM: EXPLAIN YOURSELF, SIR.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: NO CALL THERE.
ANGEL HERNANDEZ CALLING BALLS
AND STRIKES THIS AFTERNOON.
THAT MISSED IN.
WE HAVE GOT THE VANTAGE POINT.
SHAWN: CASALI STEPPING AWAY.
HE WANTS HIM TO FINISH THAT UP
FRONT, DOWN AND AWAY.
GOT A LITTLE QUICK WITH THE
FRONT SIDE.
THAT HAPPENS FROM TIME TO TIME.
FLATTENS OUT AND BACKS UP ON
YOU, AS WE SAW WITH THE SLIDER.
DID NOT QUITE CATCH THE INSIDE
CORNER.
SCOTT: URIAS AND YELICH ARE ON
FOR GARCIA.
2-2 ON ITS WAY.
GOT HIM.
SIX STRIKEOUTS ALREADY FOR LOGAN
WEBB.
THAT WAS A BIG ONE.
SHAWN: THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN HIS
BEST SINKER.
HE HAS THROWN A BUNCH OF GOOD
ONES THIS GAME.
THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN HIS BEST
SINKER.
STARTED DOWN THE MIDDLE OF THE
PLATE, DOWN AND IN, GARCIA
SWINGS ON THE TOP OF IT.
HAD HE MADE CONTACT, IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN A 6-4-3 DOUBLE PLAY.
TIM: HE CAN HIT A FASTBALL.
THAT IS HIS M.O.
THAT WORKED BECAUSE OF THAT
AMAZING CHANGE TWO PITCHES
BEFORE.
SHAWN: SLOW THEM DOWN, SPEED
THEM UP, PITCHING 101.
KEEPS YOU IN THAT ROCKING CHAIR.
SCOTT: ON TO JACE PETERSON.
JAE STRUCK OUT FIRST TIMER --
JACE STRUCK OUT FIRST TIME
AROUND.
GAME ONE OF THIS SERIES,
PEDERSON WAS 3-3 WITH A WALK.
CLUTCH CITY LAST NIGHT, AS WELL.
TWO STRIKE R.B.I. SINGLE MADE IT
3-2.
THE GO-AHEAD RUN.
LOBS ONE INTO SHALLOW CENTER.
IT WILL DROP.
URIAS IS ON HIS WAY HOME.
YELICH IN BETWEEN SECOND AND
THIRD.
THE BREWERS GET A RUN.
YELICH STILL ON THE RUN,
CRAWFORD IS GOING TO MAKE THE
TAG FOR THE OUT TO END THE
INNING.
THE BREWERS GET THEIR FIRST RUN
OF THE DAY.
JACE PETERSON WITH A LITTLE
R.B.I., KNOCK AND SCORES URIAS.
LOGAN WEBB IS SHAKING HIS HEAD
AND SAYING A FEW THINGS THAT
MIGHT NOT BE SAFE FOR YOUTUBE.
>> IF YOU ARE ONE OF THE
THOUSANDS WHO FOLLOW WILLY
ADAMES ON INSTAGRAM, YOU MAY BE
WONDERING, WHAT IS WITH THE
HASHTAG?
>> WHEN YOU GET TO THIS LEVEL,
SOMETIMES, YOU KNOW, LIKE YOU
GET A NEW CAR, BIG HOUSE, AND
SOMETIMES IT GETS TO YOUR HEAD.
>> LONG AGO, HE DECIDED HE WOULD
NOT LET IT GET IN HIS HEAD
BECAUSE A 17-YEAR-OLD THE
DOMINICAN SUMMER LEAGUE, HE
FIRST POSTED NO BOOKBAG.
THAT WAS IN 2013.
IT IS A LOOSELY TRANSLATED
SPANISH PHRASE.
ADAMES SAYS IT REMINDS HIM TO
STAY HUMBLE, NEVER BOAST, AND
REMEMBER WHERE HE CAME FROM.
WHICH WAS A SMALL TOWN IN THE
DOMINICAN REPUBLIC, WHERE HE HAD
LOVING PARENTS BUT NOT MUCH
ELSE.
>> THAT IS WHAT MAKES ME
APPRECIATE THIS.
GOD GAVE ME THIS OPPORTUNITY.
I HAVE GOT TO GIVE IT TO OTHERS.
>> WILLY ADAMES LOVES LIFE AND
LIVES IT WITH HUMILITY AND IS
SURROUNDED BY FAMILY AND FRIENDS
WHO WOULD NOT HAVE IT ANY OTHER
WAY.
>> OH MY GOD.
THEY WOULD SMACK ME IN MY FACE
PROBABLY.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: THE BREWERS TIED UP AT
ONE IN THE TOP OF THE FOURTH.
WE REACHED THE BOTTOM OF THE
INNING.
TIM, YOU HAVE PERMISSION TO DO
WHATEVER BACK GUY WAS DOING ON
THE BAY.
THAT WAS AWESOME.
TIM: I AM IN.
LET'S GO.
SCOTT: HERE IS HOW IT FINISHED
THE LAST HALF INNING.
CHRISTIAN YELICH CAP BETWEEN
SECOND AND THIRD, BUT THE RUN
COMES ACROSS FOR MILWAUKEE.
URIAS SCORES.
R.B.I. KNOCK FOR JACE PETERSON.
ONE A PIECE.
ERIC LAUER IS BACK ON THE MOUND
TO PITCH IN THE HOME FOURTH
AGAINST ESTRADA, CRAWFORD, AND
CASALI.
WHAT WAS THAT?
HE WAS GLIDING ON A MOTORIZED
SURFBOARD?
I DON'T KNOW.
SHAWN: I WISH I COULD SAY I SAW
IT.
I MIGHT BE ABLE TO HELP YOU IF I
HAD SEEN IT THERE ARE SOME CRAZY
THINGS YOU WOULD SEE ON THE BAY.
YOU SEE ENOUGH GAMES, YOU WILL
SEE WHAT IS GOING ON.
SCOTT: LOOK.
THANK YOU, CREW.
SHAWN: THAT IS A FIRST.
SCOTT: WHAT IS THAT?
SHAWN: NOTHING SURPRISES ME IN
SAN FRANCISCO, BUT THAT IS A
FIRST.
TIM: NOTHING WAS PULLING THAT
GUY ON THAT THING?
HE WAS BY HIMSELF?
SHAWN: IT HAS GOT TO BE A MOTOR.
SCOTT: MAYBE THE YOUTUBE
CREATORS IN THE COMMENTARY
SECTION CAN HOOK US UP WITH AN
EXPLANATION.
OR SOMEONE GOOGLE IT AND HELP US
OUT.
THAT IS COOL.
TIM: YOU CAN SAY GOOGLE, RIGHT?
YOU TOLD ME THAT.
SHAWN MISSED IT BECAUSE HE WAS
TOO BUSY WRITING DOWN THAT PLAY.
SHAWN: JACE PETERSON SINGLE
R.B.I., -85-4-5-6.
ONE MORE AND I RUN OUT OF ROOM.
TIM: THAT IS LIKE A LOCKER
COMBINATION.
SCOTT: ESTRADA SENDS A FLY BALL
TO CENTER.
JACKIE BRADLEY JR. BACKS UP A
BIT AND HAULS IT IN.
SHAWN: PETERSON COMING UP CLUTCH
AGAIN LAST INNING.
TWO OUT R.B.I.
TIM: HE IS A GOOD BALLPLAYER.
WE WERE IN THE DUGOUT WITH CRAIG
COUNSELL BEFORE THE GAME BECAUSE
WE ARE ALLOWED TO HAVE A THREE
ON ONE INTERVIEW WITH HIM, AND
THAT IS THE ONLY QUESTION I
ASKED I THINK, EXCEPT FOR WHY
DID YOU NOT BRING ME UP IN 2015
AND 2016?
[LAUGHTER]
NO, I ASKED HIM --
SHAWN: HE DID NOT ANSWER THAT
ONE.
TIM: HE PUSHED IT ASIDE.
I ASKED HIM, WHAT IS THE PLAYER
MOST LIKE YOU ON THIS TEAM?
AND HE GOT THE RIGHT ANSWER,
PETERSON.
HE IS JUST SUCH A GOOD
BALLPLAYER SO PREPARED.
IT IS REALLY COOL TO SEE A GUY I
PLAYED WITH, CRAIG COUNSELL,
LOOKING AT THIS OTHER GUY AND
SAY, THIS IS HOW I WAS AND WHAT
WE DID.
THAT IS WHAT GOOD TEAMS NEED.
SHAWN: PETERSON PLAYS ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
HE IS A GRINDER.
THAT IS WHAT YOU LOVE ABOUT GUYS
LIKE THAT.
YOU WISH YOU HAD A WHOLE CLUB OF
THEM.
THEY ARE NOT ALL BUILT FROM THE
SAME CLOTH, BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE
GUYS LIKE THAT ON YOUR TEAM WHO
SHOW UP EVERY DAY.
THEY WANT TO PLAY AND BE IN THE
LINEUP.THEY
WILL PLAY WHEREVER YOU PUT THEM,
WHEREVER YOU PUT THEM IN THE
LINEUP, AND THEY GET IT DONE.
SCOTT: CRAWFORD PULLS ONE INTO
THE SHIFT.
WONG PUT SOME AWAY.
THINK ABOUT OCTOBER BASEBALL AT
THIS POINT IF YOU ARE A BREWER
SPAN.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO BE
THERE.
JACE PETERSON OFF THE BENCH FOR
A BIG A.B. LATE IN THE GAME.
YEAH, IT COULD BE A CLUTCH
KNOCK, BUT HE ALSO SPINS AT
PITCHES.IF
YOU NEED SOMEONE ON BASE TO PASS
THE BATON, HE IS GOING TO HELP
FILL THE VOID FOR A BENCH
PLAYER.
SHAWN: WE ASKED COUNSELL'S
BIGGEST CONCERNS AND BENCH WAS
NOT ONE OF THEM.
SCOTT: CASALI POPS ONE UP.
HERE COMES GARCIA FOR IT.
HERE WE GO AGAIN.
PITCHING HAS BEEN SUPREME SO FAR
TODAY.
AFTER FOUR INNINGS, LAUER HAS
GIVEN UP ONE RUN.
SO HAS WEBB.
WESAIL INTO THE FIFTH -- WE SAIL
INTO THE FIFTH.
>> SWING INTO LEFT CENTER.
THE BREWERS HAVE THE LEAD.
>> HE IS A VERY GOOD BASEBALL
ANNOUNCER.
IF YOU LISTEN TO BOB FOR FIVE OR
SIX MINUTES, YOU WANT THEM TO
SAY SOMETHING THAT WILL MAKE YOU
LAUGH.
>> DRISCOLL MAKES THE PROPER
CALL.
DEFENSIVE INDIFFERENCE.
OR AS WE CALL IT AND SCORE IT,
CARELESS.
>> BOB HAS HAD THIS WONDERFUL
ABILITY TO GIVE YOU THE GAME AND
THEN,BANG.
>> THAT IS WHERE MAJOR LEAGUE
THREE WAS FILMED.
>>? IS THAT RIGHT
I HAVE NOT SEEN IT.
>> DON'T.
THAT THING WAS SO BAD, IT WAS ON
AIRPLANES THE DAY WE FINISHED.
>> HE IS VERY FUNNY ON THE AIR,
BUT HE IS AN EXCEPTIONALLY GOOD
BROADCASTER.
>> BASE HIT TO RIGHT CENTER.
ONE RUN IS IN.
THEY ARE GOING TO TRY TO SCORE.
HERE IS THE THROW.
HE IS IN THERE.
>> YOU REALLY FEEL THE GAME
THROUGH HIM, AND WHILE CERTAINLY
HE IS A BREWER BROADCASTER, SO
IN THAT SENSE, HE IS A HOMER, HE
IS NOT A MINDLESS HOMER.
HE WILL GIVE YOU A FAIR CALL.
>> SMASH UP THE MIDDLE.
BASE TO CENTER.
HERE HE COMES AROUND THIRD.
THE BREWERS WIN!
AMY: THEY SAY THAT CHAMPIONS ARE
ONE WITH PITCHING AND DEFENSE,
SO, WHO HAS GOT SOME GREAT
PITCHING STATS?
WE ARE LOOKING AT ONE TODAY WITH
THE BREWERS.
YOU KNOW WHO WAS INTO THAT?
JOEY VOTTO.
HE SAID, "I AM GOING TO SAY IT
OUT LOUD: PERSONALLY, I THINK
THIS IS THE BEST GROUP OF
PITCHERS -- TALKING ABOUT THE
BREWERS -- I HAVE FACED IN MY
CAREER.
I WAS PART OF THE TEAM THAT BASE
THE 2010 PHILLIES WITH THE LATE
ROY HALLADAY, CLIFF LEE, ROY
OSWALT, THE ENTIRE COLLECTION OF
RUMORS PITCHERS.
THIS HAS BEEN THE TOUGHEST
MATCHUP IN MY CAREER."
WE HAVE A POLL QUESTION.
WHICH TEAMS, TOP THREE, ARE THE
SCARIEST IN A POSTSEASON SERIES?
YOU KNOW WHAT JOEY VOTTO THINKS.
I THINK KAPLAN MIGHT AGREE,
SAYING THE BREWERS HAVE ONE OF
THE BEST, IF NOT THE BEST,
PITCHING STAFFS IN BASEBALL.
SCOTT: THANK YOU, AMY G.
THAT IS A TOUGH CHOICE.
EVEN STILL, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
COMPETITION FOR THEM, EVEN IN
THE NATIONAL LEAGUE, AND YOU CAN
VOTE.
YES, I'M GOING TO ASK MY FRIENDS
TO HELP US FIRST.
VOGELBACH TAKES THE PITCHER
UPSTAIRS.
1-1.
THE DODGERS HAVE A NICE-LOOKING
ROTATION.
LECTURES ARE IS A CY YOUNG
CANDIDATE, URIAS IS OUTSTANDING.
WHITE SOX HAVE SOMETHING
SPECIAL.
TIM, YOU FIRST.
HAVE FUN.
WHICH STARTING STAFF TOP THREE
IS THE SCARIEST?
TIM: I AM A BREWER EMPLOYEE, SO
I THINK I HAVE TO GO BREWER'S.
I HAVE SEEN THEM DAY IN AND DAY
OUT.
IT IS TRULY SPECIAL.
YOU ARE GOING BACK TO ZITO,
HUDSON, MULDER, OF THE A'S BACK
IN THE DAY AND YOU HAVE THREE
GUYS WITH CAREER YEARS THAT ARE
ALL-STARS.
ARE THEY ALL-STARS?
I AM ASKING FOR A FRIEND.
I DO NOT KNOW.
SCOTT: I CAN HELP TO ANSWER
THAT.
I KNOW NOT FOR SAN FRANCISCO,
FOR THE DODGERS, SCHERZER, YES.
BUEHLER I BELIEVE SO.
I DO NOT THINKURIAS WAS AN
ALL-STAR.
LET'S MOVE TO THE NEXT TEAM.
WHITE SOX.
[LAUGHTER]
I MEAN, HEY, YOU WANT ME TO DO
THE HOMEWORK.
WE HAVE RESEARCH HELP IN A
MOMENT.
VOGELBACH FLYING OUT TO CENTER.
ONE GONE.
HERE WE GO.
THIS HELPS, THANK YOU.
FOR THE WHITE SOX, LYNN, RODON,
GIOLITO.
GIOLITO WAS NOT AN ALL-STAR THIS
YEAR.
YES, I AM GETTING CONFIRMATION
IN TALKING THROUGH IT.
TIM GIVING ME A POP QUIZ.
THE ANSWER IS THE BREWERS HAVE
THE BIG THREE THAT ARE ALL
ALL-STARS THIS YEAR.
TIM: POP QUIZ, HOTSHOT.
I DO NOT KNOW THEY WERE GOING TO
THROW A GRAPHIC.
MY DAD.
SCOTT: [LAUGHTER]
SHAWN: I WILL TELL YOU WHAT, MAN
, I AM A GIANT EMPLOYEE, AND I
AM GOING TO STILL PICK THE
BREWERS.
IT IS TOUGH TO BEAT THOSE THREE.
HAD TREVOR BAUER BEEN PITCHING
AND MAYBE KERSHAW, I MAY GO WITH
THE DODGERS, JUST EXPERIENCE
LEVEL POSTSEASON.
YOU KNOW, DEFENDING CHAMPS WITH
SCHERZER, BUEHLER, AND KERSHAW
OR BAUER.
THOSE THREE WOULD BE TOUGH TO
BEAT.
RIGHT NOW IT IS NOTHING AGAINST
URIAS, BUT THAT THREE-HEADED
MONSTER OF WOODRUFF, BURNS, AND
PERALTA IS AS GOOD AS IT THAT'S.
MATTER OF FACT, WE HAVE -- AS
GOOD AS IT GETS.
MATTER OF FACT, WE HAVE SOME
DETAILS.
BURNS, WOODRUFF AND PERALTA
ALLENDER 2.5.
THE LAST TIME IT HAPPENED,
SCHERZER, BOBBY WELCH, 85 --
1985 DODGERS.
THAT SHOWS YOU HOW GOOD THEY
ARE.
BEING IN SAN FRANCISCO THE LAST
11 YEARS, COVERING THIS TEAM,
BUMGARNER WAS PART OF A GOOD
TRIO, AS WELL AND THEY WON WORLD
SERIES TOGETHER, IF I REMEMBER
RIGHT.
TIM: I THINK THERE ARE SIGNS ON
THE WALL OUT THERE.
SCOTT: THERE ARE A FEW.
FREDDY PERALTA HAS BEEN ON THE
INJURED LIST WITH A SHOULDER
ISSUE, BUT HE IS BACK TOMORROW
FOR MILWAUKEE.
PERFECT TIMING.
BRADLEY DOES NOT BITE.
2-2.
TIM: WE CAN TALK ALL WE WANT OF
OUR OPINION.
WE ARE IN THIS BOOTH, I HAVE A
CUP HOLDER FOR MY COFFEE.
IT IS ALL ABOUT WHAT THE PEERS
SAY.
YOU GO OFF JOEY VOTTO, KRIS
BRYANT, CORBIN BURNES WAS SAYING
HE GOT OUT OF CHICAGO SO HE DID
NOT HAVE TO FACE HIM ANYMORE.
HE ALREADY FACED HIM TWICE SINCE
GOING TO THE GIANTS.
SCOTT: K.B. IS LIKE, CAN I NOT
SEE THEM, AT LEAST UNTIL THE
NLCS?
WHICH COULD BE A PREVIEW THIS
WEEK.
LOGAN WEBB IS ABSOLUTELY ON FIRE
WITH. A SWING AND MISS
SHAWN: CHANGE UP THERE.
BRADLEY JUNIOR IS THINKING THE
SAME THING.DO
I HAVE TO FACE LOGAN WEBB AGAIN
IN THIS GAME?
SCOTT: HE HAS ALREADY PUNCHED
OUT SEVEN.
15 WHIPS FOR WEBB.
ONE SHY OF HIS CAREER HIGH OF
16.
WE ARE ONLY IN THE FIFTH, AND HE
IS AT 60 TOSSES.
SHAWN: NASTY SINKER.
TIM: THIS IS A BIG GAME FOR
LOGAN WEBB FOR A LOT OF REASONS.
HE HAS BEEN PITCHING SO WELL.
MAYBE THE BEST PITCHER IN THE
LAST THREE MONTHS THIS SEASON
AND THE BIGWIGS.
BUT THE TEAM IS ON A FOUR GAME
LOSING STREAK.
THEY HAVE NOT WON SINCE HE TOOK
THE MOUND LAST.
TO ELEVATE YOURSELF IN THE A
STATUS, THIS IS THE GAME YOU
HAVE TO GO OUT THERE AND PUT
YOUR TEAM ON YOUR BACK.
YOU HAVE TO SAY, BOYS, THAT IS
ENOUGH.
I WILL COME OUT AND DOMINATE.
SCOTT: MAILE CLOCKS WENT TO LEFT
FIELD AND FINDS OPEN SPACE.
HE TREKS TO SECOND.
LUKE MAILE SENDS IT TO THE
LEFT-FIELD CORNER.
A TWO OUT DOUBLE HERE IN THE
FIFTH.
TIM: AND RIGHT ON CUE, HE GIVES
UP A DOUBLE.
THAT BEING SAID, THERE ARE TWO
OUTS WITH A PITCHER ON DECK DO
NOT USUALLY HURT YOU, BUT THIS
IS A BIG GAME.
HE UNDERSTANDS THAT THEY NEED
HIM TODAY, THEY NEED HIM TO GO
OUT THERE AND KEEP HIS TEAM IN
THE GAME.
HE IS DOING JUST THAT SO FAR.
TIM: TALKING TO GABE KAPLER
BEFORE THE GAME, AND HE WAS
WORRIED ABOUT TODAY.
HE WAS LIKE, WE ARE ONLY WORRIED
ABOUT WINNING TODAY.
HE FELT COMFORTABLE WITH THE
LINEUP.
HE LIKES SOME OF THOSE GUYS ON
THE INJURED LIST, BUT WHO
WOULDN'T?
EVERY GUY WANTS THEIR TEAM
HEALTHY, BUT HE FEELS CONFIDENT
IN WHAT LOGAN WEBB CAN DO AND
WHAT HE'S DOING IN THE GAME.
SCOTT: HE CHUCKLED WHEN WE
DISCUSSED THE FACT THAT YOU
COULD SAVE A PITCHER LIKE WEBB
FOR THE NEXT SERIES -- ANOTHER
RIP, BY THE WAY, 17 FOR LOGAN
WEBB.
A CAREER-HIGH.
BUT KAPLER SAID, YEAH, WE ARE
GOING TO TRY TO WIN TODAY'S
GAME.
I KNOW, IT IS THE DODGERS, AND
THEY JUST PASSED US FOR FIRST
PLACE IN THE NL. WEST, BUT THEY
WILL WORRY ABOUT LATE TOMORROW.
LAST FEW GAMES -- NL WEST, BUT
THEY WILL WORRY ABOUT L.A.
TOMORROW.
SHAWN: HE JUST KEEPS ADDING TO
THAT RECORD.
I AM SURE THIS WILL NOT STAND AT
SOME POINT IN HIS CAREER,
EITHER.
HE HAS A LOT OF YEARS TO PITCH.
HE HAS BEEN AWFULLY IMPRESSIVE
TODAY WITH A THREE PITCH
COMBINATION THAT IS AS GOOD AS I
HAVE SEEN THIS YEAR.
I KNOW WE ARE ONLY IN THE FIFTH
INNING, BUT I THOUGHT HIS LAST
GAME IN ATLANTA, WHICH IS AS
GOOD AS HE CAN PITCH, AND TODAY
HE MIGHT SURPASS THAT.
SCOTT: LAUER IN A 1-2 HOLE.
EVEN IF YOU STRIKEOUT, IF YOU
ARE LAUER RIGHT NOW, THIS IS A
WIN.
YOU HAVE AT LEAST DRIVEN UP THE
PITCH COUNT A LITTLE BIT.
SHAWN: YOU HAVE SEEN LAUER IN
THE BOX A FEW TIMES THIS YEAR.
HE LOOKS LIKE HE CAN SWING IT A
LITTLE BIT.
TIM: HE IS COMFORTABLE.
HE HAS HAD SAC BUNS.
THEY WORK AT BATTING PRACTICE.
SCOTT: FROZEN.
LOGAN WEBB IS BAFFLING EVERYONE,
EVEN THE BROADCASTERS.
EIGHT STRIKEOUTS THIS AFTERNOON
FOR MR. WEBB.
TRYING TO WIPE AWAY THIS LOSING
SKID FOR THE GIANTS.
♪
>> ON SEPTEMBER 2, 1990, THE
BLUE JAYS' DAVE STIEB WAS ONE
OUT AWAY FROM A NO-HITTER.
I SEE GOT READY TO FACE JERRY
BROWN OF THE INDIANS, YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND IF HE WAS THINKING TO
HIMSELF, NOT AGAIN.
DAVE STIEB HAD PITCHED FIVE ONE
HITTERS IN HIS CAREER ALREADY,
INCLUDING THREE IN 1988 AND TWO
WERE PARTICULARLY HEARTBREAKING.
IN BACK-TO-BACK TO BACK
SEPTEMBER STARTS, STEVE HAD
GOTTEN TWO OUTS IN THE NINTH
INNING WITH A NO-HITTER INTACT,
ONLY TO LOSE IT.
THERE WAS THE TORONTO
RIGHT-HANDER ON THE MOUND, WHEN
OUT AWAY AGAIN.
AND WITH JERRY BROWN AT THE
PLATE, DAVE STIEB'S RUN OF NINE
ANY DISAPPOINTMENTS FINALLY
ENDED.
>> HE HAS GOT A NO-HITTER, DAVE
STIEB!
THE LONG FRUSTRATION IS FINALLY
OVER!
>> THIS IS A MOMENT YOU WILL
NEVER, EVER FORGET.
AND YOU HAVE HAD FIVE CRACKS AT
IT.
>> THAT MANY?
>> THE FIRST AND ONLY NO-HITTER
IN TORONTO BLUE JAYS' HISTORY.
AFTER FIVE ONE HITTERS, DAVE
STIEB FINALLY HAD HIS NO-HITTER.
SCOTT: TODAY, WE SHINE THE LIGHT
ON DAWSON WRIGHT WHO ASKED THE
QUESTION FOR KEVIN GAUSMAN
EARLIER, SAYING HOW IMPRESSIVE
HAS LOGAN WEBB BEEN?
HE IS ALL IN WITH THOSE SHADES
AND MAKES ESSAYS ON A MULTITUDE
OF TOPICS, INCLUDING CURRENT, B
EVANS, TEAMBUILDING ANALYSIS,
AND LEGENDARY STORIES FROM
BASEBALL HISTORY.
TODAY IS TUESDAY.HE IS
A GIANTS FAN.
HIS FAVORITE MEMORY IS THE 2014
WORLD SERIES.THANKS FOR HANGING
OUT WITH US TODAY
AND IT IS A PLEASURE TO  HAVE
YOU ON, AMYG.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE FOR MAURICIO
DUBON?
AMY: HE IS GOING TO STEP INTO
THE BOX.
IT IS THE FIRST TIME HE WILL
STEP INTO THE BOX WITH THIS CLUB
ON A MAJOR LEAGUE ROSTER SINCE
JUNE 28.
HE HAS BEEN WORKING ON HIS CRAFT
WITH THE AAA SACRAMENTO GIANTS.
I ASKED GABE KAPLER WHAT HE HAS
LIKED ABOUT THERE WERE PORTS ON
DUBON -- REPORTS ON DUBON.
HE HAS IMPROVED HIS CHASE AND
SWING PERCENTAGES, MEANING HE IS
SWINGING LESS AT BAD PITCHES AND
MOSTLY PLAYING SHORTSTOP.
TODAY HE IS IN CENTER FIELD, BUT
DID WAS GETTING REPORTS THAT HE
HAS PUT IN A TON OF WORK IN HIS
DOWN TIME AND OTHER POSITIONS HE
PLAYS BECAUSE HE IS A UTILITY
PLAYER.
HE IS VERY IMPRESSED WITH THE
STRETCHY HAS HAD, REALLY LOOKING
FOR DUBON TO BE A SHOT IN THE
ARM FOR THE OFFENSE TODAY.
SCOTT: .333, 46 GAMES AT AAA
SINCE LAST PLAYING IN MLB SINCE
LATE JULY.
THESE FIRST TWO PICTURES ARE A
PERFECT EXAMPLE, SHAWN.
HE TAKES THE FIRST TWO.THEY ARE
PRETTY CLOSE.
EARLIER IN HIS CAREER, HE
THOUGHT HE COULD SWING AT
ANYTHING.
SUPER ATHLETE.
WE ARE SEEING THE PATIENT'S
PROGRESS -- PATIENCE PROGRESS.
SHAWN: THAT IS WHAT THEY NEED TO
SEE.
THAT IS HOW THIS OFFENSE IS
BUILT.
THEY LIKE GUYS WHO DO NOT CHASE
A LOT.
THEY LIKE GUYS WHO TRY TO DO
DAMAGE WITH PITCHES IN THE
STRIKE ZONE.
THAT WAS NOT THE CASE ON A
CONSISTENT BASIS WHEN HE WAS UP
WITH THE GIANTS THE FIRST COUPLE
OF MONTHS OF THE SEASON.
SO, WE WILL HAVE TO SEE MOVING
FORWARD, THIS IS OUR FIRST
CHANCE TO SEE HIM SINCE HE HAS
BEEN RECALLED.
WE WILL HAVE TO SEE IF THAT WORK
HE PUT DOWN IN SACRAMENTO HAS
PAID OFF.
SCOTT: HE FLEW OUT TO RIGHT IN
THE SECOND INNING.
HE HAS WATCHED FOUR PITCHES.
SWINGS AT THAT ONE, AND RIDES UP
A FULL COUNT.
HE IS UP FOR RUMOR FLORES, WHO
LEFT YESTERDAY'S GAME EARLY.
THEY ARE CALLING IT A GRADE ONE
LEFT HAMSTRING STRAIN.
HE WAS ON THE 10 DAY INJURED
LIST.
LAUER COMING OFF A 1-2-3-4
INNING.
-- 1-2-3  FOURTH INNING.
TIM, YOU WOULD LOVE THAT.
PAYOFF PITCH.
HOLD UP, LET ME FIX THESE
BATTING GLOVES.
TIM: THEY ARE SHIFTING ON THE.
I ALWAYS FIND IT INTERESTING
WHEN THE UMPIRE CALLS TIME AND
POINTS AT WHO CALLED THE TIME.
TO NOT BE MAD AT ME.
BE MAD AT THIS GUY -- DO NOT BE
MAD AT ME.
WE MET AT THE SKY.
SCOTT: HE RINGS HIM UP.
PITCHER'S CALL FOR ERIC LAUER. I
AM SURE
THE GIANTS BRASS WOULD SAY, WE
WILL TAKE THAT AB.
SHAWN: HE SAW SIX PITCHES.
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN ON FIRST
BASE.
LAUER GETS THE BENEFIT OF THE
CALL.
A NICE AT-BAT BY MAURICIO DUBON.
THE END RESULT WAS NOT WHAT HE
WANTED IT TO BE, BUT, AS YOU CAN
SEE RIGHT THERE, A COUPLE INCHES
OFF THE PLATE END.
TIM: THE FIRST TWO PITCHES AT
THE TOP OF THIS ON WERE PRETTY
GOOD.
I'M WONDERING IF THERE IS A
CONVERSATION LIKE ANGEL
HERNANDEZ LIGHT, I MISSED THOSE,
BUT DOUBTFUL.
[LAUGHTER]
SHAWN: THE FIRST PITCH TO LOGAN
WEBB WAS BETTER THAN THE LAST
PITCH TO DUBON.
[LAUGHTER]
HE THREW ONE AT HALF AN INCH
INSIDE AND GOT BALL!
LOGAN WAS LIKE, I WILL TAKE THE
STRIKE.
YOU GIVE MAURICIO THE BALL.
SCOTT: THERE IS A STRIKE.
SHAWN: BUT YOU CAN TELL, I MEAN,
ANGEL HERNANDEZ HAS BEEN A
LONGER LONG TIME -- HAS BEEN
AROUND A LONG TIME.
YOU WILL GET THE BENEFIT OF SOME
CALLS OFF THE PLATE.
THAT IS A FACT.
SCOTT: 3-1 TO WEBB.
SHAWN: WHEN YOU GET THE UMPIRE
AND ONE TEAM TO CALL A STRIKE
MODE, LIKE YOU HAVE SEEN WITH
LOGAN WEBB IN THE FIRST FIVE
INNINGS OF THIS GAME, YOU WILL
GET BORDERLINE PITCHES.
SCOTT: BOUNCING BALL TO SHORT.
URIAS MAKES THE PLAY.
TWO DOWN IN THE FIFTH.
ALL SEASON LONG ON THE MLB GAME
OF THE WEEK, THE POWER TO VOTE
FOR WHICH STAND OUT PERFORMER IS
GOING TO RECEIVE THIS GORGEOUS
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME
TROPHY.
THAT WAS MR. WALKOFF LAST WEEK,
JAKE MEYERS IN HOUSTON.
STAY TUNED.
WE WILL DO THE POLL LIKE WE HAVE
BEEN DOING ALREADY.
WE WILL HEAD OUT HARDWARE IN OUR
POSTGAME SHOW IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING THE END OF THE GAME.
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF INTERVIEWS
COMING UP.
30 MINUTES DEDICATED TO THE
BREWERS AND GIANTS AFTER THIS
ONE CONCLUDES.
TIM: THERE IS REALLY A TROPHY?
SCOTT: IT IS ALREADY DOWNSTAIRS
ON THE FIELD.
AND THEN IT GETS EVEN BETTER.
YOU WOULD HAVE LOVED THIS.
SOMETIMES THERE CAN BE SOME NOT
NEED IN A SEASON.
AUSTIN SLATER WATCHES A STRIKE
ON THE OUTSIDE CORNER WITH TWO
DOWN IN THE FIFTH -- GONE IN THE
FIFTH.
NOT ONLY DO YOU WIN A TROPHY BUT
THEY ENGRAVE YOUR NAME.
CRAWFORD WON ONE LAST TIME WE
DID GIANTS AND REDS.
BIG OFFENSIVE PERFORMANCE.
I THINK HE WAS JOKING ABOUT IT
WITH AMY G.
SEE IF WE CAN BRING AMY IN ON
THE YOUTUBE TROPHY.
SHAWN: WASN'T IT 18 MONTHS, THAT
GAME?
TIM: EVERYONE GETS A TROPHY,
RIGHT?
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: LAUER FALLS BACK BUT
MAKES THE FADEAWAY THROW IN
TIME.
SEE IF HE'S OK.
SHAWN: LOOKS LIKE HE'S OK, BUT
THE SNIPER GOT HIM THERE.
ALL OF A SUDDEN A CLEAT STUCK OR
SOMETHING.
SCOTT: IS THAT THERE GOOD
OLD-FASHIONED NBA FLOP?
DID SOMEONE PUSH HIM?
SHAWN: NEVER CALLED AFOUL.
SCOTT: RIGHT ANKLE.
A LITTLE SLIP.
THROW WAS MONEY.
SHAWN: THAT WAS MONEY.
THAT WAS RIGHT ON THE MONEY.
OH YEAH, HYPEREXTENSION ANKLE.
GOOD PLAY.
SCOTT: WE WILL MAKE SURE HE IS
OK AND READY TO GO FOR THE NEXT
INNING, BECAUSE ERIC LAUER IS
SUDDENLY ON SOME KIND OF ROLL
RIGHT NOW.
YES RETIRED E--HE HAS RETIRED
EIGHT IN A ROW.
>> SEMI LONG GOES AFTER THE
FIRST PITCH AND FLIPS I HIT INTO
LEFT CENTER FIELD.
CONGRATULATIONS.
SAMUEL LONG HAS GOT A BIG-LEAGUE
KNOCK.
IT'S THAT ONE PRETTY WELL OUT OF
LEFT CENTER.
YASTRZEMSKI IS GOING TO RUN IT
DOWN.
LOGAN WEBB, SEVEN STRONG TONIGHT
IN ATLANTA.
>> CRAWFORD MARKS ONE DOWN THE
RIGHT-FIELD LINE.
BASE HIT UP AGAINST THE WALL.
RICOCHETS AWAY FROM CONFORTO.
BRYANT SCORES.
DICKERSON IS HEADING HOME.
SAFE!
GIANTS HAVE GONE AHEAD ON ONE
PITCH FROM THE BULLPEN.
>> NOBODY IS THERE.
IN A RIGHT FIELD, BASE HIT.
HERE COMES JUST FROM SKI.
THE THROW IS OFF-LINE AND GOES
RIGHT OVER THE CATCHER.
DARIN RUF GOES TO SECOND.
GIANTS HAVE GONE AHEAD, 3-2.
NUMERAL ALL THE WAY BACK AND HE
IS GOING TO WATCH IT.
HE IS GONE.
>> BELT, DEEP LEFT, AND THAT
BALL IS GONE.
>> THAT IS NOT A HOME RUN, BUT
IT IS A TOUGH PLAY.
LINDOR, NOT IN TIME.
SCOTT: GOOGLE IS HELPING TO
POWER SENT PAST -- STATCAST TO
REVEAL NEW INSIGHTS THAT TAKE
YOU DEEPER INTO THE GAME THAN
EVER BEFORE.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS THE CLOUD
TECHNOLOGY FOR MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
THIRD TIME THROUGH THE ORDER
NOW.
PITCH NUMBER 70.
THAT IS IN THERE.
SCOTT BRAUN, SHAWN ESTES, TIM
DILLARD, AND AMY G WITH YOU THIS
AFTERNOON.
WONG SEARCHING FOR HIS FIRST HIT
TODAY.
AND HE WILL NOT FIND IT THERE.
BRANDON BELT WILL HANDLE THINGS
HIMSELF.
SHAWN: ANOTHER BALL ON THE
GROUND.
SIX GROUNDBALL OUTS FOR LOGAN
WEBB ALONG WITH 8 STRIKEOUTS.
14 OF THE 15 OUTS HAVE BEEN VIA
STRIKEOUT OR GROUNDBALL.
KIND OF AS ADVERTISED FOR LOGAN
WEBB.
YOU LOOK FOR THE THIRD TIME IN
THE LINEUP -- FIRST TIME THEY
WERE 0-9.
SECOND TIME THROUGH THE OVER 3-8
WITH THE WALK.
STILL HAVE TO SEE HOW HE
NAVIGATES THE LINE OF THE THIRD
TIME.
SCOTT: KEEP AN EYE ON ERIC
LAUER.
WHEN HE STEPPED AT THE END OF
HIS HALF -- FUNNY STEP AT THE
END OF HIS HALF.
STILL MADE THE PLAY.
THEY WOULD LOVE TO GET A COUPLE
INNINGS OUT OF HIM, ESPECIALLY
AFTER BRETT ANDERSON HAD TO
LEAVE THE GAME EARLY YESTERDAY
AFTER JUST TWO INNINGS.
COME BACK THAT WENT OFF HIS
SHOULDER AND THEY PLACED HIM ON
THE 10-8 INJURED LIST.
SHAWN: AND FREDDY PERALTA COMING
BACK TOMORROW.
HE WILL NOT BE ON A VERY LONGISH
AFTER NOT PITCHING FOR A COUPLE
OF WEEKS.
NOT GOING TO GET A LOT OF LENGTH
OUT OF HIM AS WELL.
SCOTT: URIAWS IN THE AIR,
SHALLOW RIGHT.
HERE COMES SLATER.
TWO DOWN.
HELLO AGAIN, AMY G.
AMY: I JUST WANTED TO ADD WHAT
HE SAID ABOUT BRANDON CRAWFORD
WINNING THE TROPHY.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE WAS JOKING.
MAYBE HE WAS DEAD SERIOUS, BUT
HE SAID HE HAD THREE GOLD GLOVE
TROPHIES AND HE WAS GOING TO PUT
THE YOUTUBE TROPHY RIGHT THERE
FRONT AND CENTER.
IT WEIGHS OVER-UNDER 12
POUNDS.
FIND THE STUDS IN THE WALL, THAT
IS MY ADVICE.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: YOU CAN DO WORKOUT
PROGRAMS WITHOUT.
I SAW GABE KAPLER WEARING THE
DINGERS AND DEAD LIFTS SURE
TODAY.
NICE LITTLE WORKOUT WITH THE
YOUTUBE TROPHY.
BRANDON CRAWFORD WANTS ANOTHER
COULD WE WILL SEE IF HE HELPS
HIS TEAM OUT ON OFFENSE, AS
LOGAN WEBB WITH ANOTHER SHUTDOWN
INNING.
>> SWING AND A MISS, AND THERE
IS YOUR FIRST OUT.
THERE IS ANOTHER STRIKEOUT FOR
JOSH HADER.
1-2 ON THE WAY.
STRIKE THREE.
GAME OVER.
>> HE HAS GOT HIS MOUND OPPONENT
AND A 1-2 COUNT, AND DOWN HE
GOES.
NUMBER 10 FOR BRANDON WOODRUFF.
>> THIS ONE CRUSHED ALL THE WAY
BACK.
UPPER DECK.
THREE-RUN, TWO-OUT HOME RUN FOR
ROWDY TELLEZ.
NUMBER 11 ON THE SEASON.
4-0, MILWAUKEE.
>> IN THE AIR, LEFT CENTER.
AQUINO'S THROW COMES IN.
WE ARE TIED.
HE PULLS ONE RIGHT FIELD AND
DOWN FAIR.
INTO THE SCORE, PETERSON.
5-4, MILWAUKEE.
FLY BALL INTO RIGHT FIELD.
GARCIA BACK AT THE TRACK.
HE LEAVES ANY MAKE THE CATCH --
HE LEAPS AND HE MAKES THE CATCH.
GARCIA MAKES THE HOME RUN BACK.
SCOTT: THERE YOU GO, ERIC LAUER
IS GOOD TO GO FOR THE BOTTOM OF
THE SIXTH.
HIS TEAMMATE ROWDY TELLEZ IS OUR
GUY MIC'D UP TODAY.
ROWDY: GOT THE MIC TODAY.
WATCH OUT.
>> WILLIE GETS MIC'S AND DOESN'T
TELL NOBODY.
SHUT UP, WILLIE.
SHUT UP.
IT IS REALLY'S BIRTHDAY.
>> WHERE'S THE CAMERA?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY, WE ARE
LOOKING AT.
>> HEY!
IT'S MY BIRTHDAY TODAY!
>> HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
SCOTT: HEY, HAPPY BIRTHDAY,
WILLY ADAMES.
THEY LOVE YOU OUT THERE.
THANK YOU, ROWDY.
I FEEL LIKE WE DON'T JUST HAVE
ROWDY TELLEZ MIC'D UP, WE HAVE
WILLY ADAMES MIC'D UP.
LET'S SEND IT TO AMY G.
AMY: THE OTHER THING ABOUT
READY, DIEHARD GIANTS FAN.
GOT SOME TIME WITH HIM THE OTHER
DAY.
HE SAID HIS FIRST BASEBALL GAME
WAS AT CANDLESTICK.
THOSE OF US FROM THIS AREA, WE
KNOW HE WAS FREEZING FOR SURE.
HIS DAD GREW UP IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND HE SPENT MANY A FATHER'S
DAY, MOTHER'S DAY HOLIDAY AT THE
YARD.
HIS DAD WOULD'VE TAKEN OUT OF
SCHOOL EARLY TO TAKE HIM TO A
GAME GOOD DON'T WORRY, WE WON'T
TELL ANYONE.
HE SAID HE ATTENDED AT LEAST ONE
GAME OF THE '10, '12, AND '14
SEASON.
I HAD TO ASK WHO HIS FAVORITE
GIANT WAS -- SORRY, SHAWN,
IT WASN'T YOU.
IT WAS J.T. SNOW.
SCOTT: THAT'S AWESOME.
I HEARD A STORY THE OTHER DAY
FROM KEN ROSENTHAL THAT IN 2014,
HE WAS AN INSTRUCTIONAL LEAGUE
WITH THE BLUE JAYS AND HAD TO
LEAVE A LITTLE BIT EARLY, HAD A
FAMILY HUNTING TRIP.
BUT BEFORE THAT, HE WENT TO A
GAME, GIANTS WORLD SERIES
CONTEST.
HE JUST FORGOT TO INCLUDE THAT
BIT OF INFO.
SORRY, GUYS, I NEED TO LEAVE
EARLY COME FAMILY TIME --
[WHISPERS] AND GIANTS TIME.
TIM: LAST THREE GAMES HE HAS NOT
BEEN A BIG GIANTS FAN.
BUT IT'S COOL, A LOT OF GUYS
FROM THE SACRAMENTO AREA IN THE
BIG LEAGUES NOW.
SCOTT: BRYANT SENDS ONE TO
CENTER.
JACKIE BRADLEY, JR., COMMANDING
THE OUTFIELD TODAY.
A TON OF ALUMS -- ELK GROVE,
RIGHT?
100 MILES FROM HERE.
TIM: PITCHING TODAY, FROM
SACRAMENTO.
FROM A DIFFERENT HIGH SCHOOL.
YEAH, THERE IS A TON OF
SACRAMENTO BIG-LEAGUE PRODUCTS.
IT'S A HIGH FIT FOR BASEBALL.
--IT IS A HOTBED FOR BASEBALL.
SCOTT: GROUND OUT, FLY OUT FOR
BELT.
ON BASE 35% OF THE TIME THIS
YEAR.
HE HAS HAD A CAREER-HIGH 20
HOMERUNS.
THIS IS HIS 11TH SEASON IN THE
BIG LEAGUES.
LOOKING AT THE BACK OF THE
BASEBALL CARD FOR BRANDON BELT.
11 YEARS IN THE BIGS, HAD A
SWEET SWING, BIG POP.
NEVER BEEN AT 20.
BETWEEN SOME INJURY-FILLED
SEASONS AND THE FACT THAT HE
PLAYS IN ONE OF THE MORE COZY
PITCHERS PARKS.
YOU CAN SEE THE BE GIVEN FOR HIM
THIS YEAR IS THE BREAKING BALL
FOR -- BIG DIFFERENCE PRINT IS
HERE IS THE BREAKING BALL.
ALL OF A SUDDEN HE IS NAILING
BREAKING PITCHES.
YOU WONDER HOW THE CHANGES MADE
SO LATE IN YOUR CAREER TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT.
IS HE MESSING AROUND WITH A
PITCHING MACHINE THAT IS
THROWING BREAKERS AT HIM?
SHAWN: HE HAS ACTUALLY ALWAYS
BEEN PRETTY GOOD DOWN IN THE
ZONE.
SCOTT: SLICES HIS BAT IN HAVE
AND DROPS THE BASE HIT.
SHAWN: AND A FASTBALL DOWN IN
THE ZONE.
THAT IS WHERE YOU GIVE HIM A
CHANCE.
EVEN THOUGH HE DID BREAK HIS
BACK, IT ALLOWS THEM TO GET THE
BARREL OF THE BAT TO THE
BASEBALL.
YOU WATCH ERIC LAUER, DOWN AND
AWAY.
YOU HAVE TO GO BELT AND UP WITH
BRANDON BELT TO GET HIM OUT.
TOUGH TO EXECUTE THAT PITCH
EVERY TIME.
YOU CAN PROBABLY THROW BELT HIGH
TOP OF HIS OWN FASTBALL AND THE
BEST HE IS GOING TO DO IS, IT
UP, BUT IF YOU MISS DOWN IN THE
ZONE, THAT IS WHERE HE IS
WAITING FOR IT AND USUALLY DOES
A LOT OF DAMAGE.
WITH THE OFFSPEED STUFF HE HAS
BEEN HITTING A LOT OF RUNS DOWN
SLOW.
THAT HAS BEEN HIS M.O. HIS WHOLE
CAREER.
IT BLOWS YOUR MIND THAT HE IS
NOT HIT 20 HOMERUNS WITH AS MUCH
POWER AS HE HAS.
TO HIS DEFENSE COME HE IS
PLAYING IN A BALLPARK WHERE HE
HITS A LOT OF BALLS OUT TO RIGHT
CENTER AND IN VISITING BALLPARK.
HERE, IT IS A LONG WAY OUT
THERE.
HE HAS BEEN A VICTIM OF TRIPLES
ALLEY MORE TIMES THAN ANYBODY IN
A GIANT UNIFORM.
SCOTT: SKIED BY RUF.
BRADLEY, JR., MEASURES OUT
NUMBER TWO.
LET'S FINISH UP THAT LAST POLL
WE UNVEILED ABOUT AN INNING AGO.
CAP THREE STARTED--TOP THREE
STARTERS, SCARIEST AND A
POSTSEASON SERIES.
BREWERS TAKE -- IT IS CLOSE WITH
THEIR DIVISION RIVAL.
BREWERS FANS WEIGHING IN BIG
TODAY.
SHAWN: THE MORE I SEE THIS
BREWER TEAM, THE MORE I LIKE
THEM, THE MORE I FEEL JUST
BALANCE.
THEY HAVE SUCH GOOD STARTING
PITCHING, GREAT BULLPEN, GREAT
DEFENSE, GREAT BENCH OFFENSE
COURSE ENOUGH RUNS.
SCOTT: THAIRO ESTRADA TOOK THE
FIRST PITCH, CENTER FIELD.
BRADLEY, JR., GETTING A LOT OF
GOOD WORK OUT THERE.
CRAIG COUNSEL'S CLUB IS SERIOUS.
THEY TAKE THE FIRST THREE IN THE
SERIES THAT WRAPS UP TODAY.
STILL TIED AT 1-1.
>> OH, MY!
>> THIS ONE IS --
>> OUTTA HERE!
>> THAT BALL IS HIT A MILE TO
RIGHT HEADING FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY.
5-3, GIANTS.
LAMONTE WADE, JR.
>> THERE IS LAMONTE WADE'S
MOTHER, EMILY.
[LAUGHTER]
SO THE FANS COME EVERYBODY
STANDING NOW.
GIANTS HAVE BEEN PLAYING CATCH
UP ON MY LONG.
I DRIVE TO RIGHT.
DOWN THE LINE.
GRAND SLAM INTO THE WATER.
CAN YOU BELIEVE IT?
AND THEY SCORE INCLUDING THE MAN
WHO HIT THE BALL, THE GIANTS
HAVE COME FROM 7-0 BEHIND
COMMAND IS PENSKE HAS -- AND
YASTRZEMSKI HAS PUT THEM AHEAD.
SCOTT: GET READY FOR THIS.
LISTEN TO MLB'S COMCAST TO HEAR
ANALYSIS AND EXCLUSIVE IN-DEPTH
INTERVIEWS WITH BASEBALL'S
BIGGEST STARS.
MLB.COM/PODCASTS.
TIM: MLB BALLPARK APP OR
COMPLETE YOUR NEXT VISIT TO THE
BALLPARK.
ACCESS EXCLUSIVE CONTENT AND
MUCH MORE.
DOWNLOAD THE BALLPARK APP TODAY.
DO IT.
SCOTT: NAILED IT.
SHAWN: THAT WAS GOOD.
TIM: GOT UP LIKE SOMETHING ELSE.
SCOTT: YOUR TIME WILL COME.
FOULED OFF THE END OF THE BAT ON
GARCIA.
THAT WAS PERFECT, SHAWN.
I FEEL VERY COMFORTABLE AND COZY
WITH MY FRIEND SHAWN ESTES AND
TIM DILLARD.
SHAWN: I CAN'T WAIT FOR DILLY'S
READ.
TIM: I CAN READ PRETTY DECENT.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT IS NOT THE HARDEST THING
FOR ME.
I TELL YOU WHAT, WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT LOWRIE AFTER THAT PLAY AND
THROWING A 10-PITCH INNING.
SHAWN: HE HAD ENOUGH REST.
I THINK HE WAS IN THE CLUBHOUSE
FOR A GOOD 20 MINUTES AFTER
THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
WE DIDN'T GET TO SEE IT, BUT WE
ARE WAITING FOR LOWRIE TO TAKE
THE MOUND.
TIM: DIDN'T HAVE TIME.
LOGAN WEBB THROUGH HIS
SEVEN-PITCH INNING.
TIT FOR TAT, BACK-AND-FORTH.
HE LOOKED GOOD, EVERYTHING
LOOKED THE SAME.
SHAWN: DID NOT MISS A BEAT.
SCOTT: THIS IS A GOOD
OLD-FASHIONED PITCHING MATCHUP,
AND I SAY THAT NOT JUST BECAUSE
OF THE SCORE, BUT BECAUSE OF THE
WAY THEY HAVE BEEN ECONOMICAL.
THERE IS LOGAN WEBB, JUST NOT
WASTING PITCHES.
HIS NINTH STRIKEOUT.
1-1 AND THE SEVEN.
ROWDY TELLEZ HAS MORE FOR US.
SCOTT: IN A MOMENT.
ROWDY'S MIC'D UP.
SHAWN: WE ARE WAITING
FOR ROWDY TO SAY SOMETHING.
TIM: ROWDY'S NOT BEING ROWDY.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: NINE ON THE DAY FOR WEBB.
SHAWN: MELLOW ROWDY RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS THE HAT TRICK FOR
GARCIA, BY THE WAY.
SCOTT: JACE PETERSON IS 1-2.
R.B.I. HIT FOR MILWAUKEE IN THE
FOURTH.
ODD COURTESY OF FANDUEL.
WHO SAID OVER, WHO SAID UNDER?
SHAWN: GIVE ONE GUESS, BREWERS
AND THE GIANTS.
BREWERS SO FAR GIANT IS WINNING.
TIM: I DON'T GAMBLE A LOT.
I AM NOT A BETS MAN.
I MY GUESS MAN.
SCOTT: THERE IS STILL TIME FOR
YOU.
2-1 TO PETERSON.
SHAWN: THIS IS THE ONE GUY WHO
HAS HELPED YOUR CHANCES OF GOING
OVER SO FAR.
ONE R.B.I. FOR THE BREWERS.
TWO-OUT SITUATION IN THE FOURTH
INNING.
SCOTT: THE MONSTER MONTH OF
AUGUST.
HE WAS GREAT LAST MONTH.
HE DOES THAT VERY WELL.
STAYS IN THE ZONE.
LAST MONTH THEY LOOKED UP THE
POSITIONS HE PLAYED.
SIX TOTAL FOR JACE PETERSON,
INCLUDING A PITCHING
PERFORMANCE.
SHAWN: GOT THE BUMP.
HOW DID HE LOOK, DILLY?
TIM: PRETTY GOOD, LIKE A
POSITION PLAYER ON THE MOUND.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: ANOTHER STRIKEOUT VICTIM.
DOUBLE-DIGIT PUNCH-OUTS FOR
LOGAN WEBB.
ROWDY TELLEZ, ARE YOU THERE?
ROWDY: I THINK BRANDON CRAWFORD
HAS ONE OF THE BEST CLEAT GAMES
AND BASEBALL.
WHEN A COUPLE WORLD SERIES --
CECUM I TOLD YOU, CHECK OUT HIS
-- SEE, I TOLD YOU, CHECK OUT
HIS CLEATS.
FREE MARKETING, BUT YOU GOT THAT
ON THE MIC?
THOSE WERE SICK.
SCOTT: NOW THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO HOOK YOU UP WITH A PAIR,
ROWDY.
SHAWN: DEFINITELY KNOW WHERE
BRANDON CRAWFORD IS ON THE
FIELD.
TIM: HE KNOWS WHICH SHOE GOES ON
WHICH FOOT, TOO.
SCOTT: THAT'S MY NAME.
SHAWN: NO HE HAD --YOU KNOW WHO
HAD A SOLID SHOE GAME, GABE
KAPLER.
TIM: I WONDER IF THERE'S A
CONTEST, WHO CAN OF THEM WAS
ORANGE ON THEIR FEET.
GABE KAPLER WAS ON TOP OF HIS
GAME, FOR SURE.
SCOTT: IF LOGAN WEBB PICKS UP
ANOTHER STRIKE ON DANIEL
VOGELBACH, NOT ONLY WILL IT BE
ANOTHER 1-2-3 FOR HIM, IT WOULD
BE A CAREER-HIGH 11 STRIKEOUTS.
HE HAS SMASHES CAREER-HIGH MARK
AT THE MOMENT.
AS SHE HAS MATCHED -- HE HAS
SMASHES CAREER-HIGH MARK AT THE
MOMENT.
SHAWN: DEPENDS ON HOW THIS
AT-BAT GOES, BUT YOU THINK IF
YOU COULD GET THROUGH THIS
INNING AT 90 PITCHES, DEPENDING
ON HOW THE EIGHTH INNING WENT,
STILL IS A TIED GAME.
THEY HAVE A CHANCE TO PITCH
DEEPER THAN THAT TIM: I THINK
YOU GOT TO LISTEN TO THE GAME.
YOU LOOK AT SOMEONE LIKE
GABE KAPLER WHO PLAYED, JUST
LIKE CRAIG COUNSELL, YOU GOT TO
READ THE GAME, AND WHAT IS THE
GAME TELLING YOU?
IF HE CAN GO 110 PITCHES, YOU
GOTTA PUT HIM BACK OUT THERE.
IT IS NOT A PITCH COUNT GAME
OTHER THAN --
SHAWN: STUFF IS STILL NASTY,
GETTING SWING AND MISS.
SCOTT: PAYOFF.
KEEP IN MIND, THEY'RE ASKING HIM
TO BE THE STOPPER TODAY, TOO.
GIANTS HAVE LOST FOUR AND --
FOUR IN A ROW.
SHAWN: BUT WON 12 OUT OF THE
LAST 13 WITH LOGAN WEBB ON THE
MOUND.
THE ONE LOSS WAS AGAINST THE
BREWERS.
HE PITCHED PRETTY WELL IN
MILWAUKEE.
BREWERS WERE ABLE TO GET HIM
LATE IN THE GAME.
SCOTT: SMOKED OFF THE BAT OF
VOGELBACH.
IT'S GOING TO BOUNCE UP OFF THE
RIGHT-FIELD WALL.
HE IS HEADING FOR A SECOND GOOD
HERE COMES THE THROW.
THEY GOT HIM!
AUSTIN SLATER ON THE MONEY!
SHAWN: THAT IS THE BIG LEAGUES
RIGHT THERE, OH, MY GOODNESS.
TIM: HE WAS GOING.
HE PUT HIS HEAD DOWN AND STARTED
RUNNING RIGHT OUT OF THE GATE.
THAT WAS A GOOD PLAY OFF THE
WALL, THROW RIGHT THERE.
SHAWN: YOU WATCH THE THROW,
PERFECT OFF-THE-WALL.
VOGELBACH SNIFFING THE DOUBLE
OUT-OF-THE-BOX, BUT SLATER
THROWS IT CLEAN AND A STRAIGHT
HOPPER ON THE BAT THAT IS TEXT
BUT PERFECTION RIGHT THERE.
TIM: I THINK HE TOOK HIS MIND
OFF GETTING THE SECOND HALFWAY
THROUGH AND TRIED TO PICK IT UP.
SHAWN: TOUGH TO SLOW THAT BIG
BODY DOWN.
TIM: HE HAS BEEN BATTLING SOME
LEG STUFF.
SCOTT: 536 PLAYERS WITH THE
SPRINT SPEED CLOCK, AND
VOGELBACH IS 512.
SLATER KNEW IT.
>> OH, MY.
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF!
>> THIS ONE IS --
>> OUTTA HERE!
>> 1-2.
FLY BALL.
BACK INTO THE DEEP RIGHT FIELD.
IT IS GONE!
WILLY ADAMES GOES OPPOSITE FIELD
IN THE NINTH, AND THE BREWERS
LEAD IT IN COLORADO.
>> 1-0.
SWING AND A DRIVE.
DEEP LEFT FIELD.
WE ARE TIED.
WILLY ADAMES STRIKES AGAIN
AGAINST THE COLORADO ROCKIES.
THE BREWERS, BACK, DOWN 4-0.
ADAMES IN THE AIR, RIGHT CENTER.
AND IT IS UP AND OUT.
IT IS A GRAND SLAM.
THE FIRST OF THE YEAR FOR THE
BREWERS.
WILLY ADAMES AGAIN.
IN THIS BALLPARK IS LIT UP.
SCOTT: MLB ORIGINAL SEASON TWO.
SEE YOUR FAVORITE PLAYERS AND
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE GAME YOU
LOVE.
BRANDON CRAWFORD TAKES A STRIKE
ON THE INSIDE CORNER FROM ERIC
LAUER.
SO WE HAVE STRETCHED, AND WE
STILL SEE THE 1-1 SCORE.
SERIES BETWEEN THE BREWERS AND
GIANTS WRAPS UP TODAY, AND THEN
SAN FRANCISCO MOVES ON TO FACE
THE DODGERS THIS WEEKEND.
BREWERS HAD HOME BACK TO
MILWAUKEE.
THEY WILL FACE THE CARDINALS
WERE THREE.
A LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFERENT
LOOK.
TIM: SIDEARM, SITE HANDER.
GOTTA TO LOVE THOSE GUYS.
SCOTT: LOVE IT.
CRAWFORD, CASALI, DUBON AND THE
SEVENTH.
JUST 76 PITCHES SO FAR TODAY.
TIM: LONGEST OUTING THIS YEAR
WAS AGAINST PITTSBURGH JULY 3.
THIS IS UNCHARTED TERRITORY.
HE HAS EARNED IT.
I THINK YOU GOT TO LEAVE HIM OUT
THERE CONTINUALLY.
PERSONAL YOU GOT TO GO WITH
LOGAN WEBB.
LET THEM GO OUT THERE AND DEAL.
THEY HAVE SET UP HITTERS
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE GAME TO
WHERE THE NEXT TIME THEY COME
OUT THEY HAVE A PLAN.
SHAWN: IF WEBB'S SPOT COMES UP
WHERE THE GIANT GETS ON BASE,
HIS SPOT WILL COME UP.
THIS MAY BE THE ONLY OPPORTUNITY
TO SCORE A RUN.
IF HE CAN GET SOMEONE INTO
SCORING POSITION.
WE HAVE SEEN HIM DO IT ALL YEAR.
HE WILL PULL THE TRIGGER EARLY
IN THE GAME.
SCOTT: LOOK AT THAT.
TIM: MAYBE THEY ARE
CONGRATULATIONS, YOU GOT ANOTHER
ONE.
PROBABLY NOT.
[LAUGHTER]
SHAWN: MAYBE KAP IS FEELING THEY
WILL GET SOMEBODY ON BASE.
WISHFUL THINKING.
HE IS NOT SOMEBODY WHO WILL GET
HIM HOT AND THEN NOT BRING HIM
IN THE GAME, EITHER.
SCOTT: CASALI AFTER CRAWFORD.
34-YEAR-OLD BRANDON CRAWFORD.
SHAWN: OUTSIDE OF THAT FIRST
PITCH OF THE GAME, THE ONLY RUN
THAT THE GIANTS SCORED.
ERIC LAUER'S PITCHED AS WELL AS
LOGAN WEBB.
STRIKEOUTS LOOK PRETTIER WITH
LOGAN WEBB AND HIS DOMINANCE.
LAUER IS SUPEREFFICIENT.
SCOTT: THERE IS THE STRIKEOUT.
HERE YOU, SHA AS SHE HEARD YOU,
--THEY ARGUE, SHA-- HE HEARD
YOU, SHAWN.
SHAWN: LIKE YOU MENTIONED, WEAK
CONTACT.
SCOTT: DILLY, IT'S ALL YOU.
TIM: POSTSEASON RACES ON.
MLB.TV.
RESTRICTIONS APPLY.
VISIT MLB.TV FOR DETAILS.
SCOTT: I'M GOING HOME.
CURT CASALI TO CENTER.
JACKIE BRADLEY, JR., CIRCLES
AROUND IT.
THAT WAS PERFECTION.
TIM: YEAH.
I READ IT SEVEN TIMES.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT YOUTUBE VIDEO I WATCHED,
HOW TO BE A GOOD BROADCASTER,
PAYING OFF RIGHT NOW.
SCOTT: WHOEVER PUT THAT
TOGETHER.
BEAUTIFULLY DONE.
SHAWN: ANOTHER FLY BALL OUT,
DILLY.
TIM: LONGEST OUTING OF THE
SEASON FOR ERIC LAUER.
ANOTHER FIRST PITCH OUT.
FOUR OF THOSE ON THE DAY.
SHAWN: I GUY THAT THROWS A LOT
OF HOSPITALS AND POUNDS THE
STRIKE ZONE THAT IS WHAT YOU
SHOULD DO.
GO UP THERE AND BE AGGRESSIVE.
THE FASTBALL UP IN THE ZONE
PLAYS A LOT HARDER THAN IT
REALLY IS.
SEEING A LOT OF FLY BALLS, BUT
THEY ARE NOT SQUARED UP.
THE HITTERS THINK THEY ARE ON
TIME FOR IT AND THEY THINK THEY
ARE GOING TO GET BARREL AND THEN
THEY JUST MISSED THE BARREL.
TIM: LIKE BEN SHEETS BACK IN THE
DAY, THROWING STRIKES EARLY.
I HITTER THAT IS LIKE, OK, THIS
GUY ISN'T THROWING ANY BALLS.
0-2 BEFORE YOU KNOW IT.
PENDING GLOVE IS TIGHT.
YOU SAID THAT TONE AND THE
FOUNDATION WILL SUPPORT PITCHERS
HAVE DONE THAT REMARKABLY.
SHAWN: YOU GET HITTERS IN SWING
MODE BEFORE THEY STEP IN THE
BOX.
THIS GIANTS TEAM HAS PRIDED
HIMSELF ON WORKING COUNTS AND
GETTING THEM OUT OF THE GAME
EARLIER, ESPECIALLY STARTERS.
THAT HAD A DIFFICULT TIME WITH
PITCHERS THAT THROW STRIKES THAT
HAVE DIFFERENT TIMES IN THE ZONE
THIS YEAR.
GUYS THAT ATTACK THEM THAT DON'T
RUN FROM THEM AND DON'T NIBBLE,
GUYS THAT ARE AGGRESSIVE WITH
GOOD STUFF.
THAT MAKES THEM GO INTO SWING
MODE.
TIM: ONE THING THAT THIS BREWERS
STAFF AS A WHOLE DOES IS THEY
PLAY IN THE ZONE.
THEY'RE WILLING TO GET SWINGS
AND MISSES, UNCOMFORTABLE
SWINGS, WEAK CONTACT IN THE
ZONE.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO RELY ON THAT
PITCH.
HE CHASED IT.
NO, TRYING TO GIVE YOU A GOOD
STRIKE.
SHAWN: IT HELPS TO HAVE AS MANY
GUYS IN THE ROTATION AND
THE BULLPEN THAT CAN'T STRIKE
YOU OUT, TOO.
SCOTT: ANOTHER 3-2 COUNT TODAY.
BRADLEY, JR., AND THE GOLD
GLOVER IS ALL OVER IT.
KOLTEN WONG WITH A SMILE.
ERIC LAUER HAS BEEN FANTASTIC
TODAY FOR MILWAUKEE.
PRESERVING THIS GAME THROUGH
SEVEN.
>> THIS WAS A BASEBALL GENIUS
WHO POSITIONED THE GIANTS'
DEFENSE AND GAME PLAN FOR AND
AGAINST PITCHERS.
>> YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU ARE IN CONTROL.
>> BUT THE TRUE GENIUS OF WILLIE
MAYS IS FOUND IN HIS NICKNAME,
THE SAY HEY KID.
>> SAY HEY.
>> TED WILLIAMS, GARY CARTER,
KEN GRIFFEY, JR., AND WILLIE
MAYS COME ALL HALL OF FAME
PLAYERS WHO EARNED THE HIGHEST
NICKNAME HONOR, KID.
THEY'RE PLAYING STICKBALL IN
HARLEM AT 20, WINNING THE WORLD
SERIES AT 23, KNOCKING IN THE
WINNING RUN OF THE WORLD SERIES
GAME WITH HIS LAST HIT AT 42, OR
TURNING 90 YEARS OLD THIS YEAR.
>> WILLIE MAYS.
>> WILLIE MAYS IS THE PUREST
VERSION OF BASEBALL THAT WE HOLD
SO DEAR, THAT THIS IS A KID'S
GAME.
IT IS DESIGNED TO BE FUN.
WHEN PLAYED WELL AND WITH JOY,
BASEBALL IS NEVER BETTER.
SCOTT: STILL 1-1, AS WE CLIMB
INTO THE EIGHTH INNING AND
DOCUMENT THE STORY OF CHRISTIAN
YELICH WITH THE BACK-TO-BACK NL
BATTING TITLES.
AN M.V.P. ON THE RESUME,
LIFETIME CONTRACT WITH THE
BREWERS DURING HIS CAREER.
CAREER-WORST .205, AND
CAREER-WORST SLUGGING LINE.
CRAIG COUNSELL, HIS MANAGER,
SINCE HE HAS BEEN ON FIRE
LATELY.
WE ARE LOOKING ON THE CONFIDENCE
LEVEL OF ANYONE.
CAN HE REGAIN HIS M.V.P. FORM IN
OCTOBER?
DILLY SPECIAL -- HERE FOR THE
NACHOS.
TIM: HERE FOR THE HOT DOG.
YESTERDAY AFTER THE GAME I WAS
WALKING OUT OF THE PARK AND
THERE WAS A LADY SELLING HOT
DOGS WRAPPED IN BACON.
SHAWN: DID YOU GO THERE?
TIM: IT WAS IN MY WAY, AND I'M
LIKE, I HAVE TO DO THIS.
SCOTT: JUST TO GET THROUGH.
THIS IS A GUY YOU WILL NEED TO
BREAK DOWN EVEN THOUGH SHAWN'S
BEEN HANDLING THE GIANTS
PITCHERS FOR US.
TIM, YOU DECIDED TO PITCH LIKE
TYLER ROGERS, OR TYLER ROGERS
DECIDED TO PITCH LIKE TIM
DILLARD.
HE IS A HIGH USAGE GUY.
HE LED THE NL IN APPEARANCES
EACH OF THE LAST TWO SEASONS, AS
HE TAKES OVER FOR LOGAN WEBB,
WHO WAS ELITE THIS AFTERNOON ON
THE MOUND.
TIM: THAT IS THE SIDE EFFECT OF
THROWING DOWN THEIR, SUBMARINE
ACTION, EVEN SIDEARM.
LESS STRESS ON THE  IT
COMES DOWN TO HAVING A PLAY
AGAINST LEFTIES.
YOUR WHOLE CRAFT IS BUILT TO GET
RIGHTIES OUT.
WE SEE IT RIGHT HERE, DOING A
GREAT JOB AGAINST LEFT-HANDED
HITTERS.
SHAWN: YOU SEE TYLER ROGERS
THROWING OUT OF THE SHOES RIGHT
THERE.
AUSTIN SLATER RECOMMENDED HE
WEAR WHITE SHOES THIS SPRING.
YOU THROW FROM DOWN THERE, IT
COULD CAUSE A DISTRACTION TO THE
HITTER.
BALL COMES OUT OF YOUR SHOES,
WHY NOT USE IT TO YOUR
ADVANTAGE.
HE HAS BEEN ROCKING THEM ALL
YEAR LONG AND HE HAS HAD ANOTHER
GREAT SEASON.
TIM: DEAR AGENT, I NEED WHITE
SHOES AND RED PLACES.
[LAUGHTER]
SHAWN: BRIGHTER THE WHITE,
THE BETTER.
SCOTT: THERE IS NO RULE AGAINST
THAT.
SHAWN: NOT YET, ANYWAY.
SCOTT: MIGHT HAVE JUST GIVEN IT
AWAY.
SHAWN: IT IS SO FUNKY.
DIFFERENT LOOK TO THE HITTERS.
POLAR OPPOSITES RIGHT THERE --
TIM: FOR DIFFERENT REASONS.
SHAWN: NEON ORANGE.
ONE FOR SHOW, ONE FOR
EFFECTIVENESS.
TIM: HI TOP WITH BRANDON
CRAWFORD.
THAT PROBABLY HELPS SUPPORT.
SCOTT: LUKE MAILE, FOUL BALL.
WE ALSO SAW SOMETHING FROM
ROGERS AGAINST BRADLEY THAT YOU
DON'T SEE AS FREQUENTLY AS YOU
DO FOR MOST BELIEVERS.
DESPITE THE EXCELLENT E.R.A.
THIS YEAR FOR TYLER ROGERS,
STRIKEOUTS PER NINE INNINGS IS
AMONG THE LOWEST FOR THE RELIEF
PITCHER.
KILLING WORMS, TAKING NUMBERS.
SHAWN: CONTACT GUY.
MAKES THEM PUT IT IN PLATE
WEEKLY.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT, HE IS NOT A
STRIKEOUT ANY GUY.
COMING FROM DOWN UNDER, YES THE
FRISBEE AND THE SLIDER, LOOKS
LIKE IT ALMOST RISES.
MIGHT HAVE BEEN A SINKER.
DOESN'T THROW HARD.
IT IS HARD TO THROW HARD FROM
DOWN THERE.
NOT MANY GUYS CAN THROW 90 THAT
ANKLE.
TIM: WHEN YOUR HAND GETS PAST
YOUR SHOULDER GOING DOWN, IT IS
HARD TO GET FORCE BEHIND IT.
I MADE SURE THAT THE BALL WAS
JUST BEFORE MY SHOULDER SO I
COULD KEEP THE VELOCITY.
NOT TRY TO BLOW A GUY AWAY WITH
HEAT.
HE IS PLAYING OFF HIS OFFSPEED
STUFF.
JUST THE FUNKINESS OF IT -- YOU
MAY GO THE ENTIRE SEASON AND NOT
FACE A GUY LIKE THIS.
FOR YOU TO BUY INTO IT AND GO
I'M GOING TO THROW MY STUFF
BECAUSE I'M GOING TO RELY ON
THESE GUYS NOT HAVING ANY
PRACTICE AND NO REFERENCE POINT
FOR WHAT I'M DOING OUT HERE.
SCOTT: THIS IS ROWDY TELLEZ
PITCHING FOR ERIC LAUER, WHOSE
DAY IS DONE.
SHAWN: UP IN THE ZONE AND ALMOST
LOOKS LIKE IT RISES WHEN HE GETS
TO THE PLATE.
PHYSICALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO DO.
WHEN YOU COME FROM THAT ANGLE,
GETS TO THE TOP OF THE ZONE,
HOLDS ITS PLAIN AND RATHER THAN
SINKS.
IS ROWDY STILL MIC'D?
SCOTT: YES, HE IS.
WE WILL GET WORD FROM ROWDY.
AT SOME POINT WE WILL TURN THE
AUDIO AROUND AND GET HIS
THOUGHTS.
SHAWN: ANOTHER THING THAT ROGERS
DOES SO WELL IS HE STAYS OUT OF
THE MIDDLE PART OF THE ZONE.
ESPECIALLY AGAINST TEAMS THAT
HAVE SEEN HIM MORE THAN OTHERS.
DODGERS, PADRES, DIAMONDBACKS.
TEAMS THAT SEE HIM TWO OR THREE
TIMES IN A SERIES GET SWINGS
AGAINST HIM.
HE HAS GOT TO BE A TOUGH AT-BAT.
SCOTT: WOW.
THERE IS THE UP AND IN.
SHAWN: SLIDER TAKES OFF.
NASTY.
SCOTT: THAT THING SAILED INTO
THE BAY.
TYLER ROGERS FROM EVERYONE.
>> THE BIG RIGHT-HANDER WITH A
HANDLEBAR MUSTACHE.
>> UP UNTIL '81, THEY NEEDED THE
CLOSER.
THEY NEEDED THE CONFIDENCE THAT
CAME WITH A GUY LIKE FINGERS.
>> WHEN HE SIGNED WITH THE
MILWAUKEE BREWERS, WE KNEW THAT
WHEN GAMES WERE CALLED UPON FOR
HIS SERVICES, CHANCES OF WINNING
HERMETICALLY INCREASED.
-- DRAMATICALLY INCREASED.
>> WHEN HE CAME INTO A GAME, YOU
KNEW THE GAME WAS OVER.
THAT WAS THE WAY WE FELT.
>> ROLLIE FINGERS, ACE RELIEVER
OF THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS.
>> AND FINGERS NEVER MISSED A
BEAT, DOMINATING THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE.
>> '81 WAS THE YEAR THAT ROLLIE
WON THE M.V.P. AND CY
YOUNG, AND I DO NOT BELIEVE
ROLLIE FINGERS MADE A BAD PITCH
GET >> HE WAS THE FIREMAN OF THE
YEAR AND WINNER OF THE RELIEF
MAN AWARD.
BOTH HIS TALENT AND UNIQUE STYLE
BROUGHT HIM A CULT FOLLOWING IN
MILWAUKEE.
>> ROLLIE THE MAGNIFICENT WITH
HIS HANDLEBAR.
>> ROLLIE!
ROLLIE!
>> THE HISTORY AND PERFORMANCE
OF THIS MAN, ROLLIE FINGERS, HAS
BEEN CLEARLY DOCUMENTED.
SCOTT: THIS COPYRIGHTED TELECAST
PRESENTED BY THE AUTHORITY OF
THE COMMISSIONER OF BASEBALL AND
MAY NOT BE REPRODUCED OR
RETRANSMITTED IN ANY FORM AND
CONTENTS MAY NOT BE DISSEMINATED
WITHOUT THE EXPRESS WRITTEN
CONSENT.
SCOTT BRAUN, SHAWN ESTES, TIM
DILLARD, AND AMY G JOINING US
NOW.
AMY: HEARTS ARE BREAKING ALL
OVER THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO,
AS RON IS COMING UP SHORTLY TO
COACH THIRD BASE LONGEST TENURED
COACH IN SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS
HISTORY.
YOU WILL BE HANDY GET UP AFTER
THIS SEASON AND WILL NOTE
YOUNGER BE A FULL-TIME COACH
COME 2022.
HE HAS BEEN WITH THAT THE GIANTS
ORGANIZATION FOR 34 YEARS, 21 OF
THOSE YEARS WITH THE BIG-LEAGUE
CLUB.
I TALKED TO THE HITTING COACH
RESET RON WOTUS- --WHO SAID
RON WOTUS HAS BEEN A SOUNDING
BOARD GOOD RON HAS BEEN THIS
PILLAR OF WISDOM AND EXPERIENCE
AND KNOWLEDGE.
DONNIE ECKER REFERRED TO HIM AS
A HUMAN GOOGLE.
HE WILL DEFINITELY BE MISSED.
HE IS ABSOLUTELY BE LOVED BY ALL
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
SCOTT: HATS OFF TO YOU, RON.
WHAT A CAREER.
WHAT A GUY.
HE WILL BE MISSED.
HE SAID LITTLE MORE LIFE
BALANCE, HANGING WITH THE FAM AT
THIS POINT.
WHEN YOU ARE PART OF THE
COACHING STAFF, SAME GRIND AS
THE PLAYERS.
YOU ARE ON THE ROAD HALF THE
SUMMER.
SPECIAL INDIVIDUAL, SPECIAL
COACH.
LAMONTE WADE, JR., PINCH HITTER.
THAT WHEN HE GOT UNDER.
CHRISTIAN YELICH FINDING SOME
SUN AND FINDING OUT NUMBER ONE.
CAN YOU GIVE US ANYTHING GOOD ON
RON WOTUS?
DEVIN WILLIAMS IS IN THE GAME.
CHANGE OF AFICIONADO.
SHAWN: PRETTY SPECIAL PITCHER
RIGHT HERE.
SPECIAL ALL AROUND RIGHT NOW.
TIM: A LOT OF SPECIAL.
LOOKING SPECIFICALLY AT DEVIN
WILLIAMS, THE AIR BINDER.
LOGAN WEBB HAS GOT A GREAT
CHANGEUP.
COMING BACK TO THE FOREFRONT.
IF YOU LOOK SPECIFICALLY AT
DEVIN WILLIAMS COME IN HIS LAST
31 APPEARANCES, NINE INNINGS,
ONLY GIVEN UP ONE EARNED RUN.
SCOTT: THAT WILL PLAY.
SHAWN: THAT WILL PLAY.
BACK TO RON WOTUS, HE WAS MAY
MANAGER IN AA AND AAA AND WON
THE DIVISIONS BOTH THOSE YEARS.
YOU KNEW HE WAS DESTINED FOR THE
BIG LEAGUES.
HE GOT DUSTY BAKER AND HAD HIM
ON HIS COACHING STAFF RIGHT
AFTER THAT.
HE HAS BEEN WITH THE CLUB EVER
SINCE.
LONGEST-TENURED COACH.
I CAN GO ON AND ON ABOUT RON
WOTUS AND WHAT HE HAS MEANT TO
THIS ORGANIZATION AND THE WEALTH
OF KNOWLEDGE.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE HE HAS NOT
BEEN A MANAGER IN HIS CAREER AT
THIS POINT.
HE HAS HAD A FEW INTERVIEWS AND
FOR WHATEVER REASON HE HAS NOT
GOTTEN THE OPPORTUNITY, BUT HE
HAS FILLED ALL KINDS OF
DIFFERENT ROLES WITHIN THE
GIANTS AND HE IS A STANDUP GUY
AND THEY ARE DEFINITELY GOING TO
MISS HIM.
I'M SURE HE WILL BE AROUND IN
SOME CAPACITY.
THAT IS YET TO BE DETERMINED.
HE WON'T BE IN THE DUGOUT, IN
THE CLUBHOUSE, AND JUST LIKE YOU
MENTIONED, SOUNDING BOARD FOR A
LOT OF THE OTHER COACHES.
AND THE PLAYERS LOVE HIM.
CRAWFORD RIGHT AWAY, DID A GOAT
ON TWITTER AFTER HE FOUND OUT HE
WAS GOING TO STEP DOWN NEXT
YEAR.
SCOTT: STAPLE IN THE
ORGANIZATION.
WE JUST SHOWED YOU SOME
DEFENSIVE SWAPPING.
PETERSON TO RIGHT FIELD.
URIAS MOVES OVER FROM SHORT TO
THIRD.
IN COMES THE SHOW MEN, WILLY
ADAMES.
AND THE BIRTHDAY BOY.
SHAWN: HAPPY BIRTHDAY, WILLIE.
TIM: SHOULD I TELL HIM I WORE
HIS HELMET IN THE DUGOUT?
[LAUGHTER]
SHAWN: WE WILL HAVE TO SEE IF IT
WAS LUCKY OR NOT.
SCOTT: YOU WILL FIND OUT.
SL--WE WILL FIND OUT.
SLATER GONE FISHING.
SHAWN: A LOT OF GUYS GO FISHING
WITH THIS PITCH.
ONE OF THE BEST PITCHERS IN ALL
OF BASEBALL.
MAYBE THE BEST.
TIM: IT SETS ITSELF APART WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT GUYS WITH A
REALLY GOOD FASTBALLS AND
CUTTERS, REALLY GOOD CURVEBALL.
CHANGEUP IS SPECIAL IN THAT WAY
BECAUSE HE THROWS IT 86 MILES AN
HOUR.
HE KNOWS IT AND THE PATTERN
KNOWS IT IS COMING.
HE GOES OUT AND THROWS IT.
THAT HAS GOT ENCOURAGE.
YOU ARE GOING, I KNOW YOU KNOW
IT IS COMING AND I AM GOING
TO THROW IT ANYWAY.
SHAWN: WHAT IS CRAZY ABOUT HIS
CHANGEUP -- THE HITTERS KNOW
THEY ARE GOING TO SEE IT.
AND NOT LIKE TREVOR HOFFMAN -- A
LOT LIKE TREVOR HOFFMAN, HE HAD
A GOOD FASTBALL TO GO WITH IT.
HEATERS NEW THEY WERE GOING TO
SEE THE CHANGEUP.
IF YOU LOCATED, TOUGH TO SQUARE
UP.
GOT TO BE UP IN THE ZONE TO BE
ABLE TO HIT IT.
YOU RARELY EVER SEEMS TO MAKE A
MISTAKE IN THE CHANGEUP.
TIM: I THINK HE WAS TRYING TO
BALANCE IT OUT WITH THE FASTBALL
EARLY ON.
WHEN HE HAS A FEEL FOR IT, YOU
CAN THROW IT EVERY SINGLE PITCH.
THE REASON IT IS SUCH A MIND
BENDER IS BECAUSE IT TAKES YOU
BACK A NOTCH ON HOW MUCH IT
MOVES.
THEY THINK HE MADE A MISTAKE AND
IT ENDS UP IN THE DIRT.
JUST AN INCREDIBLE PITCH.
SCOTT: ANOTHER FASTBALL THE KRIS
BRYANT.
SHAWN: YOU WONDER SOMETIMES,
PITCHERS, THEY DON'T FORGET
CERTAIN PLAYERS' AT-BATS, OR IF
THEY HAVE HIT A HOME RUN.
YES FACED KRIS BRYANT BEING IN
THE NL CENTRAL.
THE PLACE NOW YOU ARE POETRY
GUY.
YOU ALMOST MIND TRICK YOURSELF
SOMETIMES INTO BELIEVING THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO HIT THE
CHANGEUP.
TIM: SOME SORT OF EDGE.
SHAWN: THEY HAVE SEEN IT SO MANY
TIMES.
MAYBE HE HAS SQUARED UP HIS
CHANGEUP IN THE PAST.
NOW HE IS SEEING A COUPLE
FASTBALLS.
SCOTT: THAT IS BALL 4.
TWO-OUT BASE RUNNER FOR THE
GIANTS.
TIM: SOMETIMES WHEN YOU GET
BEHIND ESPECIALLY REALLY GOOD
HITTERS, ONE-RUN BALLGAMES, YOU
ARE BETTER OFF WALKING THE GUY
IN HITTING THE RESET AND TRYING
FOR THE NEXT BATTER.
DEVIN WILLIAMS IS IN THE EIGHTH
INNING ROLE AND HAS COME TO THE
FOREFRONT -- IF IT TAKES ME 30
PITCHES, THAT IS FINE.
AS LONG AS YOU PUT UP A ZERO,
THEY DON'T CARE.
SHAWN: THIS IS A GUY IN THIS
WHOLE GIANT LINEUP THAT HAS THE
ABILITY TO SQUARE UP DEVIN
WILLIAMS.
SCOTT: NEXT UP, BRANDON BELT.
SHAWN: BECAUSE OF THAT HE WILL
MAKE DEVIN WILLIAMS GO AWAY FROM
HIS STRENGTH.
ABOVE HIS HANDS WITH HIGH
VELOCITY.
IF THAT IS NOT ONE OF YOUR
STRENGTHS, YOU ARE KIND OF
PLAYING RIGHT INTO HIS HAND.
TIM: GOT TO GO ABOVE THE BELT
FOR BELT.
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO DO
THAT --
SHAWN: I DID NOT.
SCOTT: I WAS WAITING FOR THAT.
TOUGH STRIKE FOR BELT.
NOT DOING MUCH WITH THAT PITCH.
GIANTS IF YOU SWING AT IT AND
MAKE --
SHAWN: IF YOU SWING AT IT AND
MAKE CONTACT IT WILL ROLL OVER
SO YOU MIGHT AS WELL JUST TAKE
IT.
TO BE ABLE TO LOCATE THAT LIKE
THAT IS UNFAIR.
SCOTT: NL RELIEVER OF THE MONTH
IN AUGUST.
TO-ONE.
BELT, BY THE WAY, FIVE HOME RUNS
AGAINST THE BREWERS THIS YEAR.
FACING A TEAM LIKE THIS SEVEN
TIMES OF THE SEASON, BRANDON
BELT AS PUNISH  BREWER PITCHING.
SHAWN: YES PUNISHED RIGHT-HANDED
PITCHERS AS FAR AS THE HOME RUNS
GO.
BAKE ON THIS GAME.
I HAD AND THE COUNT.
-- AHEAD IN THE COUNT.
BRANDON BELT COMMUTE CAN
ELIMINATE THE FASTBALL NOW.
TIM: PEOPLE ARE DOING THE PICK
TO FIRST.
NOT ALLOWED TO DO THAT.
SCOTT: SCOTT: NO.
[LAUGHTER]
NOT ON THE ROAD, YOU KNOW THAT.
SHAWN: DID THEY REALIZE 90 FEET
IS A PRETTY BIG DEAL NOW?
SCOTT: 2-1, HE IS RUNNING.
KRIS BRYANT FOR SECOND, AND HE
IS OUT LUKE MAILE DELIVERS.
WILLY ADAMES SLAPS ON THE TAG.
SHAWN: THEY ARE GOING TO GIVE
THAT A LOOK.
WHAT A THROW BY MAILE.
LOOKED LIKE BRYANT HAD A GREAT
JUMP.
HE CAN RUN.
HE IS FASTER THAN HE LOOKS.
6-5, HE CAN GET AFTER IT.
HE CAN SCOOT.
TIM: WILLIAMS NOT TRYING TO HOLD
HIM TO CLOSE AS FAR AS BEING
QUICK TO THE PLATE.
HE IS FOCUSED ON TRYING TO MAKE
THE PITCH AT THE PLATE.
SCOTT: HERE IS YOUR MONEY SHOT.
WOW, THAT IS CLOSE.
SHAWN: TOUGH ANGLE RIGHT THERE.
WE NEED TO SEE THIS ONE HERE.
UNLESS THE UMPIRE BLOCKS IT OUT.
SCOTT: THIS IS BEING REVIEWED
OFFICIALLY, BY THE WAY.
ADAMES WITH THE GLOVE ON THE
LEFT SIDE OF BRYANT.
WITH THE CROWD THAT LOOKS AT THE
ANGLE THAT WE JUST SAW --
SHAWN: THE BREWERS' BEST FRIEND
MIGHT BE THE SECOND BASE UMPIRE.
I GUARANTEE THEY HAVE A BETTER
ANGLE IN NEW YORK.
TIM: SHARE IT WITH THE WORLD.
SHAWN: THE OVERHEAD A DRONE
ANGLE.
TIM: WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT IS
GOING ON.
SHAWN: IT MIGHT NOT BE ENOUGH.
SCOTT: YOU NEED TO BE CONCLUSIVE
TO OVERTURN WHAT IS ON THE
FIELD, WHICH IS OUT.
ARE WE CONFIDENT THAT HE IS SAFE
HERE?
TIM: ON ONE ANGLE HE IS TOUCHING
HIM HIGH AND THEN IT GOES DOWN.
YOU HAVE TO ASSUME ON THE ANGLE
-- HE IS TAKING HIM EARLY AT THE
TOP OF THE NUMBER.
SCOTT: THE CROWD IS GOING "SAFE,
SAFE!"
SHAWN: NEW YORK HAS MANY MORE
ANGLES THAN WE ARE SEEING RIGHT
NOW.
THIS MIGHT BE THE BEST ONE.
THAT IS STILL HARD BECAUSE YOU
CANNOT SEE WHAT THE HAND COMES
IN.
THIS WHEN YOU CANNOT SEE BECAUSE
THE GLOVE -- THAT IS GONE.
IT IS A BIG DEAL BECAUSE OF THE
3-1 COUNT ON BRANDON BELT.
SCOTT: I KNOW THE GIANTS CROWD
DOESN'T THINK IT IS CLOSE.
IT IS PRETTY CLOSE.
SHAWN: WHAT DID YOU THINK?
IT WAS CLOSE.
WELL, YEAH, OF COURSE IT IS
CLOSE, THAT IS WHY WE ARE
REVIEWING IT COULD [LAUGHTER]
IF IT WASN'T CLOSE WE WOULD BE
MOVING ONTO THE NINTH INNING.
SCOTT: THAT IS WHY IT IS TAKING
TIME.
THIS ONE IS NOT A GIMME.
HERE WE GO.
THE CONCLUSION -- HE'S SAFE.
KRIS BRYANT SWIPES THE BAG.
SHAWN: HE HURT HIMSELF.
JAMMED IT.
GOT TO KEEP.
-- GOT TO KEEP HE'S GOT THE OVEN
MITT ON.
HE WAS WAVING THE PINKY FINGER
AND HE TOOK HIS BATTING GLOVE
OFF AS WELL.
CHECKING OUT HIS PINKY FINGER.
SCOTT: LAST YEAR HE SPENT SOME
TIME ON THE INJURED LIST WITH
THE LEFT FINGER ISSUE.
NOW THE CROWD IS PUMPED.
LEVERAGE IN THE COUNT FOR BELT.
HE WALKS.
SHAWN: WHAT THAT DID IS IT
OPENED UP THE BASE.
AS A PITCHER, YOU ARE THINKING,
ALL RIGHT, YOU GOT A GUY ON
FIRST BASE, HE WILL PITCH TO
YOU.
NOW THAT YOU ARE SECOND, NOT
GIVING IN.
TIM: I WILL JUST PUT THIS GUY
OVER HERE AT FIRST.
HE HAS BEEN IN THIS EIGHTH
INNING ROLL ALL SEASON LONG.
SO MUCH EXPERIENCE, ROOKIE OF
THE YEAR.
FOR DEVIN WILLIAMS, IT IS TO
SLOW THINGS DOWN.
IT IS THE FREEZE THE KICKER
MOMENT WITH A REVIEW ON THE
PLAY.
THEY LOOK AT IT IN FIVE SECONDS
AND GO HE IS SAFE.
PROBABLY WOULD NOT HAVE AFFECTED
THE PITCHES SO MUCH.
THAT IS ONE OF THE WRONG THINGS
ABOUT REPLAY, YOU OVERLOOK THE
PITCHER.
HE THROWS TO THE CATCHER AND
STUFF, BUT IT TOTALLY DISRUPTS
THE MOMENT OF WHAT YOU ARE
TRYING TO DO.
ONE MORE THING THE PITCHER HAS
TO OVERCOME.
SHAWN: I DON'T THINK DEVIN
WILLIAMS REALLY LOVED THE
MATCHUP AGAINST BRANDON BELT
ANYWAY.
YOU SAW HIM GO AWAY FROM HIS
STRENGTH, WHICH IS HIS CHANGEUP.
KNOWING BRANDON BELT'S STRENGTH
IS SOFT DOWN IN THE ZONE.
AS SOON AS KRIS BRYANT STOLE
SECOND BASE, MADE IT PRETTY
EASY.
SCOTT: DARIN RUF LOVES
LEFT-HANDED PITCHING.
WE WILL SEE IF HE HAS THE
ABILITY TO CRACK THE CODE
AGAINST ONE OF THE TOUGHEST
RIGHTIES IN BASEBALL.
SHAWN: DEVIN WILLIAMS LOOKING
IN, LIKE THAT COULD HAVE BEEN A
STRIKE.
A LITTLE BIT BETTER FRAME JOB,
HE MIGHT'VE CAUGHT THE BOTTOM
PART OF THE ZONE.
SCOTT: WE SAW A SIMILAR LOCATION
CALLED FOR A STRIKE EARLIER IN
THIS INNING.
BRYANT ON SECOND, BELT ON FIRST.
GIANTS HAVE ONE RUN TODAY, AND
HE CAME ALL THE WAY BACK IN THE
OPENING INNING, FIRST PITCH FOR
THE OFFENSE, AUSTIN SLATER
SOCKED A HOMER.
ARE WE GOING TO SEE ANY
FASTBALLS THIS A.B.?
I FEEL LIKE THIS COULD BE
CHANGEUP CITY.
SHAWN: I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT.
GIANTS LOOKING FOR THAT BIG HIT.
THEY HAVEN'T HAD IT.
IT'S BEEN A WHILE.
SCOTT: RUF BLASTS ONE,
LEFT-FIELD, AND IT'S DOWN IN THE
CORNER.
HERE COMES BRYANT.
THE GIANTS GRAB THE LEAD.
IT IS 2-1.
DARIN RUF COMES THROUGH AGAINST
DEVIN WILLIAMS WITH A DOUBLE.
SHAWN: YOU SAW THE GRAPHIC,
RUNNERS IN IT'S GOING POSITION.
--RUNNERS IN THESE GOING
POSITION.
DARIN RUF SO CLUTCH COULD GET
THE CHANGEUP IN THE ZONE THAT HE
LIKES AND DRIVES THE BALL TO
LEFT FIELD.
THAT IS THE BIG HIT THEY HAVE
BEEN LOOKING FOR ALL SERIES.
MR. CLUTCH DOES IT AGAIN.
SCOTT: MR. WILLIAMS GIVES UP HIS
FIRST EARNED RUN SINCE JUNE 23.
THAT WAS A WHILE AGO.
IT IS SEPTEMBER, FOLKS.
SHAWN: AND YOU SAW KRIS BRYANT
GOING DOWN INTO THE TUNNEL.
I'M WONDERING IF THAT SLIDE INTO
SECOND BASE DIDN'T DO SOMETHING
TO HIS HAND.
HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE ON THAT
ONE.
NONETHELESS, GIANTS TAKE THE
LEAD.
MIGHT BE THE FIRST LEAD THEY
HAVE HAD IN THIS SERIES.
SCOTT: WELL, THEY HAD THE LEAD
IN THE FIRST INNING JUST
BRIEFLY.
AUSTIN SLATER WITH THE HOME RUN.
BUT THEN THE BREWERS CAUGHT UP
IN THE FOURTH.
IT HAS BEEN A SERIES DOMINATED
BY MILWAUKEE.
GIANTS OUT IN FRONT.
AND IT IS UP TO THAIRO ESTRADA.
THIS WOULD BE NICE INSURANCE,
BIG CUT AND A MISS ON THE
CHANGEUP.
TWO IN SCORING POSITION.
BELT AT THIRD, RUF THE BIG MAN
AT SECOND.
SHAWN: LIKE YOU MENTIONED,
OUTSIDE THE FIRST INNING, SLATER
'S HOME RUN, SECOND LEAD OF THE
SERIES.
THEY HAVE NOT HAD A LEAD IN THE
FIRST THREE GAMES OF THE SERIES.
TOUGH TO PLAY FROM COME-BEHIND.
SCOTT: ESPECIALLY AGAINST THIS
TEAM.
I MEAN, I SAW A COMMENT, ONE OF
OUR YOUTUBE CREATORS --BREWERS
GOT TO BE THE TOUGHEST TEAM TO
HIT AGAINST IN THE EIGHTH AND
NINTH, CRAZY ONE-TWO PUNCH WITH
WILLIAMS AND HADER.
SHAWN: DILLY, YOU CAN ATTEST TO
THIS -- BOXBERGER AND COUSINS,
MISSING SOMEONE ELSE DOWN THERE,
THEY ARE NO JOKE.
TIM: STRICKLAND.
SHAWN: STRICKLAND, THAT GUY.
TIM: I THINK WE ARE -- DEVIN
WILLIAMS RAN INTO TROUBLE WAS
GETTING A READ ON RUF'S
APPROACH.
NEXT PITCH, CHANGEUP, STRIKE.
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT HIS APPROACH
WAS.
WAS HE TRYING TO HIT SOMETHING
RIGHT SIDE?
I THINK HE SAT ON THE CHANGEUP
DOWN ANY.
THAT IS THE ONLY WAY YOU HIT
THAT PITCH AND KEEP IT FAIR.
I THINK WE HAVE SEEN A LOT OF
TIMES A GUY THAT SELLS OUT FOR
IT IS GOING TO HIT IT 500 FEET
WAY BACK UP AWAY FOUL.
FOR HIM TO KEEP THAT FAIR, THAT
IS A GOOD PIECE OF HITTING.
SCOTT: 0-2 ON ESTRADA.
REAL TALK QUESTION, DILLY --
WHERE YOU EVER DISTRACTED BY THE
MASCOT?
TIM: RIGHT NOW I AM.
SCOTT: LUCILLE HAS BEEN PUTTING
ON A SHOW THE ENTIRE INNING.
LUCILLE IS DEVIN WILLIAMS'S
ULTIMATE WEAKNESS.
DANCING UP A STORM BEHIND HOME
PLATE.
SHAWN: GIANTS ARE PULLING OUT
ALL THE STOPS TRYING TO WIN THE
GAME.
GET THE MASCOT GOING.
SCOTT: WHATEVER WORKS.
DID THAT EVER DISTRACTED?
TIM: THE FAMOUS SAN DIEGO
CHICKEN, COACHING FIRST BASE.
I GET IT.
SHAWN: I REMEMBER PITCHING IN
MONTRÉAL, AND YOU COULD SEE
BEHIND HOME PLATE THEY HAD THIS
PLEXIGLASS WHERE PEOPLE COULD
SIT, AND THERE MASCOT USED TO
SIT DOWN THERE -- YOU COULD SEE
THERE WAS A TV BACK THERE.
IT WAS KIND OF A DISTRACTION
BECAUSE YOU COULD SEE YOURSELF
PITCHING THROUGH THE PLEXIGLASS.
BUT THE MASCOT USED TO MAKE ALL
THESE HAND GESTURES AND TRY TO
DISTRACT YOU AS A PITCHER.
YOU CAN LET IT GET TO YOU IF YOU
FOCUSED ON IT.
USUALLY PRETTY TUNNEL VISION OUT
THERE.
SCOTT: 2-2 NOW AGAINST ESTRADA.
THE LATE, GREAT TOMMY LASORDA
GOTTEN A LITTLE BRAWL WITH THE
MASCOT AT ONE POINT, WHO WAS
DISTRACTING THE SQUAD FOR THE
DODGERS BACK IN THE DAY.
SHAWN: TOMMY DESERVED IT.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: ESTRADA WITH A DEEP
DRIVE, LEFT FIELD.
OH, HE GOT ALL OF THAT ONE!
THAIRO ESTRADA FOR THREE, IT'S
5-1 SAN FRANCISCO!
MUSCLE UP, YOUNG MAN, HIS FOURTH
OF THE YEAR.
SHAWN: HE GOT THE BIG HIT FROM
DARIN RUF, AND THAT MIGHT HAVE
BEEN THE KNOCKOUT BLOW FOR
THAIRO ESTRADA.
THAT'S THE NEXT MAN UP MENTALITY
FOR THIS BALLCLUB.
THAIRO ESTRADA GETS THE STARTER
TODAY -- START TODAY, FACES A
TOUGH STARTER -- TOUGH FRIDAY IN
WILLIAMS, TO ADD TO THAT
LEAGUE-LEADING HOME RUN TOTAL
FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS.
TIM: THAT ONE HAD MORE OF THE
HORIZONTAL MOVEMENT RATHER THAN
THE DOWNWARD MOVEMENT.
SOMETIMES THAT HAPPENS.
SCOTT: A CAREER-HIGH FOUR RUNS
ALLOWED BY DEVIN WILLIAMS, THE
GIANTS WITH A LATE PUNCH.
IT'S 5-1.
>> IT HAS NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE
IN THE ALCS, WERE A CLUB HAS
FALLEN BEHIND IN THE FIRST TWO
GAMES AND THEN COME BACK TO WIN
IT.
>> COUNTY STADIUM WAS ROCKING
THAT NIGHT.
>> THE AMERICAN LEAGUE
CHAMPIONSHIP ON THE LINE.
>> 3-2, GOT THE BASES LOADED,
CECIL COOPER HITTING.
>> CECIL COOPER COMES TO THE
PLATE, OPPORTUNITY STARING HIM
IN THE FACE.
>> MR. COOPER, BASE HIT, LEFT
FIELD, A LINER!
ONE RUN HOME.
THROW COMING ON.
SLIDE, HE SAFE!
THE BREWERS LEAD, 4-3.
>> WITHOUT QUESTION, THE BIGGEST
MOMENT IN MY LIFE.
>> LISTEN TO THIS CROWD AT
COUNTY STADIUM!
BOB: AND SO IT CAME DOWN TO A
FUTURE HALL OF FAMER AGAINST A
NEWLY CHRISTENED CLOSER.
WHAT A POETIC WAY TO REACH THE
WORLD SERIES.
>> BALL LINED AT SHORT.
HE THROWS, IT'S OVER!
THE BREWERS HAVE WON THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE PENNANT!
MILWAUKEE, YOU HAVE A WORLD
SERIES!
SCOTT: WHAT AN EIGHTH-INNING FOR
SAN FRANCISCO, DARIN RUF WITH
THE R.B.I. DOUBLE TO VAULT THE
GIANTS IN FRONT, 2-1, THAN
THAIRO ESTRADA WITH A THREE RUN
TRICK OFF DEVIN WILLIAMS.
NOW HOBY MILNER IN THE GAME.
FIRST PITCH SWINGING FOR BRANDON
CRAWFORD, AND A LITTLE BLOOP
INTO KOLTEN WONG'S GLOVE.
A CAREER-HIGH FOUR RUNS ALLOWED
BY DEVIN WILLIAMS, ONLY THE
SECOND TIME HE HAS GIVEN UP A
HOME RUN AGAINST A RIGHT-HANDED
HITTER.
IT'S THAIRO ESTRADA TO SAVE THE
DAY, AND WE'LL SEE IF THE GIANTS
CAN WRAP THIS ONE UP.
>> THEY'RE A STRIKE AWAY FROM
WINNING THE WORLD SERIES.
>> GREAT FINISH TO GAME SEVEN.
>> MADISON BUMGARNER, ALL HE HAS
DONE TO HELP THE GIANTS GET
HERE.
>> IT WAS FITTING THAT HE WAS ON
THE MOUNT.
-- MOUND.
>> LOSING WASN'T AN OPTION FOR
HIM.
>> THE 2-2.
♪
>> ONE THAT POP UP ONE UP, --
WHEN THAT POP UP WENT UP, IT
SEEMED TO STAY UP THERE FOR AN
ATTORNEY.
-- AN ETERNITY.
>> I JUST CONCENTRATE, CATCH THE
BALL.
DON'T MISS IT.
DON'T GET TOO EXCITED.
>> DOWN THE LINE IN FOUL BALL --
FOUL GROUND.
>> IT WAS UNREAL.
IT WAS UNREAL.
>> GIANTS WIN!
>> AND THE GIANTS HAVE WON THE
WORLD SERIES AGAIN!
>> FOR THE THIRD TIME IN THE
LAST FIVE YEARS!
>> THE SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS ARE
THE CHAMPIONS OF THE BASEBALL
WORLD.
SHAWN: VISIT THE SAN FRANCISCO
GIANTS OFFICIAL YOUTUBE CHANNEL
TO WATCH BEHIND THE SCENES
CONTENT, HIGHLIGHTS, AND LEARN
MORE ABOUT YOUR FAVORITE
PLAYERS.
SUBSCRIBE TO YOUTUBE.COM/GIANTS,
AND DO IT TODAY SO YOU NEVER
MISS A VIDEO.
SOUNDS PRETTY COOL.
WHAT HAVE YOU GOT?
TIM: THE BREWERS YOUTUBE PAGE IS
THE BEST PLACE TO GO.
JUST VISIT YOUTUBE.COM/BREWERS
TO SUBSCRIBE.
ANYTHING YOU CAN DO --
SHAWN: ♪ I CAN DO BETTER ♪
SCOTT: WHAT A SHOWDOWN.
SHAWN: HE GOT ME ON THAT ONE.
I HAD TO REPEAT THE GIANTS
THING.
SCOTT: GIANTS FANS ARE HAPPY
AFTER THAT EIGHTH-INNING.
LAMONTE WADE JR. OUT PLAYING
LEFT FIELD NOW FOR THE GIANTS.
AND THERE IS JAKE MCGEE.
THEIR CLOSER GOING FOR NUMBER 30
ON THE SEASON, 29 SAVES SO FAR
THIS YEAR.
AND FOR ALL THIS CHANGEUPS WE'VE
SEEN FROM DEVIN WILLIAMS, YOU'RE
MOSTLY GOING TO SEE FASTBALLS
FROM THIS MAN, THE LEFT HAND OR
WITH A STANDUP SEASON THIS YEAR
FOR SAN FRANCISCO.
FIRST THREE IN THE ORDER FOR THE
BREWERS, NON-SAFE SITUATION, I
SHOULD MENTION.
SHAWN: AND HE HASN'T PITCHED IN
A WEEK, SO HE'LL BE WELL RESTED.
HE WILL PITCH MORE THAN TWO DAYS
IN A ROW.
HE IS ONLY A BACK-TO-BACK GUY.
HE NEEDS TO GET SOME WORK IN AN
UNSAFE SITUATION.
WHEN YOU'RE GOING TO SEE IS 98%
FASTBALLS.
SCOTT: WONG UP THE MIDDLE, BASE
HIT TO START THE NINTH.
HIS FIRST HIT OF THE DAY AND
URIAS WILL FOLLOW.
TIM: THAT'S WONG'S MO RIGHT
THERE, LOVES TO HIT LEFTIES.
HE'S BEEN STRUGGLING OF LATE, SO
THAT WAS A GIFT, FEELS WAY MORE
COMFORTABLE FACING LEFTIES AT
THIS MOMENT IN THE SEASON.
SHAWN: AND JAKE MCGEE WAS HAPPY
TO SEE A LEFTY IN THE BOX.
THEY'RE 10 FOR HIS LAST 60 OFF
OF HIM.
KOLTEN WONG WON THAT BATTLE.
SCOTT: SOMETHING'S GOT TO GIVE,
AND IT DID.
WONG AT FIRST.
URIAS HAD THE DOUBLE AND THE
FIRST, AND HE SCORED THE LONE
TALLY FOR MILWAUKEE TODAY.
SHAWN: U.S., CLOSER CAN THROW
ONE PITCH, IN ESSENCE, BEING A
FASTBALL AND STILL GETTING IT
DONE.
AND THE FACT IS, MCGEE HAS ONE
OF THOSE FASTBALLS.
IT PLAYS A LOT HARDER THAN IT
REALLY IS.
YOU THREW 94, 95 TO A HITTER,
AND 96, ESPECIALLY UP AT THE TOP
PART OF THE ZONE, IT HAS THAT
SPIN.
WE TALK ABOUT SPIN, WHERE IT
LOOKS LIKE IT HAS MORE CARRY,
HOLDS ITS LINE A LITTLE BIT
MORE, WHERE HITTERS AREN'T ABLE
TO GET ON TOP OF THAT PITCH.
AND THEY'LL TELL YOU THAT THE
BALL THAT COMES IN LOW WILL
CATCH THE BOTTOM PART OF THE
ZONE.
BUT WHERE HE'S EFFECTIVE IS THE
UPPER PART OF THE ZONE.
SCOTT: URIAS POPS ONE UP, BUT IT
IS GOING TO GO OUT OF PLAY.
AND URIAS ACTUALLY HOMERED OFF
MCGEE, SO HE DID GET ON TOP OF
ONE BACK IN 2018, IN AUGUST.
IT WAS HIS FOURTH MAJOR LEAGUE
GAME
THERE'S A LITTLE HISTORY.
BUT A LOT OF WORK TO DO FOR THE
BREW CREW OFFENSE HERE IN THE
NIGHT.
SHAWN: THAT'S WHY THAT SWING OF
THE BAT BY ESTRADA IS PROBABLY
GOING TO PLAY BIG HERE.
THIS IS A BREWERS CLUB THAT
DOESN'T GIVE UP.
SCOTT: TO CENTER.
IN COMES -- OH, DUBON!
THAT'S GREAT COVERAGE.
WHAT A PLAY BY MAURICIO DUBON.
WELCOME BACK TO THE BIG-LEAGUE
CLUB.
SHAWN: HE'S AN ATHLETE.
CAN PLAY ANYWHERE, DON'T LOSE
ANYTHING DEFENSIVELY.
YOU CAN PUT HIM AT SHORT, HE'LL
MAKE GREAT PLACE.
WE'VE SEEN HIM MAKE PLAYS IN
CENTER.
HE CAN MAKE UP FOR LACK OF JUMP
OR ROUTE WITH HIS ATHLETICISM
AND HIS SPEED.
GREAT PLAY RIGHT THERE.
TIM: JUST IMPRESSIVE.
HE WAS MY SHORTSTOP IN THE
BREWERS MINOR LEAGUES AND I'VE
SEEN HIM MAKE SOME AMAZING
PLACE.
NEVER IN CENTER FIELD, NEVER IN
A BIG MOMENT LIKE THAT.
JUST A FUN GUY TO WATCH PLAY.
SCOTT: SICK ATHLETE.
SHAWN: PLAYS OF THE FIELD,
TOUGHEST POSITIONS.
SCOTT: AND THE CLOSING SPEED FOR
DUBON THERE.
SHAWN: I THOUGHT OFF THE BAT IT
WAS GOING TO BE A BASE HIT
BECAUSE HE FROZE, WHICH YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO, OR FIRST STEP
BACK, BUT HE WAS ABLE TO CLOSE
THAT GROUND IN A HURRY.
SCOTT: NOW IT'S YELICH.
SHAWN: RARE SLIDER FROM JAKE
MCGEE.
HE'LL MIX THAT IN FROM TIME TO
TIME, JUST MORE OF A SHOW ME
PITCH, TRY TO GET YOU OFF THE
FASTBALL.
SCOTT: YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE
GAME POLL IS LIVE.
SHOW YOU THE OPTIONS AGAIN IN A
MOMENT.
THERE YOU GO.
SLATER, WEBB, RUF, ESTRADA.
SHAWN: IT'S GOING TO BE A TOUGH
ONE TODAY.
SCOTT: RUF HAD THE GO-AHEAD NOT,
WHICH -- KNOCK, WHICH COULD BE
THE DIFFERENCE.
ESTRADA HAD THE THREE RUN BLAST
THAT PUT THEM AWAY, OR SO YOU
WOULD THINK.
TIM: YOU HAVE TWO PICTURES IN
THE BOOTH RIGHT HERE.
SHAWN: I THAT MCGEE IS LIKE,
LET'S GIVE THAT TROPHY TO
ESTRADA.
SCOTT: WONG STAYS CLOSE AT
FIRST.
SHAWN: I WAS GOING TO SAY,
LOOKED LIKE HE WENT.
HE DID.
SCOTT: HE DID.
CHRISTIAN YELICH IS A STRIKEOUT
VICTIM.
SHAWN: RARELY DO YOU SEE JAKE
MCGEE STRIKE SOMEBODY OUT WITH A
SLIDER.
BUT AGAINST THE LEFTY YELICH,
GETS HIM TO CHASE, YELICH
THINKING THE SAME THING.
WHERE IS THAT 90% OF THE TIME
FASTBALL?
SUPPOSED TO THROW ME A FASTBALL.
SCOTT: BREWERS WON THE FIRST
THREE IN THIS FOUR-GAME SET.
NEVER TRAILED.
TODAY, FLIPPED THE SCRIPT SO FA
R.
AND LOOK WHO IT IS, THE BIRTHDAY
BOY, WILLY ADAMES, LAST CHANCE
FOR MILWAUKEE.
TIM: THIS IS THE PART OF THE
ORDER THEY WANTED UP IN THE
NINTH.
THE LEADOFF SPOT, TOP OF THE
ORDER.
THEY PUT IN WILLY ADAMES TO PLAY
SHORTSTOP IN THE LAST INNING.
HERE HE IS IN THE BIG MOMENT,
TRYING TO KEEP THINGS ALIVE.
THE BREWERS HAVE DONE THAT A
LOT.
A LOT OF COMEBACKS.
SCOTT: THIS WOULD BE QUITE THE
FEET.
SHAWN: WILLY DOESN'T NOTE TIM
DILLARD PUT HIS HELMET ON BEFORE
THE GAME.
TIM: THIS COULD BE BAD.
HOPEFULLY, NO ONE WILL TELL HIM.
SCOTT: AN ADAMES-LIKE
PERFORMANCE FROM BILLY ON THE
MIC TODAY.
RUNNER'S GOING.
AND THAT'S DOWN.
SHAWN: NO CONTEST.
SCOTT: NOPE.
DEFENSIVE INDIFFERENCE.
WHAT DOES BOB UECKER SAY ABOUT
THAT?
WHO CARES?
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
TIM: BRANDON BELT'S PLAYING
RIGHT FIELD, I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT KOLTEN
WONG.
SCOTT: IT'S ALL ON ADAMES, WHO
IS HITTING IN GARCIA'S SPOT.
ADAMES GOES TO RIGHT.
IF IT'S FAIR, IT'S GONE.
IT'S GONE!
HAPPY BIRTHDAY, WILLY ADAMES!
NUMBER 23 ON THE SEASON,T WO RUN
SHOT ENDS UP IN THE BAY.
SHAWN: WELL, THERE WAS A HOME
RUN IN THAT HELMET.
YOU CAN TAKE SOME CREDIT FOR
THAT ONE.
TIM: BEFORE I TAKE CREDIT, LET'S
SEE -- OH, MAN.
SCOTT: FOUL BALL.
SHAWN: CAN'T WAIT TO TAKE THE
CREDIT FOR THIS ONE.
SCOTT: YOU KNOW THEY'RE GOING TO
LOOK IT OVER.
WE'RE IN THE NINTH.
ORIGINALLY CALLED A HOMER,
SWITCHED AROUND AFTER THE UMP
CONFERENCE.
CRAIG COUNSEL IS HEATED.
I MEAN, WE'RE GOING TO LOOK AT
IT.
SHAWN: HE JUST GOT TOSSED.
SCOTT: IS TOSSED!
TIM: HE IS HEATED BECAUSE STU
SCHEURWATER IMMEDIATELY CALLED
IT A HOME RUN AND THEN CALLS THE
UMPIRES TO SEE IF THEY GOT IT
RIGHT.
THEN THEY DIDN'T EVEN REVIEW IT
AND THEY JUST OVERTURNED IT.
SCOTT: YOU FIGURE THEY'RE GOING
TO REVIEW IT NOW.
SHAWN: IF THEY DON'T REVIEW IT,
GABE KAPLER WOULD POUNCE ON THE
HEADSET.
SCOTT: AND THEY WILL.
COUNSELL HAS BEEN TOSSED.
YES, HOME RUN, I'M SURE.
LET'S CHAT ABOUT IT.
TIM: HE SAID FAIR, AND THEN
LET'S GET ALL THE UMPIRES.
COUNSELL'S POINT, ALL YEAR LONG,
WHEN IT COMES TO THE UMPIRING
CREW, IT FEELS LIKE THEY MAKE
THESE WEIRD CALLS AT THE BIGGEST
MOMENTS OF THE GAME.
SHAWN: YOU SEE, JUST FOUL.
YEAH, THEY GOT THE CALL WRONG,
AND THEN THEY GOT IT RIGHT.
FRUSTRATING FOR A MANAGER.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE THE UMPIRES
WILL MAKE A CALL KNOWING THEY'VE
GOT THE SECURITY BLANKET OF THE
REPLAY.
SCOTT: THAT TIM DILLARD HELMET
MAGIC NOT THERE.
YET!
2-2 TO ADAMES.
WE'LL SEE IF HE CAN DO IT AGAIN.
OPPOSITE FIELD, THAT ONE TWISTED
WELL FOUL.
ONE MORE TIME.
IT'DIDN'T TAKE LONG ONCE IT WAS
FELL.
TIM: I THINK WHAT THEY WERE
TRYING TO DETERMINE, I THINK STU
THOUGHT IT MIGHT HAVE REFLECTED
OFF IT.
RIGHT THERE, IT WAS TOUGH TO SEE
WHETHER IT HIT OFF OF IT OR
WHETHER IT WENT NEAR IT.
SCOTT: I DIDN'T WANT TO CALL IT,
BUT STU MADE ME DO IT.
THIS ONE'S ON THE GROUND.
IT'S GOING TO BE A TOUGH PLAY
FOR ESTRADA.
OF COURSE HE MAKES IT!
GAME OVER.
SHAWN: HIT A HOME RUN.
MAKE A GREAT PLAY TO END THE
GAME.
TIM: WILL THAT GET YOU A TROPHY?
SHAWN: IT MIGHT.
SCOTT: GIANTS OUT OF FIRST PLACE
FOR ABOUT 17 HOURS.
BACK IN THERE WITH THE DODGERS.
THE BREWERS TAKE THE SERIES.
THEY WIN THREE OUT OF FOUR, 82-
53 ON THE SEASON.
THE GIANTS PICKUP A W, SALVAGE A
GAME INTHIS SERIES.
WHAT A DAY.
AND IT ENDED LIKE THIS.
SHAWN: THAIRO'S PUMPED.
GOOD DAY AT THE BALLPARK FOR
THAIRO ESTRADA.
DONOVAN SOLANO, WILMER FLORES ON
THE I.L., GETS A CHANCE TO
START, HUGE HIT, NICE DEFENSE.
SCOTT: ONE OF TWO RIGHT-HANDED
HITTERS TO EVER HOMER OF DEVIN
WILLIAMS IN THE NATIONAL LEAGUE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT IT.
POSTGAME SHOW RIGHT NOW.
SCOTT: IT'S THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE, PRESENTED
BY STATE FARM, 30 MINUTES WITH
YOU, US.
SHAWN ESTES, TIM DILLARD.
WE'LL GET SOME PLAYER INTERVIEWS
TO YOU, 30 MINUTES DEDICATED TO
THE BREWERS AND THE GIANTS.
WHAT A SERIES.
IF YOU WATCH ALL FOUR, THESE ARE
COMPETITIVE BALLCLUBS.
IT HAD A PLAYOFF ATMOSPHERE.
TODAY, IT WENT TO THE GIANTS,
AND THAT'S WHY GABE KAPLER SAID
FORGET ABOUT THE DODGERS SERIES.
I'M GOING WITH LOGAN WEBB TODAY
BECAUSE WE NEED TO WIPE AWAY
THIS LOSING SKID.
SHAWN: THEY WENT TO THE STOPPER
WITH LOGAN WEBB.
TWO RUNS OR LESS, MAKE THAT 14
GAMES.
GIANTS HAVE WON 13 OF THE LAST
14 GAMES, SO THE RIGHT GUY ON
THE MOUND.
YES, YOU NEED TO WIN THE GAME
TODAY.
YES, YOU'RE TIED WITH THE
DODGERS, THE GREAT ANSWER BACK
AFTER A TOUGH THREE GAMES FOR
THIS GIANT TEAM.
TIM: AND ERIC LAUER ON THE MOUND
FOR THE BREWERS WAS OUTSTANDING,
BEST START ALL SEASON LONG
AGAINST A REALLY GOOD TEAM.
FOR THE BREWERS TO TRY TO GO TO
THE SUPERMARKET SWEEP, THAT'S
TOUGH TO DO.
I THINK IT CAME TO A CULMINATION
AGAINST DEVIN WILLIAMS IN THAT
EIGHTH INNING.
I THINK IT WAS A CULMINATION OF
THE ENTIRE SERIES OF THE GIANTS
FINALLY COMING TOGETHER WITH
SOME GOOD AT-BATS AND GETTING
GOOD SWINGS AT GOOD PITCHES.
SCOTT: I LIKE THAT.
IS THAT DILLARD PHRASE?
SUPERMARKET SWEEP?
THAT'S GOOD.
SHAWN: THAT'S THE FOUR-GAME ARE?
-- FOUR-GAMER?
SCOTT: I'VE CALLED IT SUPER
SWEEP.
BUT I LIKE SUPERMARKET BETTER.
GIANTS TAKE THIS ONE.
AND IF YOU MISSED ANYTHING, WE
ARE GOING TO GIVE YOU FULL
HIGHLIGHTS IN JUST A FEW.
WE ARE GOING TO CHAT WITH A FEW
PLAYERS POSTGAME FIRST AND GIVE
YOU A RESULT OF THE POLL,
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
BUT IT WAS AUSTIN SLATER WITH A
HOME RUN AND THEN THEY DIDN'T
SCORE FOR A WHILE.
TEXTBOOK RUMORS PITCHING WHERE
THEY SHUT DOWN THE GIANTS, AND
YOUTH THOUGHT SAN FRANCISCO
MIGHT BE IN TROUBLE, JUST DUE TO
THE FACT DEVIN WILLIAMS WAS DOWN
YESTERDAY, SO HE WAS READY TO GO
FOR TODAY.
THIS WAS ONE OF THE DEFINING
MOMENTS.
TECHNICALLY, RUF HAD THE WINNING
HIT, BUT THAIRO ESTRADA WITH THE
PADDING THAT MADE A DIFFERENCE.
SHAWN: BIG SWING OF THE BAT BY
ESTRADA.
COUNSELL SET IT UP THE WAY HE
WANTED, LAUER PITCHED SEVEN
INNINGS, LONGEST START OF HIS
EAR.
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE, THAT
HAPPENS.
I DON'T CARE HOW GOOD YOU ARE.
SOMETIMES YOU JUST GET BEAT.
HITTERS JUST BEAT YOU.
WASN'T LIKE THEY WERE MISTAKES.
HE'S BEEN DOING IT ALL YEAR
LONG.
TIM: HE WAS DOING IT IN THIS
SERIES TO.
PITCHED THE LAST GAME AGAINST
THE TWINS, GOT UP THE SECOND
DAY, GOT HOT, DID NOT COME INTO
THE GAME, SO HE WAS OFF
YESTERDAY, QUICK TURNAROUND IN
THE DAY GAME.
HIS STUFF WAS GOOD, JUST WASN'T
ENOUGH TO GET IT DONE.
SHAWN: GOT QUICK OUTS IN THE
INNING.
SCOTT: LOGAN WEBB HAD THE GOOD
STUFF.
HE IS GOING TO JOIN US NOW.
LOGAN WEBB JOINS US IN ABOUT 10
SECONDS.
GETTING THE MIC SET UP.
ONLY SEVEN STRONG TODAY FROM
LOGAN WEBB.
HE WAS DEALING THIS AFTERNOON
FOR SAN FRANCISCO, PICKED UP A
CAREER-HIGH IN TERMS OF THE
WHIFFS, TOO.
LOGAN WEBB JOINING US RIGHT NOW.
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE W FOR THE
TEAM, AND A BIG ONE IN A SERIES
AGAINST A VERY TOUGH OPPONENT IN
THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS.
HOW DO YOU EVALUATE YOUR
PERFORMANCE?
AND AS I MENTIONED, MORE WHIFFS
THAN I'VE EVER SEEN FROM YOU IN
YOUR CAREER.
LOGAN: WE JUST TRIED TO ATTACK
THE GUYS.
THEY GOT A REALLY GOOD TEAM.
WE HAD A GOOD GAME PLAN GOING
IN.
JUST TRIED TO GO OUT THERE AND
COMPETE, RIGHT?
I THINK WE REALLY NEEDED A WIN
AS A TEAM.
IT WAS AWESOME.
SCOTT: IT'S SO GOOD THAT YOU NOW
GET A LITTLE EXTRA HARDWARE THIS
YEAR.
I KNOW YOU'RE GOING FOR SOME
OTHER HARDWARE, BUT HERE COMES,
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME
TROPHY.
IT'S GOT A LITTLE WEIGHT TO IT,
BICEP CURLS.
THAT'S ALL YOU.
WE'LL HAVE YOUR NAME ENGRAVED
FOR YOUR PERFORMANCE TO A GLOBAL
AUDIENCE IN YOUTUBE, SEVEN
INNINGS, 10 STRIKEOUTS, AND
REALLY, THIS HAS BEEN STRETCHING
THE GOOD STUFF FOR A WHILE.
HAS ANYTHING BEEN DIFFERENT THAT
YOU NOTICED OR THAT YOU'VE
WORKED ON AS PART OF YOUR GAME
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS
THAT'S TAKEN YOU TO ANOTHER
LEVEL?
LOGAN: I THINK IT'S SOMETHING
KAP HAS SET A BUNCH, AND
SOMETHING I TALKED TO BUSTER AND
KIRK A LOT, JUST ATTACK THE
ZONE.
I FEEL LIKE THAT'S JUST BEEN THE
MAIN THING THE PAST 14, 15
STARTS.
SHAWN: SHAWN ESTES HERE,
CONGRATULATIONS
NICE WIN HERE.
DID YOU FEEL MORE PRESSURE
TAKING THE MOUND TODAY KNOWING
YOUR CLUB REALLY NEEDED YOU?
YOU LOST FOUR STRAIGHT.
YOU PITCHED SO WELL AS OF LATE.
DID YOU FEEL ANY ADDED PRESSURE,
ESPECIALLY AS WELL AS LAUER WAS
PITCHING TODAY?
LOGAN: NOT REALLY PRESSURE.
I THINK THE ADRENALINE WAS UP.
IT FELT LIKE A PLAYOFF TIE GAME.
-- TYPE GAME.
LIKE I SAID, THE BREWERS ARE
UNREAL AND THEY'VE GOT REALLY
GOOD STAFF, GOOD LINEUP.
I WAS JUST SUPER EXCITED TO
PITCHED TODAY, AND I THINK
WARMING UP, KNOWING THAT WE'VE
GONE THROUGH A LITTLE ROUGH
PATCH, A LITTLE MORE ADRENALINE
TODAY.
SHAWN: MAY 11, YOU PITCHED
AGAINST THE RANGERS, YOU HAD A
ROUGH FIRST INNING, LABORED, GOT
DELIBERATE, THREW A BUNCH OF
PICTURES, I BELIEVE 25.
EITHER CASALI OR BUSTER SAID TO
PICK UP YOUR PACE, ATTACKING THE
STRIKE ZONE, WORKING QUICKER.
SINCE THAT STAR IS WHEN YOU'VE
TAKEN OFF.
LOGAN: THAT WAS A BIG THING FOR
ME.
I TALKED TO WOODY ABOUT IT A
BUNCH, TOO.
THAT GUY IS MORE CRAZY THAN I AM
ABOUT THE PACE, BUT WHEN I GET
MY PACE GOING, I THINK IT JUST
GETS ME INTO THAT ATTACK MODE.
AND WHEN I DO THAT, GOOD THINGS
HAPPEN.
TIM: TIM DILLARD UP HERE WITH
THESE GUYS.
I'VE GOT A GREAT QUESTION FOR
YOU.
YOUR SLIDER AGAINST LEFTIES.
AS A RIGHT-HANDED PITCHER
THROWING AGAINST LEFTIES, YOU
DON'T ALWAYS HAVE THAT REFERENCE
POINT.
THAT WAS HUGE EARLY ON, LOCATING
THAT SLIDER DOWN AND IN.
CAN YOU TALK TO THAT A LITTLE
BIT?
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU WORK
ON?
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU COME OUT
OF THE HAT THROWING IT?
I FEEL LIKE THAT WAS THE
BUILDING BLOCK WITH GETTING GUYS
OUT WITH THE CHANGEUP.
LOGAN: I FEEL LIKE WITH SPRING
IN EARLY PARTS OF THE SEASON, I
WAS REALLY CHANGEUP HEAVY,
ESPECIALLY TO LEFTIES.
AND I THINK GUYS ARE STARTING TO
SIT ON THAT.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE WORKED ON
IN THE BULLPENS, TALKING TO
BUSTER AND CURT ABOUT IT, KIND
OF JUST LETTING IT PLAY, JUST
SETTING IT UP AND THROWING THE
CRAP OUT OF IT, LETTING IT DO
ITS THING.
IT WAS HUGE TODAY.
IT'S BEEN A HUGE PITCH I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON AND TRYING TO HONE IN
ON, SO I'M EXCITED ABOUT HOW IT
WENT TODAY.
SCOTT: LOGAN, WE LOVE THE
SLIDER, THE FRISBEE.
WE LOVE THE PACE.
KEEP IT UP.
CONGRATS ON THE W AND SEE YOU
DOWN THE LINE.
THANK YOU.
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME,
LOGAN WEBB.
PITCHERS IN THE BOOTH, YOU WIN
TODAY.
51% OF THE PIE, LOGAN WEBB IS
YOUR PLAYER OF THE GAME.
HE WAS THE STOPPER OF THE
STREAK.
MUCH MORE ON THE POSTGAME SHOW
COMING UP.
♪
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT!
>> MY GOODNESS.
GREAT BASEBALL RIGHT THERE.
>> AND THAT ONE'S GOING TO GO!
>> THAT BALL WAS CRASHED.
>> AND THIS IS GOING TO DO IT!
>> OH, MY.
>> STRIKE THREE.
>> THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
>> TALKED ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS, THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
SCOTT: BACK IN THE BOOTH, IT'S
THE POSTGAME SHOW, PRESENTED BY
STATE FARM.
THIS WAS A FUN ONE.
IT WAS TIGHT, THE BREWERS AND
THE GIANTS LOCKED IN, 1-1 FOR
QUITE A WHILE, AND THE GIANTS
PUT UP FOUR RUNS IN THE EIGHTH
INNING.
WE'LL SHOW YOU IT ALL IN JUST A
FEW, AND A THREE RUN SHOPPER
THAIRO ESTRADA.
HERE'S SOME MATH FOR YOU.
THE GIANTS PUT UP FOUR RUNS IN
THE EIGHTH.
SIX RUNS IN THE PREVIOUS 44
INNINGS, SO THE OFFENSE HAD BEEN
A BIT CHILLY, A BIT COLD.
TIM: THAT WAS THE CULMINATION OF
THE WHOLE THING.
YOU KIND OF WANT IT TO LAST, BUT
IT WAS A CULMINATION OF THE
GIANTS, FINALLY SOME OF THOSE
AT-BATS PAID OFF.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE DEVIN WILLIAMS
WAS ON THE RECEIVING END OF
THAT.
IT'S HARD TO HOLD GOOD TEAMS AT
BAY FOR LONG.
SCOTT: YOU KNOW WHAT I WAS
LAUGHING AT?
LOGAN WEBB SAID PLAYOFF FEELING.
YOU HAVEN'T PITCHED IN THE
PLAYOFFS YET.
SHAWN: WELL, IF HE DID, THIS IS
WHAT IT WOULD FEEL LIKE, MAYBE
MORE AT STAKE IN THE PLAYOFFS.
BUT SPEAKING OF THE PLAYOFFS,
THIS TEAM WILL AND AVIDLY BE A
PLAYOFF TEAM.
WILL THEY BE IN A ONE-GAME
WINNER TAKE ALL?
OR ARE THEY GOING TO GET TO PLAY
FIVE GAMES?
THE WAY THE DODGERS ARE PLAYING
RIGHT NOW, IT'S GOING TO BE
TOUGH TO WIN THIS DIVISION.
TRY TO GET AS HEALTHY AS YOU
CAN, AND WHO IS GOING TO PITCH
THAT ONE GAME?
IS MAKING THE CASE TO BE THAT
ONE GUY.
SCOTT: MIGHT BE A PIGGYBACK
OPTION, WITH WEBB AND GUZMAN.
THEY HAVE THE SAME RECORD AS THE
DODGERS, BUT THE GIANTS WIN, AND
HERE'S HOW IT HAPPENED.
WE BEGIN WITH AUSTIN SLATER,
LAST NIGHT 0-3 WITH A WALK.
THIS TIME, FIRST PITCH, GOING
AFTER IT, DEEP CENTER FIELD, AND
FORGET ABOUT IT!
AUSTIN SLATER MUSCLES UP AND THE
GIANTS ARE ON THE BOARD WITH ONE
PITCH.
IT'S THEIR FIRST LEAD OF THE
SERIES, MAKE IT 1-0 ON HIS 10TH
OF THE SEASON.
BRADLEY STRIKES OUT.
IT'S BEEN A TOUGH SEASON FOR HIM
AT THE PLATE, AND WEBB HAS K'D
NUMBER THREE.
SHAWN: THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD ONE.
SCOTT: SHAWN WILL ANSWER LATER
BECAUSE LOGAN WEBB IS OH SO
ECONOMICAL THIS AFTERNOON, NOW
NINE UP, NINE DOWN.
AND WONG IS DOWN ON STRIKES,
LOGAN WEBB'S FIFTH PUNCH OUT
ALREADY THIS AFTERNOON.
AMY G, LOGAN WEBB IS LOOKING
GOOD.
URIAS INTO THE CORNER, AND THAT
IS GOING TO PUNCH OFF THE WALL
AND TURN INTO A STANDUP DOUBLE.
A ONE OUT DOUBLE FOR URIAS.
URIAS AND YELICH ARE ON FOR
GARCIA.
2-2 ON ITS WAY.
GOT HIM!
SIX STRIKEOUTS ALREADY FOR LOGAN
WEBB.
ONTO JACE PETERSON.
CLUTCH CITY LAST NIGHT, AS WELL,
TWO OUT, TO STRIKE SINGLE.
LOFTS ONE INTO SHALLOW CENTER.
IT'S GOING TO DROP.
URIAS IS ON HIS WAY HOME.
THROW IS GOING TO CATCH YELICH
BETWEEN SECOND AND THIRD, BUT
THE BREWERS DO GET A RUN.
CRAWFORD IS GOING TO MAKE THE
TAG FOR THE OUT TO END THE
INNING, BUT THE BREWERS GET
THEIR FIRST RUN OF THE DAY, JACE
PETERSON, A LITTLE BLOOP R.B.I.
KNOCK THAT SCORES URIAS.
1-1 NOW, AND LOGAN WEBB SHAKING
HIS HEAD, SAYING A FEW THINGS
THAT MIGHT NOT BE SAFER YOUTUBE.
>> PITCH ON THE WAY, SWING AND A
MISS!
HE STRUCK HIM OUT ON THE
CHANGEUP.
SECOND TIME HE HAS PUNCHED OUT
JACKIE BRADLEY JR., SEVEN
STRIKEOUTS NOW FOR 4.2 INNINGS
RECORDED BY LOGAN WEBB.
SCOTT: CLARK'S WANT TO LEFT
FIELD AND HE FINDS SOME OPEN
SPACE.
IS GOING TO TRUCK TO SECOND.
LUKE MAILE SENDS ONE ALL THE WAY
TO THE LEFT-FIELD CORNER, A
TWO-OUT DOUBLE HERE IN THE
FOURTH.
FROZEN.
EIGHT STRIKEOUTS THIS AFTERNOON
FOR MR. WEBB, TRYING TO WIPE
AWAY THIS LOSING SKID FOR THE
GIANTS.
ONTO THE SEVENTH WE GO AND
DANIEL VOGELBACH.
INTO THE CORNER, GOOD PIECE OF
THAT ONE.
BUT, DO NOT TEST THAT ARM OF
AUSTIN SLATER.
HE DID IT.
TIM: HE WENT FOR IT.
I THINK HE COOLED OFF THE JETS
AROUND HALFWAY TO SECOND.
IN THAT MOMENT RIGHT THERE, HE
IS TRYING TO MAKE SOMETHING
HAPPEN.
SOMETIMES, IT'S BETTER TO PLAY
IT SAFE.
SCOTT: I KNOW IT'S BEEN A SLUMP
FOR THE GIANTS DEFENSE, BUT MOST
OF THE SEASON THEY HAVE BEEN
GREAT.
TYLER ROGERS OUT OF THE BULLPEN,
STRIKING OUT THE SIDE.
SHAWN: NOT REALLY A STRIKEOUT
GUY.
HE CAN GET YOU A STRIKEOUT, BUT
HE IS MORE OF A PITCH TO
CONTACT, GROUND BALL GUY.
UNBELIEVABLE THREE STRIKEOUT
INNING PERFORMANCE TODAY.
SCOTT: AND DEVIN WILLIAMS --
THIS IS RARE -- DID NOT HAVE IT.
KRIS BRYANT IS GOING TO COME ON
DOWN ON THE DARIN RUF DOUBLE TO
GRAB THE LEAD FOR SAN FRANCISCO
AND THEN EVENTUALLY, THAIRO
ESTRADA, SEE YA!
THAT'S FOR THREE.
SHAWN: AND THAT ALLOWED GIANTS
FANS TO EXHALE A LITTLE BIT MORE
BECAUSE NOW THEY HAD A FOUR RUN
LEAD INSTEAD OF JUST A ONE RUN
LEAD.
SCOTT: AND IN THAT NINE,
MAURICIO DUBON CALLED UP TODAY,
AND DUBON SAYS LOOK AT ME.
I CAN FLY.
SHAWN: TOOK A LITTLE INTERESTING
ROUTE TO THE BALL, BUT HE WAS
ABLE TO CLOSE THE GAP WITH HIS
ATHLETICISM.
SCOTT: WITHOUT WILLY ADAMES HAD
A HOME RUN.
THAT WAS A CALL THAT WAS
OVERTURNED.
AND THEN WHO ELSE?
THAIRO ESTRADA, AND THE GIANTS
PICKUP A W.
WHAT A GAME FOR US ON YOUTUBE,
GIANTS 5, BREWERS 1.
BOTH TEAMS ARE JUST AWESOME,
THREE OF THE TOP TEAMS IN THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE, BREWERS,
GIANTS, AND DODGERS GETTING IT
DONE ALL SEASON LONG.
WE'VE GOT MORE FOR YOU ON THE
POSTGAME SHOW, PRESENTED BY
STATE FARM, ANOTHER INTERVIEW
COMING YOUR WAY WITH AMY G IN
JUST A MOMENT.
♪
>> THERE'S A BASE HIT.
WONG SLAPS ONE TO LEFT.
HERE COMES CAIN.
AQUINO'S THROW TO THE PLATE AND
CAIN IS IN THERE!
R.B.I. SINGLE FOR KOLTEN WONG.
IT'S 4-2 CINCINNATI.
WONG SENDS ONE DEEP TO RIGHT,
AND SHE'S GONE!
KOLTEN WONG, TWO RUN HOME RUN.
ADD ON RUNS FOR THE BREWERS IN
THE BOTTOM OF THE EIGHTH.
IT IS 7-4 NOW.
>> HOW BIG IS THAT?
HE HAS COME UP WITH SOME HUGE
HITS, AND BIG HOME RUNS.
>> TWO OUT, TWO RUN HOME RUN FOR
KOLTEN WONG AND THREE R.B.I.'S
IN HIS LAST TWO AT-BATS.
>> HE HAS STRUCK OUT TWICE IN
THIS ONE.
THIS ONE DOWN THE RIGHT-FIELD
LINE.
THAT'S GOING TO PLATE THE RUN
FOR MILWAUKEE.
TWO RUNS COME HOME.
>> TOOK A WHILE FOR THE BREWERS
BATS TO COME ALIVE THIS SERIES,
BUT HERE THEY ARE.
KOLTEN ABLE TO WAIT BACK, SMOKES
IT DOWN THE RIGHT-FIELD LINE.
SCOTT: LIFE-SIZED CONNECT FOUR,
IT'S ALL GOING DOWN ON THE FIELD
AT ORACLE PARK AFTER THIS ONE.
BUT IT WAS A SHOW DURING THE
GAME, GIANTS 5, BREWERS 1.
DARIN RUF ACTUALLY HAD THE
GAME-WINNING SHOT.
IT WAS A DOUBLE TO MAKE IT 2-1.
AND THEY ENDED UP TACKING ON
THREE MORE THANKS TO THAIRO
ESTRADA.
WE HEARD FROM LOGAN WEBB.
LET'S HEAR WHAT DARIN RUF HAD TO
SAY WITH AMY G.
AMY: I HAVE ONE OF THE HEROES
FROM TODAY'S GAME, AND THAT'S
THE OFFENSE, DARIN, THAT GIANTS
FANS HAVE COME TO KNOW AND LOVE
THIS SEASON.
WE HAVE A LOT TO BREAKDOWN.
LET'S START WITH THE EIGHTH
INNING BECAUSE YOU WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE GO-AHEAD,
TWO OUTS, AND DOUBLE FROM YOU.
AND THE BREWERS PITCHING STAFF
IS SO STELLAR.
HOW WERE YOU ABLE TO GET TO
DEVIN WILLIAMS?
TAKE US THROUGH THAT AV'-- AB
DARIN: OBVIOUSLY, KRIS AND
BRANDON WORKING GREAT A BIT --
A.B.'S BEFORE ME.
LUCKILY, I WAS ABLE TO KEEP IT
FAIR DOWN THE LINE, AND YEAH, I
MEAN, IN THAT SITUATION, YOU TRY
TO LOOK FOR THE PITCHER IS GOING
TO GO TO IN THAT SITUATION.
LIKE I SAID, I WAS ABLE TO STAY
INSIDE, AND CREDIT TO BRANDON
AND KRIS BEFORE ME AND THEN
THAIRO HAVING A GREAT AT-BAT
BECAUSE THOSE INSURANCE RUNS ARE
ALWAYS HUGE.
AMY: IT HASN'T BEEN OFTEN THIS
SEASON THE OFFENSE IS COOLED
OFF.
WHEN YOU HAVE INNINGS LIKE THAT
AND YOU KNOW HITTING IS
CONTAGIOUS, DO YOU FEEL YOU GOT
ON TRACK A LITTLE BIT?
DARIN: HOPEFULLY.
WE LUCKILY HAVE NOT REALLY
STRUGGLED AS MUCH AS WE HAVE
THIS LITTLE STRETCH ALL YEAR, SO
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET ON TRACK.
WE'LL HAVE AN AWESOME SERIES
THIS WEEKEND.
AND YEAH, IT'LL BE FUN TO GET
THE OFFENSE ROLLING AGAIN.
AMY: BIG SERIES COMING UP, BUT
LET'S TALK ABOUT LOGAN WEBB.
AND YOU HAVE A LOT OF
PERSPECTIVE IN THIS GAME.
YOU HAVE BEEN AROUND LONG ENOUGH
TO KNOW THE ABSENT FLOWS.
AND LOGAN IS JUST LEARNING THAT.
BUT EVERYONE HAS COMMENTED ON
HIS MATURATION IN THIS GAME, AND
HIS CONFIDENCE IN THIS GAME.
HE HAD A LOT OF PRESSURE TO BE
THE STOPPER AND STOP THE SKID.
JUST YOUR THOUGHTS ON WHERE HE
IS AT IN HIS CAREER, HOW
IMPRESSIVE HE HAS BEEN THIS
SEASON.
DARIN: I DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE
THE RIGHT WORDS TO SAY HOW
IMPORTANT HOW IMPORTANT LOGAN
HAS BEEN THIS SERIES IS, BUT I
REMEMBER GOING BACK TO SPRING
TRAINING, HOW EVERYONE WAS
COMMENTING ON HOW GREAT HE
LOOKED, AND I FEEL LIKE EARLY ON
IN THE SEASON, HIM I HAVE BEEN
PUTTING TOO MUCH PRESSURE ON
HIMSELF TO GO OUT THERE, AND
DEALT WITH SOME ARM ISSUES, GOT
HIMSELF RIGHT, AND BOY, HAS HE
BEEN AMAZING FOR US THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS?
JUST SEEING, BEING ABLE TO WATCH
SOME OF THE GAMES ON TV IF I'M
NOT STARTING, THE MOVEMENT ON
HIS PITCHES, IS TO SEEN, HIS
CHANGEUP -- TWO SEAM, HIS
CHANGEUP AND HIS SLIDER, REALLY
GOOD PITCHES.
AMY: HE HAS STEPPED UP BIG TIME.
LAST QUESTION FOR YOU -- YOU
CAN'T MAKE IT ANY MORE DRAMATIC.
YOU GUYS WERE OUT OF FIRST PLACE
FOR ABOUT 17 HOURS.
DOCTORS COME IN -- DODGERS COME
IN, AND YOU ARE TIED FOR FIRST
AGAINST YOUR N.L. WEST PHOTOS.
GABE KAPLER SAID THERE IS A
SENSE OF URGENCY, BUT YOU DON'T
NEED TO PANIC.
YOU'RE IN SEPTEMBER AND THE
NUMBER OF GAMES, THEIR LIMITED.
SO, HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
HOW DO YOU NAVIGATE BETWEEN
URGENCY AND PANIC?
DARIN: WELL, KNOWING THAT YEAH,
THESE THREE GAMES ARE IMPORTANT,
BUT KNOWING, LIKE YOU SAID, WE
HAVE 20 SOME LEFT AFTER THAT, AS
WELL, OBVIOUSLY WANT TO PLATE
REALLY WELL, BE REALLY
COMPETITIVE, MAKE THE PLAYS WE
ARE SUPPOSED TO, HAVE GREAT
AT-BATS, JUST PLAY SOLID
BASEBALL.
I THINK IF WE PLAY SOLID
BASEBALL, PLAY FUNDAMENTALLY
SOUND, HAVE QUALITY AT-BATS,
WE'RE AN AMAZING TEAM.
AND THAT'S ALL YOU CAN ASK NO
MATTER WHO YOU'RE PLAYING.
AMY: YOU MAKE IT SOUND REALLY
EASY.
DARIN: IT'S NOT EASY TO DO IT,
BUT YOU HAVE TO DO IT.
AMY: I KNOW.
CONGRATULATIONS ON TODAY'S WIN,
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
SCOTT: WE APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
NOT OFTEN WILLIAMS GETS RUF'ED
UP LIKE THAT.
HOW DID HE DO?
DARIN: IT'S A -- TIM: IT'S A
GREAT PUN.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE YOU
LOOK AT HOW IT CAME ABOUT.
BUT I'M GOING TO LOOK FOR A
PITCH -- I THOUGHT IT WAS A
GREAT COMMENT.
HE WAS SURPRISED HE WAS ABLE TO
KEEP IT FAIR.
THAT WAS THE DIFFERENCE MAKER.
SCOTT: AND WE ALSO WERE
ENTERTAINED BY ROWDY TELLEZ ALL
DAY.
ROWDY, TAKE IT AWAY.
ROWDY: DOES ANYBODY WANT TO BE
FRIENDS WITH ME TODAY?
ANYBODY?
ANYBODY WANT TO BE FRIENDS WITH
ME TODAY?
YEAH.
JUST BECAUSE I GOT A MICROPHONE
DOESN'T MEAN WE CAN'T BE
FRIENDS.
ONE, TWO, ONE, TWO, CHECK,
CHECK.
I THINK BRANDON CRAWFORD HAS ONE
OF THE BEST CLEATS IN BASEBALL.
HIS CITY CONNECTORS THESE, SIC
-- CONNECT JERSEYS, SICK PAINT
JOB.
THOSE ONES LAST NIGHT WERE MADE
BY NIKE -- IF YOU GET A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF ALL-STAR GAME'S, I
GUESS NIKE MAKES THEM FOR YOU.
CHECK OUT HIS CLEATS, DUDE.
HE'S GOT A GOOD CLEAT GAME.
I TOLD HIM THAT ON FIRST
YESTERDAY.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE HUMBLE OR
NOTHING, BUT YOU GOT A TOP-FIVE
CLEAT GAME IN THE GAME.
DUDE, HIS CITY CONNECT ONCE WERE
PAINTED ON -- ONES WERE PAINTED
ON.
THAT'S FREE MARKETING FOR SOLD
BY SUR.
DID YOU GET THAT ON THE MIC?
THEY WERE SICK.
SICK.
LO-CAIN, ONE WORLD SERIES RING,
TWO HOMERS.
>> ONCE YOU PUT THAT TIME IN --
HOW THAT HELL DID YOU GET MIC'D
UP, NOT ALL PEOPLE?
YOU GOT HALF A YEAR IN THE SHOW?
ROWDY: THREE.
LET'S GET THIS RIGHT.
>> BEEN THERE, DONE THAT.
ROWDY: THIS IS A 1937 ANYMORE
WHEN YOU DEBUTED, SO LET'S
RELAX.
>> LET ME TELL YOU ALL
SOMETHING, WHAT CAMERA ARE WE
LOOKING AT?
ROWDY: I DON'T KNOW.
WE JUST GOT A MICROPHONE ON.
>> K.C. GOT MY GOOD YEARS.
ROWDY: GOOD YEARS COMING UP.
>> MILWAUKEE SHOWED ME LOVE.
ROWDY: IRA TOLD HIM.
WILLY GETS MIC'ED AND TRIES TO
SNEAK ATTACK.
WILLY, SHUT UP.
I LIKE YOU WHEN YOU WERE YOUNG.
WITH THE TIGERS, I LIKE TO. --
LIKED YOU.
>> WHERE'S THE CAMERA?
ROWDY: I DON'T KNOW WHAT CAMERA
WE ARE LOOKING AT.
>> IS MY BIRTHDAY TODAY, DOG.
THANK YOU.
ROWDY: ♪ FELIZ COMPLETE ON YES
-- CUMPLEANOS ♪
SCOTT: LOGAN WEBB, YOU'RE ALMOST
THERE.
THIS GUY DID IT IN 1916, 1917.
I WASN'T CALLING THESE GAMES.
I DEBUTED A FEW YEARS LATER.
13-1 DURING THAT STREAK.
FERDIE SCHUUP.
IS THE NAME.
TIM: I CAN'T SAY -- SHAWN: I
CAN'T SAY I'VE HEARD OF HIM.
TIM: IT'S A GREAT NAME.
SCOTT: HE WAS BORN IN 1891.
SHAWN: PLATE IN 1916-1917, SAN
FRANCISCO GIANT ERA, LOGAN WEBB
HAS THE RECORD.
YOU SAW THE GUY RIGHT BEHIND HIM
WAS KEVIN GAUSMAN, DID IT THIS
YEAR.
THAT SHOWS HOW IMPRESSIVE THOSE
GUYS HAVE BEEN AN LOGAN IS NOT
FINISHED.
TIM: IT HELPS TO HAVE A GUY WHO
WAS ALONG THE -- FOR THE RIDE
WITH YOU.
YOU LOOK AT THE BREWERS STAFF
AND THEY'RE KIND OF GOING
THROUGH THIS STORY TOGETHER, AND
YOU NEED THAT.
YOU NEED THAT FROM PITCHERS WHO
HAVE BEEN THERE.
JOHNNY CUETO HAS BEEN THERE.
IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO HAVE
SOMEBODY ALONGSIDE YOU FOR THAT
RIDE.
SCOTT: PERALTA IS BACK TOMORROW,
STARTING FROM MILWAUKEE.
A LITTLE BIT OF NEWS, POSTGAME,
THAT WE HEARD FROM CRAIG
COUNSEL.
HE SAID AVISAIL GARCIA WAS
REMOVED, PRECAUTIONARY, BUT BACK
AND HAMSTRING TIGHTNESS.
IT'S THAT TYPE OF YEAR WHERE
MILWAUKEE WAS IN CRUISE CONTROL,
SEE WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU ARE AT
FULL STRENGTH COME OCTOBER
BECAUSE THEY ARE SITTING PRETTY
IN THE DIVISION.
TIM: THEY ARE, AND THEY HAVE
THIS ROOM TO BE PATIENT WITH
GUYS AND MAKE SURE THEY ARE
COMPLETELY HEALTHY BEFORE
RUNNING THEM BACK OUT THERE FOR
THE DEEP PLEDGE.
-- PLUNGE.
HE HAS PLAYED MORE GAMES THAN
ANYONE ELSE FOR THE MILWAUKEE
BREWERS.
TO GET HIM SOME REST IS THE GOOD
THING.
SCOTT: WE ARE GOING TO GO ON THE
FIELD AND PLAY SOME GAMES.
SEEMS LIKE A GOOD TIME.
DO THEY DO THIS AFTER ALL THE
GAMES?
THAT AND THE SIEGEL'S TAKING
OVER AT ORACLE PARK.
THIS WAS A FUN ONE.
I WANT TO GIVE A SPECIAL SHOUT
OUT TO OUR PRODUCER, MICHAEL
TRAINER, AND HIS WIFE, ALEXIS.
THEY WELCOMED A BABY GIRL, BORN
AUGUST 22, AUBREY ADDISON
TRAINOR.
WELCOME TO THE WORLD.
WE SHARE A BIRTHDAY, AUGUST 22.
YOU'RE A LEO.
YOU MIGHT NOT COMPREHEND THAT.
THIS WAS AN ABSOLUTE BLAST.
THANK YOU GUYS.
WE APPRECIATE EVERYONE WATCHING
WORLDWIDE ON YOUTUBE.
AND WE DO THIS EVERY WEEK ON
YOUTUBE, GLOBALLY.
THIS ONE IS A FINAL.
THE RIVERS FALL TO THE GIANTS.
THEY DO TAKE -- THE BREWERS FALL
TO THE GIANTS.
THEY DO TAKE THE SERIES, THOUGH.
WE HAVE THE FIRST PLACE ASTROS
IN THE A.L. WEST HOSTING A PESKY
DIVISION RIVAL, THE SEATTLE
MARINERS.
THE PREGAME SHOW WILL START
ROLLING OUT 1:30 EASTERN.
FOR THE GREATS TODAY, TIM
DILLARD, SHAWN ESTES, AMY G, OUR
CREW AT WEST, I'M SCOTT BRAUN
LOGGING OUT FOR NOW.
GREAT ONE TODAY.
SEE YOU NEXT TIME ON YOUTUBE.
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]